[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
today for This Little Light Studios live
I'm Keith that Weiler part of the team
here and we are so thankful that you
guys can be a part of us today it's
giving Tuesday and for giving Tuesday we
decided to do an all-day live and
there's a couple of reasons for that one
of those reasons is there's a lot of
things in here we want to just simply
give back we can give back an
information give back in sneak peeks
behind the scenes
give back in some special little
giveaways that we have going on so
that's one reason the second reason is
we really want to bring awareness to one
of our needs that were were really
aiming at for this year
and it's a big need
but we're just going to put it out there
and that need is we you know we we had
this studio that you guys helped us
purchase it's been an absolute blessing
we are so thankful to be able to work
here but it's not 100 done once you have
a nice building like this you still have
to retrofit it and so in the back which
you're probably going to see a little
bit of later we have a warehouse
essentially is what it is it's a it's
just a big open space and in order for
us to do production work well we
realized we need to enclose some of that
big space for a couple of reasons one is
sound and another reason is heating and
cooling because when you have 20 plus
foot high ceilings and just a big open
40 by 50 space it is not very cost
effective to heat and cool that so nor
is it easy to rig lights or anything
like that so we would like to to really
put a box within the box so to speak and
and really make a proper studio and to
do that it takes money unfortunately and
so we are trying to raise 250
000 for that project we're going to call
that phase two of what we're doing here
we've already passed phase one which was
just getting this building in the first
place so we could help spread our team
out and and grow properly so this is
phase two and then there will be a phase
three but we're going to save that for a
little bit later so just to give you
guys a little bit of heads up on what's
going on today can I give you a preview
in the schedule I'm going to grab mine
here and take a a bit of a peek we're
going to start just after this with a
morning devotional share something with
you that's on my heart
um two after that we are going to do a
bit of a meet the teens segment and this
is going to be you know 10 15 minutes or
so of each one of us sitting down and
you as viewers getting to know us a
little bit better probably more
specifically like how did we get
involved in this work in the first place
as you can imagine we have come from
various backgrounds and so
um you know you're going to find out a
little bit about each one of the team
members here after that we're going to
take a look at some past projects we're
going to sprinkle in some testimonies
throughout the day some of you have sent
testimonies in so thank you for that the
ones that we were able to get in will
get in and if not we'll probably find
another way to work them in so I'm sorry
if you don't see it today
we're going to talk about you know what
we're doing in our Spanish and
international Channel we're going to
talk about how we've been growing on
social media that's really been a
fascinating year there
and so we're going to do some team q a
we you guys have sent us questions in
and so we're going to try to answer some
of those questions and like a lot of
what we do sometimes that's just going
to be off the cuff off the top of our
heads we haven't necessarily prepared a
bunch of answers we like to do things
unscripted because it'd be we believe
that it comes off very real very organic
and we want to be that way with all of
you
have some a donor giveaway that's a very
exciting giveaway we're going to be
talking about later we're going to have
a special segment about the Black
Panther video that we did with kindy
she's going to take you behind the
scenes break some of that down maybe
answer some of those questions
and we have a couple other exciting
announcements that we're going to be
doing over the next several weeks and so
Scotty I'll talk about those later I
probably will join him during that time
but for the time being why don't we get
into our devotional thought and to do
that I'm going to open with prayer and
then we will get started so let's pray
Heavenly Father we just ask a special
blessing on those who join us today and
we ask that you would pour your spirit
upon them we ask that as we contemplate
things from your word that you would
help guide our minds and that today can
be a blessing to anybody who joins not
just from the devotional thought but as
they look and see how you are growing
this ministry and changing the lives of
others and we thank you for that in
Jesus name amen
just want to start out with a story it
was 1969 in past Christian Mississippi a
group of people were gathering to have a
hurricane party in the face of a storm
that was named Camille the wind was
howling outside the Posh risholu
Apartments when police chief Jerry
Peralta pulled up sometime after Dark
and facing the beach less than 250 feet
from the surf the apartments were
directly in the line of danger
a man with a drink in his hand came out
of the second floor balcony and waved
Peralta yelled up you all need to clear
out of here as quickly as you can the
storm is getting worse
but as others joined the man on the
balcony they just laughed at Peralta's
order to leave
This Is My Land one of them yelled back
if you want me off you'll have to arrest
me
Peralta didn't arrest anyone but he
wasn't able to persuade them to leave
either
he wrote down the names of the next of
Ken of the 20 or so people who gathered
there to party through the storm
they laughed as he took their names they
had been warned but they had no
intention of leaving
it was about 10 15 p.m when the front
wall of the storm came ashore
scientists clocked Camille's wind speed
at more than 190 miles per hour gusting
to 230 miles per hour
raindrops hit with the force of bullets
and waves off the Gulf Coast crested
between 22 and 28 feet high
news reports later showed that the worst
damage came at the little cell
settlement
of motels Go-Go bars and gambling houses
known as past Christian Mississippi
where 20 people were killed at a
hurricane party in the Richelieu
Apartments
nothing was left out of that three-story
structure but the foundation the only
Survivor was a five-year-old boy found
clinging to a mattress the following day
and prior to the hurricane they would
have deemed their surrounding Paradise
everyone was happy
having a good time
but something had happened something
that hadn't been warned about and ins or
something that had been warned about and
instead of listening to the instructions
of the one who could foresee the danger
they did what pleased themselves
like the people in the apartments Eve
did not see the danger instead of
heeding the warnings of the one who knew
the consequences she pleased herself
Genesis 3 6 tells us so when the woman
saw that the tree was good for food and
that it was pleasant to the eyes and a
tree desirable to make one wise she took
of its fruit and she ate and she also
gave to her husband with her and and he
ate
you see Eve bought into a much more
Sinister deception than God is keeping
something from you
she was made to believe that God had a
good gift which he would not give
and then in an instant they went from
having every need supplied to a newfound
knowledge that only told them they now
had a need which could not be filled
you might say they went from being rich
increased with goods and in need of
nothing
to wretched miserable poor blind
and naked
Genesis 3 10 tells us they were afraid
it reads this way so he said I heard
your voice in the garden and I was
afraid because I was naked and I hid
myself
picture someone that you love and the
next time you go to give them a hug they
cower back in fear screaming don't hit
me
and you start to get a small taste of
what God was experiencing
and it's here that we learn that hurt
people hurt people
the one who provided everything gets
blamed for everything
Adam blamed God for God's great gift of
Eve to him
likely confused and hurt by that Eve
carefully leaves herself out her gift
not appreciated and blames the serpent
the serpent cursed has succeeded in
Breaking the relation between God and
man and the relationship between man and
man in one Fell Swoop
he had destroyed the perfect harmony in
God's living example of marriage which
would testify a picture of his love
you know it's one thing to offer help to
someone you love
it's another thing to pursue someone you
love who blames you for everything
doesn't trust you runs away from you
when you try to go near them on their
way to certain death when you're the
only one who can save their life
The Dilemma is that of a broken
relationship
how do you fix that well if you're a man
you can't if we could we wouldn't be in
the position we find ourselves in today
and if you're God you can
but it would require another gift a gift
that would prove God would not withhold
any good gift
and since nothing could be found with
more goodness than himself
he would become the gift
my children have told me they need many
things which are merely a want and I
have a response they have heard many
times need is a strong word
the Bible speaks to the great need of
man in a word Jesus and Jesus tells
sinners like you and I to do something
he tells us to repent in Mark 2 17 it
says this when Jesus heard it he said to
them those who are well have no need of
a physician but those who are sick I did
not come to call the righteous but
Sinners to repentance
in Revelation 3 19 says this as many as
I love I rebuke and chasten be zealous
therefore and repent
but even repentance is not something we
can do ourselves
Romans 2 4 puts it this way or do you
despise The Riches of his goodness
forbearance and long-suffering not
knowing that the goodness of God leads
you to repentance
what do Sinners need they need
repentance but before they repent they
need a reason and that reason is the
gospel the gospel is what corrects our
understanding about the love of God and
turns us around so that we can stop
running from him
you see the atoning sacrifice of God is
not an appeasement offering and it
wasn't done to make God love you more it
was done because God couldn't love you
more
it was a gift
The Ultimate Gift which God would not
hold back to show his love for man
First John 3 1 says behold what manner
of love the father has bestowed upon us
that we should be called the sons of God
how strong is that love Romans 8 38 and
39 says it this way for I am persuaded
that neither death nor life nor angels
nor principalities nor powers nor things
present nor things to come nor height
nor depth nor any other created things
shall be able to separate us from the
love of God which is in Christ Jesus our
lord
he could have given up on us
but he didn't
second Peter 3 9 says the Lord is not
slack concerning his promise as some
count slackness but is long-suffering
toward us not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance
God doesn't want to let go of a single
person on this planet he will wait as
long as it takes if it means it will
save another soul
so what's your condition today
are you right with God
can you identify with the words of
Isaiah 6 5 it says this you meet him he
rejoices and does righteousness who
remembers you in your ways you are
indeed angry for we have sinned in these
ways we continue and we need to be saved
we all need to be saved but don't get
the wrong idea here God is not angry at
you God is angry because sin is killing
his children
some of whom he will lose forever you
occupy a place in God's heart which
cannot be filled by anyone else
and one of the greatest mistakes of
humanity
is that we let
physical appearance influence character
judgment
did you know that the Bible describes
Satan as a being perfect in Beauty it
goes on in detail in passages like
Isaiah 14 and the Ezekiel 28 to describe
this
but if you contrast that I want you to
take some time today and read Isaiah 53
and see Jesus for what he truly is
the Bible describes him not as one who
is physically beautiful and yet he is a
picture of the most attractive person we
have ever seen
the sacrifice that he made
infinite
how do you respond to that
first John 4 19 says we love him
because he first loved us
and I want to close with this story
it said that Cyrus the founder of the
Persian Empire once had captured a
prince and his family
and when they came before him the
Monarch asked the prisoner what will you
give me
if I release you
the half of my wealth was his reply
and if I release your children
everything that I possess
and if I release your wife
badges your majesty
I will give you myself
Cyrus was so moved by his devotion that
he freed them all
and they returned home or while they
were returning home actually the prince
said to his wife wasn't Cyrus a handsome
man
and with a deep
love
for her husband
she said to him
I didn't notice
I could only keep my eyes on you
the one who was willing to give himself
for me
and as you think about or contemplate
the great love and sacrifice that was
provided
for your great need and my great need
let's turn around
back to Jesus and with repentant Hearts
let us Proclaim these words
I could only keep my eyes on you
the one who is willing to give himself
for me
we're going to close that
um
thought with prayer
I hope that you will truly give your all
to Jesus
and I hope that you will truly surrender
to him that's why we do what we do here
and then after I get done praying in a
few moments
Scotty's going to join me and we're
going to find out a little bit about his
story but let's pray
Heavenly Father we are so grateful for
how you have provided
and
you have given so much as we look at
that how can we respond
to that with anything but great love
I pray that everyone that's watching
will surrender their hearts to you and
we ask it in Jesus name
amen
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
foreign
to do something that lets someone know
you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
help them every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
family I am Julius Erving market and I'm
from iligan City Philippines I thank God
for the ministry that he has blessed you
with
me my wife and my extended family
enjoyed learning from you every week as
you provide thought-provoking relevant
and christ-centered content
which motivate us to study the Bible for
ourselves pray fervently and by God's
grace bring Jesus Christ loving Ministry
into our daily lives
we admire how you consistently refer to
the Bible for solid principles when
whatever issue that you discussed
topics which are not usually discussed
freely in the church
as well as how we can deal with this
sensitive issues through practical means
and be Overcomers
Happy Thanksgiving doll from the
producers designers cameraman and anyone
whom we usually cannot see a special
mention to Keith for accepting our
invitation as our speaker last year 2020
in our ay program
and also my wife says hi to Candy
Brittany Scott and Mikey and Alex
also the the weekly guest in sharing
their expertise and experiences on those
topics
uh we may not be able to see each other
in person here on Earth but I pray that
with God's grace we will be able to see
each other in heaven
we keep you in our thoughts and prayers
at all times
and I am actually wearing my weakness
right now
Maranatha
[Music]
foreign
y well we are back with a segment of
Meet the team and we're going to start
from the top down our oldest uh standing
member like he's been with the ministry
the longest and it's because it started
with him but he is actually the oldest
here hey we're not going to tell you how
old
um
I've been with the ministry the second
longest and I'm not the second youngest
here we'll let you guys figure that out
who do you think is older than me maybe
you can put that in the comments below
and we'll have a little fun with that
but Scotty uh your your story is a
little different than the rest of us
because it started with you
how did that you know or this has been
extremely neat to see the ministry grow
into what it's turning into
um it's just nothing that we ever sat
down in the very beginning and said hey
let's do this let's start a Ministry
it's just something that God really sort
of opened this door and we walked
through it and then open this door and
we walk through it
um so for those of you that are watching
that that maybe don't know the history
of even how this whole thing started
um I took film studies in college and
with an aspiration of ending up in Los
Angeles working in the film and
television industry and
um I ended up injecting out of school
and just going down there and jumping in
and at the time that I ended up down
there
um it was uh right at the the dawn of
reality television
um that was kind of booming everybody
thought it was gonna like I come and go
and you know not stick around for very
long and so it was really easy to get a
job we all jumped into different various
uh reality television shows and uh
that's probably perhaps where my passion
for documentary filmmaking came from how
long did it take between the time that
you moved down to La before you were
working in the entertainment industry so
everybody in Los Angeles uh I think
there's six million or so people that
that are in there and I would probably
bet five and a half million of them are
trying to get into that industry when
you go fill up gas at the gas tank or
the gas pump uh you know the the
attendant is writing the script I mean
it's just like everybody's involved in
it right
um and so I I initially went down there
with the intention of actually jumping
into the acting side of this business
business so I got an agent started going
on auditions and quickly found that was
not gonna happen uh was an awful actor
praise God
and my brother who also
um went to film school he was a year
ahead of me in school he also helped
start this ministry
um Tom he ended up going down there and
working on a television show called
BattleBots do you remember this TV show
I know maybe it was like robots that
they would battle against each other and
if your robot could destroy somebody
else's robot well he did specialty
camera and he was kind of the first out
of the bar our group to get a job and so
I got a job from working through him so
it was a couple years before I started
working behind the camera I chased the
front of the camera thing for about six
years okay that's cool
um
so
when you got down there you you had been
raised in a Christian home
like went through Christian Schools like
all the way like even went to a
Christian College started out
how long before your Christianity more
or less went by the wayside
so I grew up with an incredible amount
of knowledge my parents were were very
invested into the church and there
wasn't a weekend that I didn't miss
going to church sure and uh I actually
only spent one year in a public school
system the rest of the the time even
College was all private based and so I
had a lot of of religious understanding
it was about six months from the time
that I went down there and I just
started hanging out with people who
really don't care about religion and I
surrounded myself with people that
didn't really have a connection to it
and so real fast uh you know Hollywood
is as much of who you know who you can
meet who you can get involved with
um and so really I I recognized that
really early and then began to really
associate with people that really didn't
have an interest in god wow well that's
not
why we're here today
at some point that flicked
and you know you went from going being
in Christianity going to Hollywood
Christianity going by the wayside to
coming back kind of a prodigal son type
experience so what what opened your eyes
or flipped you around so
um if if I can really think back over my
experience
um there was not a moment that I
remember God leaving me he was
constantly trying to knock on the door
of my heart it was if I think back on my
experience it was really me that was
holding my hand up it was like no God I
don't want you right now I don't need
you there wasn't a rejection so to say
like I never came to the place where I
was like okay God doesn't exist right
right right which I don't even know if
that's worse like being involved in
worldliness knowing the truth but that's
that's my experience and my brother had
his high school reunion come up at our
little Christian School that we both
grew up at and he invited me to go he
was one grade ahead of me in school and
I didn't want to go but I agreed and I
had a conversion at that experience and
really started thinking like what am I
doing like I know this stuff is real and
it was such a a sort of Awakening God
really opened my eyes that that I began
to look at the world around me and just
began to recognize the Warfare around me
um I was very much interested in
filmmaking because that's what I wanted
to do and be so I was a collector of
movies I watched movies I mean where I
spent my time was at the theaters on the
weekends there was no reason why I
didn't you know I wasn't being careful
because of the ratings or anything I
just literally watched everything there
was
um and uh I had a experience where I
kind of really started turning my heart
back towards God and saying Lord show me
I want to see you in and I know you're
real and he started showing up very real
in my life it was just experience after
experience
um he started sending people that would
come and start having religious
conversations with me
um and I began to have a relationship
back with God and uh I told him like
Lord I want to do something for you uh I
feel like I've been living the last 10
years of my life for myself and all of a
sudden when I opened my heart to God and
said you know whatever you ask of me I
will do this my phone rang and it was a
youth pastor that had asked me to come
and talk at a youth rally and give a
talk about my experience being in
Hollywood but more specifically he was
interested in sort of like using
Hollywood to try and make a spiritual
point
kind of like if if you were to make a
point with like using Superman and
sayings like Jesus yeah and to be honest
that's what I would have done uh I was
very much so pro-hollywood I I this is
what I wanted to do for a living so I
was never thinking any negative thoughts
towards it whatsoever and I sat down and
I really started praying Lord what do
you want me to say I'm definitely scared
to stand up in front of a group and tell
them any religious thoughts in my mind
and
um and all of a sudden
um I put a movie in from the early 2000s
that was a film that I really liked it
was called Fight Club it was a Brad Pitt
and Edward Norton and I was just putting
it in for inspiration and in the middle
of the movie there was this scene like a
real emotional scene where Brad Pitt
slaps Edward Norton and he says you have
to consider the possibility that God
does not like you in fact God hates you
in all probability he doesn't want you
we don't need God we don't need
salvation we don't need Redemption and
he goes on and he says this whole
monologue about how much God hates me
right I put it on pause and I went how
is it possible that I just watched this
movie a bunch of times I mean I
literally could quote a lot of the movie
but I did not recognize that that scene
that they just told me God hated me
and it was from that premise that I said
well what else uh what's going on inside
the brain when you watch TV and as I
started kind of really looking and
researching it was like all of a sudden
I I was shocked at how the mind works
and and the way that the brain
interprets information and how you can
let something come into your brain but
you don't consciously think about it at
the time and so um it was from that
premise that that uh all of a sudden I
think God opened my eyes to the
spiritual warfare that was that was
permeate in Hollywood
so
did you ever expect to have
a team or a Ministry or be doing that
like I mean you were asked to get a talk
did you ever expect that anything would
grow out of that and you'd be doing that
the rest of your life not in a million
years not in a million years in fact I
made very good money in uh Hollywood
doing what I was doing I had a career
path that would have you know been quite
successful down the way and
um but I really had this passion and I
really said Lord I I want to serve you
and I and I and I came to this place
where I realized even the even the edge
of Hollywood that I was working on I was
working on things that were promoting
ungodly things and as I began to build a
relationship with him I really came to
this Crossroads and it was like am I
gonna really serve God with all my heart
and so in the very beginning of the
ministry
um we would actually go around we would
give this seminar on sort of the effect
Hollywood was having on your on your
brain but then I would actually go back
to oh would I go back to work for a
whole year I traveled around and spoke
at churches and then would go back and
work in the weekdays I spent all week
long
um working on different sets did you
feel a conflict of interest absolutely
absolutely and I tried to rationalize it
like I'm not the guy that's coming up
with the content I'm just working here
and as I began to sort of like
emotionally eject out of the work
um it was interesting because I think
the devil just realized he was losing me
and the jobs became more money and more
ridiculous tasks for for you know like
why would you pay me that much money to
do that you could pay you know somebody
a quarter of the cost to do this over
here and so um I think the devil was
just really trying to say look how easy
I can make it and God was just showing
me time and time again even if you're
not the guy that's like coming up with
the concept you're still part of their
entity they're still part of their army
and um that's where I really began to
say okay Lord let's do this I will do it
full-heartedly and at this time it was
just myself my brother and a childhood
best friend of mine and the three of us
decided to all leave our jobs and and we
moved back up to Northern California and
started working in the basement of a
school and that's where this ministry
began I've been in a couple basements
I've been in a couple basements yes so
praise God this is amazing it's not a
basement because this is not a basement
this is actually the first time in Let's
see we started working
um in a Ministry capacity maybe
2007-2008 so so by the time we really
Incorporated it was about 2009 that was
when we first officially said we're part
of a Ministry and and whatnot
um but uh we've never had a home and
this is the first home we've ever had
thank you to all the awesome donors uh I
know this is like giving Tuesday but we
are thanking you for being generous to
our ministry and affording us this
opportunity because we have a team now
and it is really neat what this team is
capable of I'm sure you'll see a little
bit more of that today it's amazing
um in all that time I think little life
has only paid rent one year yeah it is
pretty amazing God had provided a space
that for whatever like the Ministries or
the school it was a non-profit as well
so they were like you know we're
non-profit we don't need to make money
from this you're welcome to use the
space we're not using it
um and uh God just really afforded us
this beautiful opportunity to put our
energy in fine finances into the people
and it's really grown a neat team
that's amazing it's amazing story and I
know it always excites people to hear
that it's it's interesting when you know
somebody who's been in the industry and
we've heard a lot of stories from this
guy and uh so as we're uh
you know as we've talked a lot some of
the things he's told me it's just kind
of like I can't believe that especially
about that person or that person like
really that really went on so it's been
pretty crazy and Scotty's been a great
person to work with and so thank you for
sharing your story and they are a little
bit of your story it's much longer
there's places on the internet you can
find it so if you want to check out more
of his story I'm sure if you dig in our
YouTube channel you can find more of his
testimony there and get a much longer
piece of that but we're going to
transition to another story because
we're going through different people's
stories
um today and so the next one I guess
gets to be mine I have the second
longest longevity here and now
um with little light so yeah
right no no not the second order no
they're supposed to guess who that is
yes or the second oldest person it's not
me yeah I used to be
Keith has a cool story he's been here a
long time how long you been at little
light like over 10 years now over 10
years the ministry's only lasted about
12 years so so if you go from like the
official non-profit status standpoint
yeah that was 2009 I came on board in
2013. wow so the ministry has been going
a while I've been going a while wow I
remember when we had our 10 year and
like now we're not too far from our 15
really wow so did you ever picture
yourself being a Ministry I don't know
I've heard your story but go back to
your your raising up are you raising a
Christian home I was raising a Christian
home
um raising a Christian Home unlike
Scotty I didn't go to Christian Schools
like my whole life I've been um like you
product public school right yeah
I went to a Christian School like maybe
for a couple of months here and there
you know little sprinklings but
um usually my parents thought that it
was kind of behind in their education so
I wouldn't mind up putting us back in a
public school yet I actually did have a
desire to work in Ministry from the time
I was baptized at 10. wow and
I I had told God at 11 years old that I
wanted to be an evangelist
and I didn't know what that would look
like or where that would go
you know as as reality takes takes hold
though you you know you grow up you go
to school
um my family basically
left the church when I was 14 years old
we didn't go to any church any reason
for anything they started out pretty
solid in church yeah very steady and
then like at 14 dad had an argument with
the pastor everybody peace out and then
from 14 to 21 like nothing there is no I
mean yeah I mean we we would pray in our
meals and stuff like that kind of more
traditional yeah kind of thing yeah was
it really like a lot of heavy Christian
influence but I would say during that
time is where a lot of media influence
started coming into my life and so where
I didn't go to Hollywood or any film
studies or anything like that
I remember watching a ton of stuff what
was your favorite genre of stuff do you
want oh yeah like action adventure you
know like James Bond kind of stuff oh
yeah he made a video on James Bond you
can watch he did a video on 007 yeah
very so
yeah that was kind of my kind of my
thing but
um eventually god
um
you know
broke back into our our family the
pastor from the church we were going to
he left new one came in he came and
visited our home and it's funny he was
from South Africa and the only reason I
knew that is from watching so many
movies oh yeah yeah because he I
recognized the accent and I was like and
I knew it from Lethal Weapon uh yeah
I'll Lethal Weapon too I think it was
because they had South Africans in there
and so I recognized the accent I'm like
that guy's from South Africa like a
Caucasian yeah yeah I was just that we
get the idea of everybody from Africa's
um
a lot of light-skinned people so I knew
that told my parents they were kind of
intrigued and then
I don't know we started going back to
church and that was I was like did the
church reach out to you guys
not that I knew of but you know I found
like the 14 15 16 year old kid like yeah
they're not talking to me yeah you know
they would have been trying to talk to
my parents or calling that's what I mean
that the church say Hey you haven't
noticed you back in church there's
probably one or two people that called
or something like that to try and make
them I just think that's important you
know if you see somebody kind of not
participating anymore reach out to them
they might not be in a place where they
want to respond at that moment but it
does feel good to have to know that the
church has reached out to you I've heard
this story a lot where I left the church
and nobody even checked on me the I
remember the guy that came with the
pastor and that's always kind of held a
little bit of a special place in my
heart because
he took the time out he didn't have to
come you know he didn't have to come
with him but he did come so I thought
that was uh important and needed yeah so
14 to 21 like nothing
um and then about that time I mean I had
started school late I didn't think I was
going to school at all I told my parents
I was going to college so what did you
go good job
and they're like you're gonna go to
school later that to me was a miracle
because
uh I'll come from money
um you know my parents didn't have a way
to help me with college or anything and
so when I went to school they were like
you're gonna have to figure it out well
I don't have a job I have no money I'm
told I need to go to school and I didn't
do well in standardized testing first
time around so it was like
what am I going to do so I showed up at
registration
and
I had to retake in one of the
standardized tests like the ACT is what
they do in the midwest it's like the SAT
but not
and I'd retaken it to improve my score
I got a score I didn't know really if it
was good or bad or anything but when I
went down there they took registration
or orientation they separated everybody
into different groups and I wound up in
a small group
and they were like making me pick out
classes and all this kind of stuff and
I'm like like kind of stressed out
because like I'm supposed to pick all
these classes I don't even know how I'm
going to pay for it and I think they
probably could see the like clueless
look on my face one of the
um he was a teacher there Professor
there he came over and he's like do you
know why you're here I was like no way
and uh he's like no I mean like while
you're in this room I was like no I
don't know why I'm in this room I mean
I'm supposed to register a classic or
something he's like you know he's like
you're in this room because everybody in
here scored top 10 percent on
standardized testing in this school
and
um he's like do you have like your like
how did you do in in high school like
your grades and stuff well I did High
School I did fine
and so I was like okay well if that was
your grades and based on what you got on
the test and he's like what place did
you graduate in your class so I told him
and he was like
I think we can put you on a full ride
scholarship whoa and I was like
you know I have been going to church or
anything you know it's like 19 I think
that time and none of this other stuff
had even happened and I I could look
back and say wow God was really working
in my life then and I was like Act of
Faith to help me in a in a place where I
needed help wow anyway about 21 is
or so it's about the time I met my wife
she challenged me on some things
spiritually I met some people at school
that were were helping me spiritually
and started taking me to campus meetings
that were Christian and that felt pretty
good because I was felt like I was
starting to get fed and get Fellowship
and I've met some other people and you
know next thing you know God is just
like surrounding me with people who are
either feeding me or challenging me
spiritually that's awesome and it was
pretty awesome so
yeah I went through that
um got my degree
took me a long time because I just kept
kind of tacking on more and got married
to this girl who challenged me I didn't
know at the time we were going to get
married but we did and what I liked
about her is here she was at a secular
school she was a strong Christian you
know I knew that and I knew she was a
seeker of Truth and so we actually wound
up helping each other and so
um she'll be in here later today and
probably try to avoid the camera I like
to play yeah
right all these are available at
lightwear dot shop really uh helps us
out and we're sponsored we get to wear
them all the time okay so you and your
wife are now in Ministry together in the
same Ministry how did little light come
into the picture yeah so I remember
watching uh I was really on social media
a lot a lot of Facebook Farmville kind
of stuff and I remember in my Facebook
feed a video got posted of Scotty at
AFCO which is a college of evangelism he
did a series there and I watched the
video and in my heart I knew like those
things weren't good for me but I didn't
feel like I had a good reason like
movies and things yeah and you know I'd
done some gaming and things like that
too and so when I saw the video I was
like
that's the reason why like I recognized
that was the reason why like I now had a
Biblical foundation and that's what a
lot of us are kind of looking for like
you can tell me no no no but unless you
know why you're really you're not gonna
change you you almost want to like I
know with younger kids like if you tell
them no you can't do that Sparks and
interest the Rebellion what are you
trying to keep from me yeah
so
um I I watched the other videos in that
series and then
um I remember uh one of the elders at
our church or deacons or something he
invited little light to come out they
came out it was branded heard him talk I
tried to kind of connect with Brandon it
worked okay not not too well and then
um
and then one day I was I was working in
agricultural chemistry that was part of
you know my degree was in chemistry so I
was working at agricultural chemistry
and
the day I switched positions in my
company I remember was January 15.
and I just called the office at little
light I was like I just I have to call
them I need to talk to somebody
so I called somebody answered the phone
and he was like yeah you probably ought
to talk to Scotty so they gave me his
cell phone or something or his home
phone I called he answered and I just
like spewed out my story and my heart
for like probably an hour
and at the end I was like does that
sound crazy and he was like nope wow and
so
at that point it was kind of like you
know we had started a dialogue but he
was like well what do you do he's like
do you know how to edit video do
Graphics anything like that I was like
no
I just felt like I was a fit I don't
know what I would do the way I looked at
it is like you guys are the
professionals and I'll just do whatever
like all the research the mail the
shipping stuff or whatever needs to be
done
and so
um
we I don't know we just kept talking and
eventually uh we wound up
I wound up helping him with their
website and
I don't know we just kind of had a
working relationship and a distance and
I was answering started to answer some
of the emails and things like that for
him so they wouldn't have to take time
doing that yeah and
and then I remember
um
it was like 2013 they invited it's like
early 20 or no it was mid it was July in
2012. invited me out to do like a
camping trip with them and I went out to
the camping trip we talked
and
clearly I knew on my end God was like
really prouding me to work with the
ministry and I basically told God look
the only way that's going to happen is
you have to sell my house and by that
time life was transforming us very
active in church at a young family a
full-time job
and I was like I don't have time to
advertise I have no
um I have you know I don't know what am
I I can't call A realtor I don't know a
realtor I don't even I can't even put an
ad in the Thrifty Nickel
so so the time you were just like
volunteering I was volunteering yeah for
like a couple of years so
I just kind of threw my hands up and
it's like God if you want me to work
with this ministry you have to sell my
house
yeah
two weeks later
I got a phone call
and somebody on the other end said I
hear you're showing your house and that
scent chills way up and down my spine it
was like that's weird like that that
kind of like because you just said you
don't even never happened I did not ever
die so the only connection I could make
is I had to really think about it is
six months six seven months prior to
that point
I was talking with a lady at church I
never talked to you like I just don't we
have nothing in common
there's no reason for me to and and I
told her that I said this statement I
don't even know why I said it like I had
no reason to make a small talk yeah I
was like she was asking about things in
my life and it's like I feel like God is
laying on my heart that I should be
willing to sell my house wow
and I was like it I don't even know what
else we talked about I don't even know
why I told her that nothing her daughter
is the one that called me two weeks
after I prayed that prayer wow and it
was like the perfect time for her
daughter is a perfect time for me all
that and so God literally just like sold
the house what I didn't know on the
other end is Scotty told me later they
were praying too because they're like oh
you know small Ministry finances are
tight
they were praying that they had income
for somebody who had a small family wow
because they didn't want to you know
take on that financial responsibility
and that's it's uh it's a lot to bring
somebody on
because they're you know it's you're
it's not like inviting just like some
single guy you're gonna go get a job you
know so it doesn't work out they're like
you know you're moving a whole family
yeah
so they were praying for that and they
got it
they got like a Year's worth of income
wow big donations and I was like that's
that's pretty incredible so God's
answering on both ends
and it's just it's amazing to me how God
will answer
um those prayers and so yeah I guess you
know the short versions the rest is kind
of the history but it's about 14 months
later we moved out to California and
yeah I've been doing it ever since and
you got invited to start speaking I
speak a lot of churches that was the one
thing I told Scotty I could do because I
I you know I had started speaking a lot
at church and it's like yeah I can't do
that all these other things but I can
speak you know I mean you just learn
material so I did
um I was like if I can help alleviate so
he doesn't have to do it all the time
I'm happy to do that and so yeah I
started speaking actually I started
before I even moved out there wow there
was one time I was kind of I was kind of
nervous I went to Chicago
and I've been to since that one event
I've been back to Chicago like three
times but
um spoke at a church in Chicago it's
like 300 people packed it's like English
Spanish kind of makes yeah and it's the
only place I've ever been where
everything went completely smooth oh
awesome everywhere else like I just walk
in and I'm like what's the technical
difficulty yeah like I know it's gonna
happen what is it this time
it's like we don't use keynote we use
PowerPoint you got to convert everything
oh you have HDMI we only have this and
this was working yesterday it's not now
yeah that's what happens all the time
all the time on set to
um I was thinking about when you said
how it was working over here and working
over here it makes me think of the story
of when Saul became Paul and he was
blind and he was told to go meet this
other person yeah and like the other
person was told to go meet and like they
meet halfway
and it's like they were both being
Guided by God and they were both on a
mission that God had implant had planned
so with a little light they didn't have
enough funds but all of a sudden this
comes up at the right time when you're
moving here like it's amazing how God
works all things together for good it is
yeah and and you know there's not like
none of us except for Scotty went to
like Film School really well I guess now
we have Micah who's behind the camera he
went uh they want to be a
cinematographer but it's like you know
when we were growing like that God just
provided people and when he provided the
people he provided the skill set needed
so like editing and all that I just
learned from Scotty yeah or the whole
selfie documentary or yeah I mean you
just you know pick his brain and watch
YouTube videos and figure it out and
the I guess the one thing I had that
that where God blessed was I always had
a Bend toward technology so picking that
kind of stuff up was really easy I had
played with tons of software as just
that was just fun for me I would like
just download programs and use them
because I wanted to know how they worked
that's what I thought was cool about
Scotty he said a long time ago he he's
like God I'm not going to be looking for
people I'm not on a mission to hire
people I'm just going to do what you
called me to do if you want somebody on
this ministry you'll send them you'll
make the way and that's the way it's
really we all kind of have that story
like how it happened it was like because
he said
you can teach anybody to work on a
computer to edit video to do this and
that but you can't you can't like make
somebody have the heart for Ministry so
that's really what the hiring process
here is looking for if you have the
heart the True Heart for Ministry it's
nice because now we've gotten I guess
big enough I don't think of us as big
but we are we have been growing we have
gotten to the point where
you know God is almost sending us like
both we're able to look for the
specialty skill
but like you said you know we're still
looking as the the heart for Ministry is
the primary thing but it's like we're
able to pick from a pool of hearts that
have oh you're a graphic designer how
nice you know yeah you can have the best
portfolio though if you don't have the
art
s tomorrow nice to have the Best of Both
Worlds at this point you know it's super
handy anyway that's a little bit of my
story and there's a lot more to it
especially when it concerns my wife and
how all that worked out but that's
another probably another time and place
and yeah maybe we can hear a little bit
from her and if she does the printing
and we're going to go into that but
we're gonna do another little interview
here
so
Candy's coming in now
yeah
hello hello
hey
doing good how are you doing good doing
good
so um everything has been going smooth
so far yes this is just so everybody
knows this is live live this is not
pre-recorded we're this wasn't done
yesterday actually we all the way up to
the minute like I was still putting
together trivia questions just like 10
minutes ago yeah it really is it really
is like we're like we're going live okay
hold on
yeah and that's not just today I mean
since the beginning when did you start
working here uh I think 2017. wow 2017.
okay and so how'd you get introduced
it's a little light well
um you know I was I was always raised in
a Christian home and things like that
and then as a
as like a nine-year-old boy it was kind
of like my age of accountability I told
I realized that I was a senate needed a
savior I knew I at nine years old I'd
already lied I was cussing I stole stuff
I knew there was nothing that I could do
to deserve heaven or go to God and I
knew I needed Jesus yeah and so yeah a
lot of people wonder ask questions like
um if a baby dies you know what's going
to happen to them I think we all have to
come to a point where the decision is
our own yeah you're not going to heaven
because you were baptized as a baby or
because your parents are Christian you
know and so age nine was kind of my age
of accountability at that moment and uh
I started going to youth groups and
surrounded by cool teenagers that I
looked up to and they were on fire for
God I go on a mission trips and stuff so
I was surrounded by godly people
but um
I just my parents tried to shelter me
from Bad media which was smart on their
behalf they were like we're not going to
watch The Simpsons no MTV no violent
video games rated R and all that and um
but I was starting to get to the age
where I'd spend the night at friends
houses and those parents didn't have
those guards so they would be watching a
rated R movie and I'd see that stuff or
the kid had violent video games in his
bedroom and the parents were okay with
that so I'd be playing that
and uh I got to the age where my parents
could go to the store and I could stay
home while they were gone and so I'd
turn on MTV yeah so I guess that's
important like it was fantastic that
they were trying to shelter you from
what was out there but parents should
also prep their children on what to say
or maybe how to handle situations when
the parents aren't there but their kid
is exposed to the things that aren't too
good exactly like that's kind of our
whole mission here is to give people the
why because as a kid when you say hey
you can't do this you can't do that you
can't do that you're thinking well why I
don't know it just looks weird it looks
bad or whatever it's like that's not
good enough that's not a good enough
answer so you get curious and you go
into that and you're like wow this final
video game is fun
um so yeah I started I'm living proof
that the media does have an impact on
people because uh I remember seeing like
MTV Spring Break and everybody's in
bikinis and getting drunk and having a
good time and rock music and all that
and I'm looking at that thinking like
well that looks like fun but I know that
that's not where a Christian would be so
to me it was like is this really is this
Christianity trying to keep us from
having fun
and so then I I remember the day I saw
Marilyn Manson come on screen
on MTV and something immediately in me
was like I want to be just like that and
people that's the guy who dresses in all
black oh yeah this was back in the 90s
93 or something like that yeah I was 10
years old yeah you were in the womb
still
and people asked like oh where'd that
come from what made you drawn to that I
don't know that's the mystery of
iniquity we've been talking about that
lately our draw to sin we live in a
fallen world and things like that and um
I just remember from that point on
starting to have some really tough
questions I started to have skepticism I
started to think the Christians were
just really narrow-minded and if they
don't understand it it must be of the
devil because I was I was always into
the Paranormal and aliens and ghosts and
I was like why can't we play the Ouija
board
because I just started seeing that stuff
actually and I was in public school in
elementary school and there was a game
day and a girl said can we bring in a
Ouija board the teacher was like No And
I remember asking my mom what's a Ouija
board I didn't know what that was and
she said oh it's some game where they
call it a game but yeah some board that
you play with and you talk to dead
people and stuff like that and so I was
really intrigued by that actually
but you said you had tough questions
like what would make them tough is
because finding those the answers were
difficult like yeah it's like I would
ask questions like well
do you believe in aliens or goat what
are ghosts you know because and in the
from the Christians that I was around my
family included in the church and
everything they didn't really have good
solid answers on those things because we
know now we we teach on this a lot that
the dead or dead until Christ Returns
the dead in Christ are going to raise
from the dead but when you believe
when you're dead you're not really dead
you're just kind of somewhere else well
those ghosts could very well be your
family members or something and say I
wasn't I wasn't given that hard answer
like this is what the Bible says and
this is a deception so it wasn't that
the answers weren't there right the
glasses were in the Bible yeah the
answers were in the Bible that's the
truth yeah and that's what I've grown to
realize is that so much of the era I
grew up in seemed like that's when
Christianity started becoming more
lukewarm same story with Keith
our family started out with like a firm
solid we go to church every week we go
to Bible studies every Wednesday we have
home Bible studies but in my teenage
years it seemed like the whole family
just became lukewarm and it just slipped
off I see a trend like that with people
my age it seems like their family kind
of lost interest maybe not didn't become
unbelievers but lost interest in doing
things in church or devotion and things
like that
and so by the time I was 12 I was just
totally checked out I was like
Christians are narrow-minded they just
they don't understand there's things out
there there's mysteries in the world
that they don't understand and they just
say it's the devil and that's the kind
of the question the kind of answer I
would get to my tough questions was
well some things we just don't know
until we get to heaven
yeah and there was and and now I've
after studying the Bible I see that
there are good answers for things like
why is there suffering in the world
things like that
and um so I just started you know I
checked out I was still 12 you know I
was still living with my parents so I
couldn't do all the things that I wanted
to do or whatever but in my heart I was
totally already cut off and I began to
just um started messing around on the
internet was kind of new there wasn't
things like Facebook but there was
message boards and forums and I would
read about people's stories of playing
with the occult playing with Wicca and
casting spells and things like that and
that was really intriguing to me and I
started going down that road and that
just led to I read all kinds of stuff
and I was always plagued with the
thought of what is my purpose in this
world like I did I never asked to be
born I didn't ask for this and yet I'm
being told you must choose who you serve
because if you don't you're going to
burn forever and ever and it's like
what I didn't ask for this why do I have
to figure this all out and and so I
wanted to believe that there was just
nothing
but at the same time I was never an
atheist I couldn't have that mindset
because I did believe in the
Supernatural and the Paranormal so I was
always just trying to final which truth
is the truth and um so
the the thoughts of this if I if I
become the biggest rock star the next
rocket scientist or a jailbird my entire
life it doesn't matter if the end result
is death
it doesn't matter what I do in my life I
can choose to just not get out of bed
forever because the end result is death
and so that idea was just so depressing
that I just decided to escape through
drugs and alcohol and just chasing every
lustful desire of My Flesh
but my mom never stopped praying for me
and that's something that I am really
passionate about right now is
intercessory prayer praying for your
lost family and loved ones and my mom
always prayed for me she saw that when
she talked to me about God it was just
pushing me away and so my cousin came
right at the right time shared how the
Bible changed his life I was at kind of
a rock bottom and I was like okay I'll
give it a chance you know and and so I
started reading the Bible for myself God
was revealing himself to me in this
Bible because that's what I asked I had
an honest seeking Heart Lord if you're
real reveal yourself to me in this he
started answering my prayers in
Supernatural ways that I couldn't
reject anymore
and uh I accepted Christ October I mean
uh April 2005 but didn't know what to do
with it I didn't I wasn't studying the
word I'd go to church here and there
I believed in God and I and I had a
personal relationship with him I prayed
him and things like that but my life
didn't have any fruit and I was still
chasing my dreams of uh being a I had a
clothing line that was getting pretty
big it was on
models all around the world and rock
bands metal bands and like rappers like
Soldier Boys click and things like that
and me and a friend started rapping and
we got to the point where we were in
California at a mansion having a music
video shot this was in 2012.
and it was like the whole dream was
coming true like there was
you know we were getting free beer from
Bud Ice And so there's sponsorships yeah
yeah there were sponsorships there was
the girls there was
um you know rubbing shoulders with
people who were already celebrities and
it really felt like there's no way that
this is just happening naturally
everything all the time felt like it was
a supernatural door being opened
and right after that that seems to be
something like similar to Scotty's
experience and where the devil thought
like he knew that he was losing his grip
so he started throw in all these uh
monetary things
exactly and um no but he made the
decision I want to hear your decision
you know because that's that's two
different paths right there so it's just
it's so important to be in the word
ourselves because I was being told by
other Christians that I that God was
blessing my life wow these are this is
happening because you're a Believer you
got all the girls like King Solomon you
got all the free beer Jesus started
water into wine you got every green herb
bearing seed I had Christians giving me
scripture twisting scripture to make
these things look like a blessing in my
life because I wasn't studying for
myself I believed it and I remember
um coming back from that trip having the
music video shot I had every intention
on moving to California all my furniture
was in storage already my my friend
already moved out there my partner and
he was like calling me every day when
are you coming out here man
and uh
and I started fun and I was a valet at a
hospital and I was saving up all my tip
money
but I started finding these little
tracks about it was called signs of the
times it was like what happens when you
die the truth about hell and the second
coming all these things
and when I read them I was like this is
scripture like this it was different
than what I was taught different from
what I was told but yet I couldn't deny
it because of the scripture upon
scripture upon scripture and I I
remember I found a little book and I
ordered 30 copies of it because the
first chapter of this book said why is
there suffering and it made complete
sense about how God has given us free
will even the angels have free will
that's why Lucifer that's why he allowed
Lucifer to Rebel if God would have
destroyed Lisa for the moment he
rebelled all the angels in heaven would
have bowed To God In Fear right like oh
don't question God because he'll destroy
you so in God's perfect wisdom he's
allowing all this free will to happen so
that one day we will live forever in a
perfect world and will never question
God's Commandments we'll say these
Commandments aren't keeping anything
good from us it's for the benefit of us
and Humanity around us and I never heard
it explain that perfectly so I ordered
30 copies of this book
and so uh
like a door knocker type missionary guy
came to my door and and was just sharing
with me and he he could tell that oh
yeah so 2012 was like the blinders fell
off my eyes I was like I could see the
signs of the times New World Order and
just all the occult type things and the
movies and stuff
and he said I think you'd like these
guys and she gave me two bootleg copies
of Little Light Studios we'll allow it
yeah and when I watched it I was just
like wow there's a Ministry out there
that's talking about the same stuff like
I'm seeing but they're like going on a
deeper level like looking at the names
of the characters and the the storyline
and all this stuff
and I was thinking man I'd love to work
for a Ministry like that but they're in
California I'm in Chattanooga Tennessee
and
um even that could have been
misinterpreted because your dream or
your previous stream was in California
what if you were like oh maybe this is a
sign let me go out to California to
continue our music career and also hook
up with these guys yeah but you had that
discernment like I mean you waited out
well my intentions was moved to
California get a good reputation with
the world being an act but not an act of
being a rapper and uh having a clothing
line it's like an influence then when
they look up to me then I can say Hey
you know there's like secret a secret
war going on and it's in the Bible and
all this stuff you really need to do a
show on that because people have taken
that path you know there's Christians in
the industry but their actions aren't
really matching their their witness so
there's a big conflict in that regard
but we'll save that for a different job
that was my intentions God knew that
that was a bad path because talking
about photo shoots of models and rapping
about beer and all this stuff I was
still learning the truth about certain
things and as I began to read the Bible
it said be sober and I was like whoa I
need to be sober
um so I remember shortly after I came
back it was like God drew a line in the
sand said you can have this dream it
will happen if you pursue it you see the
sponsorships you see the the connections
it's going to happen or you can lay it
all down and follow what I have for you
and at that moment I made the decision
on my own it wasn't that my kingdom was
crumbling down and I was like God you're
my last resort I made the decision to
lay this down
and follow what he had for me and I'm
telling you
when you do that God will open up so
many doors for you he'll give you
Eternal purpose whereas my my purpose
before was trying to get the crowd drunk
or or hyped up or whatever and I thought
that if I surrendered he would take away
my dreams but God gave me those gifts of
graphic design of making t-shirts of
video editing and all these things
and now I get to use him for his glory
because what's crazy is when I
surrendered shortly after that somebody
said hey if I paid for you to go to
Evangelistic college would you go I was
like yeah but I won't be able to pay my
bills while I'm in there for four months
another Pastor heard that started to go
fund me like in two weeks had enough
money raised to pay my bills while I
went so now I'm in this Evangelistic
training College whereas I'm telling you
right after I surrendered don't be
afraid to surrender to God because he
already freed me from addiction I I
surrendered to him on New Year's 2013
woke up without a single withdrawal from
marijuana and alcohol something I had
withdrawals from every day and um now
I'm in this Evangelistic college and
while I'm in there is that where you
heard well you heard about little light
from the person who knocked on your door
right okay so then I suppose God just
take
you up or also getting you knowledgeable
about his word going through this
college I was not ready to work a little
later right but I was at the point when
I when I surrendered everything like I
surrendered the alcohol stuff that's
when I got to go to Evangelistic College
somebody in there said hey Mikey would
you want to be in a commercial there's
this big ministry that's doing a
commercial they need somebody with
tattoos okay so I was like sure and I
show up at the shoot and it's raining so
I get in the car with
um with two people while we're waiting
on the other people to come and I I'm in
the back seat and I hear these two
people in front talking
and uh I hear him mention something
about a little light and I find out that
they're from Little Idaho Scotty and
Keith in the car in the car yeah and I
was like wait you guys worked a little
less so you guys came all the way here
to shoot this commercial I said we
actually moved here like four months ago
I was like yeah what
so then I I just you know I started
having a conversation with Scotty about
how man I I really appreciate the
ministry I have a burden for the Youth I
see the same kind of things you guys are
seeing and and uh he could tell that I
had a heart for the ministry and so they
invited me to do like a small video
and then when I came there I said don't
you guys want to start printing t-shirts
here and he said yeah well your machine
fit right here and so I the thing is is
God wants us to pray big prayers we can
pray for our lost car keys and a good
grade on our test like he cares about
those things but he wants to he wants us
to pray big because when he answers
those prayers
everybody knows that he did that there's
no way that you could have done it and
so I look back and I'm like God move my
favorite Ministry from California
not to Atlanta not to Alabama but right
there in my city and then gave me a gift
that they were looking for the t-shirt
printing thing is what got my foot in
the door and at that time it was three
like three members and then I got to
join on
and uh so it was a small team and yet
had all the people in Chattanooga I was
able to get on there because of the way
that I was submitting to God and praying
for these specific things in my life
so yeah that's how I so you came in
doing t-shirts what do you do today
oh we all do a little bit of everything
but spent a lot of time researching and
um you know trying to put together
presentations that show what we see when
we look at pop culture and we look at it
through the lens of the Bible and so
anything you're working on that's coming
out soon yeah I'm working on a Avatar
video because there's a movie A lot of
people are excited Avatar 2 is coming
out and uh the video you just did really
inspired me to want to do a more
produced video because we do a lot of
live stuff and and the even the LED live
shows you know it's just like a table
talk discussion
um but yeah when when you did that video
I was like man we need to do more stuff
like this stay tuned we're actually
going to do a video commentary about the
video that Mikey's referencing black
panther
um and yeah you're going to talk about a
project you made as well later on in the
Stream so we got a lot of cool things
coming on check out don't forget to join
the trivia I dropped the link in the
comments there and I think you're about
to get interviews
all right I'm ready Alex
so you excited or what yeah I know I'm
ready
Okay so
candy
um
I was growing up you grew up in the
Christian home I'm sure it did I did I
grew up in a Christian home I was born
in Saint Lucia oh it's a little island
in the West Indies yeah
um and yeah but I came here as a baby I
grew up in New York right and yes grew
up in a Christian home my mom and I
um she she you know in contrast to Mikey
he was saying he grew up in a very like
strict household and then it kind of
eased up a little bit and that allowed
him to like kind of deviate into
everything else that he was he was
involved in it was the opposite for me
it was more relaxed growing up in terms
of like the media would watch but also I
think things were a little bit more mild
back then than what we're dealing with
today
um but then my mom is uh and she's been
on the show Mama calendar shout out to
you
uh she she was a Seeker you know and she
she was really she's a researcher has an
analytical mind if anyone's asking where
I get it from
um and so as she would study the Bible
as she would
um watch different documentaries and
really under gain a deeper understanding
about media and its effects and also
biblical knowledge and how we should
live as Christians and what our
responsibility is
um then our household started chain
because she started implementing that
that information so it got not
necessarily more strict but as I grew up
but it was like here is the information
and this is what I'm so grateful to her
for is as she got the information she
shared it with me and then asked me to
make a decision and it was easy for me
to make the right decision because I saw
her living it out and how God was
working in her life and so
um it just it was second second nature
and it was a family thing and we could
support each other and it was a free
home in terms of me being able to ask
questions and um people who know us
called me her little pocketbook because
she would take me everywhere business
trips to learn you know how to be
self-sustaining as a person well-rounded
as a person but also religious seminars
would travel and just see the world and
yeah yeah so my upbringing was very um
one of of of gaining knowledge to be a
well-rounded person that's great I mean
now I understand why you you had a
passion or like anyone in New York yeah
six hours driving or eight hours and
Florida yeah I can go over there and you
went to Mexico it's a hard transition
man living in Tennessee now New York
still has my heart so anytime I have the
opportunity yeah it's a job that's great
so little life Studios when he was the
first time they maybe you watched one of
the our documentaries or video somebody
tell you about
um
it was um a friend of ours a family
friend they were conducting Bible
studies as like in their Outreach thing
and so they invited us to to join in as
I believe it was a support
um I would just like to make the Bible
study grow bigger and anyway it was
adults and at the time I was a kid I was
in Middle School and so there were other
children there as well so we went all in
the basement to hang out as kids when
the adults are upstairs on their thing
but of course they didn't leave us to do
whatever we wanted so the owner of the
house popped in the DVD actually had it
here oh nice Magic Kingdom whoa so we
all sat around the TV he's like oh you
know Disney let's see what this is about
and now a little did we know yeah right
what was in here of a powerful
I must admit though I could care less
about the information yeah well it
wasn't it wasn't information that joined
me and it was actually the production
How It Was Made I was very intrigued
that's what kept my attention like how
how did they edit that and how did they
get the music like that and how did they
build this set like that it was very
interesting to me and um it was
something that had caught my eye growing
up as well just video cameras
um and and computers and these things so
um this was the first time I saw
um well that's not true because we
watched three of the end growing up as
well so this was the first time coupled
with a previous experience that I saw
Christians using media for evangelism
like in a very creative even like
Hollywood produced style uh way
and got me really excited
um and so the friend of ours who the
home that we were in gave us a few other
DVDs replacement gods and these things
and that was my first exposure in middle
school every time I tell Scotty that
story he feels very old but uh yeah he
was impacting the lives of people uh old
and young yeah
back then this came out in when 2011
2011. yeah so that was your first time
you know heard about New Life Studios
I'm gonna go a little four more years
later on okay and of course you know we
sharing like how you
you know get involved with live life
Studios and everything before that I'm
gonna ask you something okay
uh
when was the moment when the USS Christ
because you can grow up in the Christian
Home sure I mean you can hear about
Bible singing songs and stuff like that
but in the moment you say you know what
I'm gonna put that thing in my personal
life I'm gonna
Jesus Is My Savior is my friend so can
you share with us no it was interesting
I can't really pinpoint a specific time
but I think I came to the realization of
making a full commitment as I was put in
positions where I needed to share my
faith so it makes sense so I started
going on mission trips
um
I think my first one was back in 2013
and they'll refer different things and
I've been on several since and in each
of those occasions whether it be abroad
or even right here in this country
um I was put in a situation where I
would meet people who would ask me what
I believe or maybe I had to present
something or even preach and seeing how
God worked in like Providence and also
words that I would say that I'm like
where did that come from you know it's
like literally reading God's word being
put in positions where I have to share
God's word of them seeing how he
answered prayers seeing how he's
literally using his people as he said in
his word to broadcast his love to the
world broadcast the gospel it just made
us so real in my life it was like
I can't do anything else but this like
this is this is it so yeah I would say
growing up from an early age like middle
school high school
um and even into college it was just a
fragile thing of just deepening that
impression of this is what I'm called to
do and this is what you know really any
Christian has called today any Bible
believer and so I think that
um practice of practice just practice
sharing uh
um and putting taking advantage of
opportunities that God places in our
lives for him to work so he becomes
personal to us that's really what
solidified it for me
I knew that question was coming man he
likes those types of questions
so uh so the moment the moment you say
you know what I grew up this morning I'm
gonna call and then I drop my resume and
I know
it was
it was so I can graduate so I can
graduate college
um and it's funny how yeah production
right full circle yeah because remember
I when I saw this I already had like an
interest like how does it how does a
video production work so I actually uh
took it up as a hobby and I took some
courses in high school and my hobby
became my my major in college I studied
media production and I specialized in
videography video production
and as a requirement to graduate I
needed to go for a year of internship
and so I went to a convention called gyc
generation Youth for Christ and I
started handing out my resume to a bunch
of different Ministries and
organizations and companies and I was
like Lord
I did my part I pray that you do your
part but specifically close all the
doors where you don't want me and leave
that one door open just keeping it
simple please leave that one door open
where you want me to go I don't really
want any part in terms of the decision
because I don't want to make the wrong
decision please show me which where
where's you want me to be
and so little by little people started
uh not responding to my emails and the
last person to respond to me or that
kept responding to me was Little Light
Studios and so I came here on internship
in 2018 and before I even graduated they
hired me on they hired me in April of
2019 I graduated in June of 2018 and
2019 sorry I've been here ever since
right yeah I I specialize in like
editing so I was like okay I'm gonna be
behind the camera I'll be in the
background I'll just do what I need to
do and like quietly go out like no we
need you in front of the camera we need
you in production both pre and post and
all of that but
um I just praise God for this ministry
because it just expanded my mind and the
possibilities and what's out
and not just involving me in in my
specialty but showing me how the
business works you know how to speak
professionally and all these all these
things um going to conventions and all
this stuff so it was very well-rounded
and it was I think that it this was only
able to happen because of how small the
ministry was at the time because we've
grown but at the time um the kind of
training that I got here it was that's
great blessing
so uh the last question I know you
involved with International and
University's International but also
you're a producer and you the latest
video that you produce one of the LEDs
is
uh the Black Panther yes and I watch it
four times because it was a great
information the production and how it
was the whole thing and edit yeah and
you know like when we produce here we
checking every single thing so I need to
watch the like four or five times to the
storyline and everything so can you tell
us a little bit uh how many hours do you
work on and that's a question okay yeah
how many hours did I work on black
panther
um it took three weeks day and night so
I'll answer it that way I don't know how
many hours that is but yeah three weeks
both during the day nine to five and
also I went home and had to continue
studying writing the script and editing
as you know like we slept in the office
or I Mikey and I were sleeping here and
always trying to get it done and man God
God help us because usually those types
of Productions take months but he just
you know what I'll save that for later
we're gonna have a whole video
commentary on that I have stories to
share testimonies to share and also
little um like director notes so stay
tuned for this afternoon
um join me to watch the Blackman yeah
excuse me the bathrooms are exposed all
right so I'm great we appreciate you
here in Little Life Studios uh you're
one of the keys here to make things
happen so thanks so much for sharing the
gifts and I think we're gonna be
okay we're gonna go more testimonies
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
foreign
to
go out of your way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world
please
hello hope you guys are doing well so my
story starts off with me actually being
born in a Muslim family my dad was born
Muslim and my mom converted at around
the age of 21 12 or 19 19 to 21
um so I was born into that and raised
raised Muslim
um all through my childhood and teens
and something about that even when I was
little just never felt right to me
I never knew who God was through that
um because in the Muslim faith God is
Allah so that's who my God was at the
time and I always found myself rebelling
against that religion because it just
felt very dominating and
um
I didn't feel any true like real love in
that religion so I around the age of
17 18 19 in that that
time of my life I actually rebelled and
I kind of rebelled throughout my whole
teens by doing a lot of things against
that religion
yeah so then I rebelled and moved away
from home and
around the age of 20 to 22. I found
myself getting into the New Age movement
fully into that I was in that for five
years actually just recently as of
beginning of this year got out of that
but I was fully into the whole New Age
movement I was doing tarot cards I was
meditating manifesting into
witchcraft you name it and it was never
to get back at anybody it was always
with good intention
white magic so
um yeah I was doing that for a while and
when even when I moved back home I was
still doing that and then at the
beginning of this year is when I read
something online that really convicted
me and it was talking about how
people who do divination are not
welcomed into the kingdom of God and I
just was like wait a minute I thought I
was doing good I thought I was helping
God and all that deception and then I
thought that I was going the right way
like beginning of this year where I was
doing tarot but I was using angel cards
and I was like oh it's fine I'm I'm
talking to Angels like and so it's this
is like Godly right and I made a whole
Tick Tock and got so many followers and
then a lot of scary
um demonic things were happening
um very scary
spiritual things that really shook me
and
God saved me out of that because I found
myself just at one moment just crying
out for him I just had enough of it it
was just I was just I just remember one
time just laying in my bed saying
God help me and just crying because it
was just mental physical emotional pain
and just feeling
so much weight lifted off me at that
moment and that was only this this
spring and summer of 2022 and is when I
was saved and now I'm doing
everything in my best effort just to
shine light on the New Age movement and
on that dark deception and bringing it
to light as best I can on social media
and in real life and being a true
follower of Christ and I would love to
get my my testimony my story out and
help those who are in either in the
Muslim faith or in the New Age movement
wake up and realize that it's not true
light it is a false light and I would
love to have that opportunity thank you
so much God bless you
hi little lights I'm Wendy Parker and
I'm here just to share a quick testimony
of how your channel has been a huge
blessing to me and my family
it all started about three years ago
when my husband and I Heard a Voice from
the Lord saying to move from Anchorage
Alaska to Indiana
to minister to our family
and we thought it was going to be easy
because the Lord told us to do it but
quickly learned that a prophet is
accepted but not in his own country and
a lot of the conversations that we tried
having with our family fell on deaf ears
it got to the point where if we would
mention our faith an argument would
break out uh we knew that this wasn't
pleasing to the Lord
so instead of bringing up these topics
we decided to turn our ministry into a
Ministry of prayer and so my husband and
I started praying that the Holy Spirit
would do the work that the Holy Spirit
would reveal truth to them in a way that
was new and and didn't come from us and
that's where your channel comes in
um
I had found
the channel strange normal with Bradley
Burnham and Mike Jenny and I was able to
share these truths with a relative that
came over and that was adamant about
aliens that video was an easy way for me
to just hey take a look at this and see
you know what you think about it and it
went really well surprisingly where if I
had tried to speak about God and any
other
scenario that person would just get up
and walk away so
I started to see then how God could use
these videos in a drastic way to speak
in situations where we couldn't
um after watching a lot of the the
videos on Bradley's Channel my husband
and I saw little light Studio come up in
our news feed and started watching these
and one instance that I loved I was with
some family members and I said hey I've
got this video you have to watch and it
was the video of Marvel something that
we'd all watched together throughout the
years and didn't see any harm in from
you know surface value and
one specific relative was being very
skeptical and saying you know I don't
really see how all these things
fit together and oh I don't think that's
really the message of the movie I don't
really see where scripture fits in and I
just started praying Lord I know these
are truths I can see very clearly you
need to intervene here Lord help help
this person to see the truth and I kid
you not a minute later a little clip
comes up where Robert Downey Jr steps
out and says we're here for this signs
and wonders
and I looked at my relative and I said
signs and wonders isn't that crazy and
they're like well I don't understand and
I said well it says in the end that the
Antichrist comes and deceives many with
signs and wonders and I said and the
whole world will Marvel after the Beast
and that person just stopped and looked
at me and said Marvel I was like
yes and that person had said you know
the Holy Spirit just gave you that to
show me how all of this fits and it was
like this Veil just lifted up off of
their eyes and since that moment
um I have used your videos to share a
lot of really important vital truths to
our day and age in pop culture and um
it's been amazing
the difference I've seen in the
conversations is just astounding it went
from let's not talk about that here I
want to have a nice meal together to hey
do you have any new videos from Little
Light Studios that we could watch and
all these conversations that we tried
having before now it's like an open book
we can talk about these things after
we've watched a video and we have this
Fellowship that we really were not able
to have before so my husband and I are
super grateful for all the work that you
guys are putting into these videos and I
just want to share with you how greatly
people are being influenced by them
there is so much Fruit by all of your
work so God bless and thank you and we
will be watching that is you're making
me nervous
hey guys uh so now we have Alex here you
guys have known him from Little Light
Studios espanol page but for those of
you who don't know he is going to tell
us a little bit more about himself
so Alex tell us about yourself
well my name is Alex I'm from Mexico and
I grew up in a Christian home
um
come to United States when I was
20 almost 21 and
and 2001 that was 1999 2001 I met my
wife yeah Mary and been married for 21
years so
yeah yeah cool so yeah have you always
been a Christian or is that something
that uh yeah I grew up in a Christian
home and just uh you know those 300
years in the teen years it was a little
while
uh so you know music and you know
parties and stuff like that and I left
the church for like five years or six
years I mean I was going to church but I
mean yeah yeah
no exactly and but the thing is that it
was a moment in my life that uh my
middle brother
uh he saw how's the little brother was
acting and how I was dressing and you
know all that stuff and believe it or
not I used to have long hair and these
are long hair and different colors and
and not very good listener kid and and
things like that but my middle brother
come to me and say can you give me two
hours of the 24 hours
God gives you
and I was like hmm that was very
kind of interesting what you're saying
right so I would sit down with him and
and every time I see my brother my
middle brother he always been in the
church
my older brother is kind of like me like
you know off and on but uh he come to me
and told me say if you still keep living
your life like that
you don't gonna make it you need to ask
Jesus to come to your life you know
Salvation and he was you know he went to
a little bible study you know like
Daniel when the books are open you know
the Book of Life the book of this you
know so they say and say if if you don't
have
your name in the books of life and you
don't ask for forgiveness and uh you're
gonna be safe you know stuff like that
this is your little brother my middle
brother okay yeah so I was like
interesting and then he went all the way
to Revelation said
um you know after a thousand years the
New Jerusalem is coming down right and
the redeemers are inside the city and he
told me he said
the
the castillejos family is going to be
inside in the city I don't want to see
my little brother be outside the city
and I was like I never heard those you
know right I mean I remember growing up
in the church hearing that kind of stuff
but now how he explained to me how tell
me the whole thing I was like hmm that's
gonna
I don't like to see that picture you
know right even though that I was doing
bad things and I was like okay two
minutes two hours is and I'm out so I
just left
but I believe it was the Holy Spirit you
know of course in my the person my mom
you know
uh lots of prayers I don't remember
exactly it was like next month and six
months or something like that but I
remember I was you know one evening uh
hang out with my friends and some party
stuff like that
and I see the scene you know like this
friend is doing this thing this person
is drinking over here this person want
to do something and you know the whole
thing right and I believe it was the
Holy Spirit it was only like 15 seconds
or a very small amount second because
and now we understand that
all the stuff that we listen that we put
in our minds right how the holy spirit
is going to go over there and break
those chains and kind of talk to you
because you're putting all these you
yeah you know a lot of things in your
mind influences influence and stuff like
that so I had this thought I was looking
around and I had this thought it was not
my thought
what are you doing with your life this
is not your world
and I was like what what are you talking
about like this is not what I'm thinking
I'm just having fun Saturday night you
know 11 o'clock yeah and this is not
your life I have this this start
and seriously I just
how you stand up
and I was kind of convinced I was like
this is not my life like this is not
what I'm going through right after like
five years of not not being good
Christian or something like that yeah so
you stand up and I laugh and of course
my friend's like hey what are you doing
I mean party's not over I was like I'm
out yeah so since that that moment
seriously I had getting up a five in the
morning
before going to high school my last year
of senior year and I was reading my
Bible in Bible study yeah and yeah I cut
my hair and looked you know dressing
better when I was dressing before and I
remember the the the principal the
school told me to say I don't know what
you're doing but you're doing good you
look better and keep doing what you're
doing yeah so that was my my experience
of that and I was baptized a few months
later okay and that so you it seems like
you were a Christian before you came to
work here oh yeah so like how did you
come to know about little light and
um like what's really Your Role here and
all the things that you do well in 2011
I was here in the United States and
everything media was very very powerful
because you know you watch things in
Hollywood or whatever you know movies
stuff like that I was very addicted to
movies
um Superheroes Batman it was very you
know my my take because I really like
the the character of two different lives
right you know one life is like that I
want life you know you know Bruce Wayne
and Batman you know so I was like you
know what that's my life you know
because I was like Christian but I'm
like Christian I go on parties and
everything so in 2011 being a Christian
going to church and all this stuff and
um I remember I used I used to go to
this website audioverse to download
videos and that was 2011 I mean MP3 I
mean you don't have all this fancy
phones or whatever
so in 2011
I downloaded preaching is called
American Idols by Scott Meyer oh okay
and I was like okay I'm gonna listen to
my preaching you know I used to go to
bed you know going to bed listen to my
preaching
and I 11 o'clock at night listen my
preaching and this guy was talking about
Scotty he was talking about his
superheroes and all these movies of
Batman you know all the stuff that what
they come from and all the clips they
were talking about
you know against God about against the
Ten Commandments about you know all the
stuff and I'm like I watched the Batman
movie like 10 20 times
and they're I mean you know when you
watch something now right reveal right
what is wrong yeah he was very shocking
to me I was like what opened your eyes
yeah totally so I was like wow can you
imagine that I mean what I'm putting my
mind so of course the next day I was
like who's those guys you know so I went
to the website they had like maybe like
five videos on YouTube uh the trailers
and Magic Kingdom stuff like that so
watch it documentaries yeah and I was
like I need to get one of those copies
you know and so the whole point is that
I call him and I said
I mean you changed my life you know my
my my Christian walk you know uh
can I help I mean do you guys have this
thing in Spanish and you said no I have
somebody to work on you know they're
translating the Magic Kingdom uh but you
can help us I can send you a file and
everything so I helped to finish the
Magic Kingdom in Spanish the subtitles
in Spanish and then the other one the
file system Workshop replacement gods
and also so I help them to bring those
ones and subtitles and expense five DVDs
so is it subtitle titles or voiceovers
in the beginning was the subtitles okay
but after a year or something uh they
decided that we decided because I was
like I mean I'm sure if you
I mean you want to watch something and
it's subtitles I mean after a while
you're like okay I'm lost so we decided
to you know what I want
the voiceovers because I want my you
know the Latino Community to listen and
to understand very well so it's a lot of
more work
and but uh thank God you know um uh uh
so the whole point is you know I helped
them and they told me hey you want to
come down to California to do the
voiceovers I help them the controller
won and the whole point is that they
told me to say we really want somebody
to share this message to the the Latino
Community you know and I said well yeah
great I mean I can call somebody said no
he said we want you Alex so I was like
I'm just a translator you know I'm just
a translator guy you say uh so the whole
point is there I don't I need to pray
about it because it's not just like you
need to stand up somebody and share it
you know you need to be it's a lot of a
lot of things involved to be a speaker
or shared spiritual stuff yeah so after
a month you know I pray talk to my wife
and we decided to go to this ministry
and since 2000 that was 2011 2012 some
in the summer 2012 I've been starting to
go to the
you know the Hispanic churches I went to
Mexico many times speaking Yeah speaking
Hollywood series okay yeah and Guatemala
two times Puerto Rico four times Canada
around the United States yeah so
yeah different places and I know that
you wear a lot of different hats here
but I think like what you're doing with
the little light espanol is so important
because we have so many people who come
to us and they're like you know can we
get this video translated in Spanish and
that's really the bulk of what you do
yeah um so it's like really important to
get this out to the Spanish-speaking
world and we just really appreciate your
work here yeah yeah yeah totally so that
was that volunteering job by the way oh
you volunteered and then it led yeah
since 2011 until two years ago uh you
know how it is you know people growing
everything and uh when Scotty said it's
time to Let's Do It full time and I was
like well let's do it that's awesome so
yeah well thank you so much for sharing
like your story helping us know a little
bit is there anything that you think
that you would tell the audience that
they can help the Spanish Channel if
there is any way for them to uh a lot of
you know a lot of people don't share
with us about like hey how we can help
and everything translating I mean I have
few people already translated but if you
maybe into like editing videos you know
that a huge help for me because I I'm
the only person and their projects uh
the next huge videos that I'm working on
is and the anime
and the documentary I mean it's four
parts yeah so I'm working part one and
then also with dragon reveal part two so
that's gonna be the next year so how
would they send how would they let you
know that they're interested you can
send an email to me and say Alex at
lls.tv and we can talk you know nowadays
the technology is so it's you know it's
very good so we can share videos and
stuff like that so awesome thank you so
much for sharing that and letting us
know what's going on with the Spanish
Channel and everything so yeah thank you
thank you
and now we are next interview actually
is me
Brad is interviewing me hello Beth
unmute my mic now are we live do we go
straight into it
oh do we have a commercial between it
I'm not sure
all right we're going straight into it
that's what the producer said Mr
Producer Alex over here
Brittany hi wow
you've been here a while right only one
year at least longer than I have yeah I
guess yes I came here in August of 20.
so what's this year so 2021 yeah and
then you came in January of 2022 earlier
this year yeah yeah so you were you came
a little month a few months after and
you've had a few you like we all we all
wear a few hats here right right and you
have two so tell me from the very
beginning what did you start and what
are you doing now oh man okay so from
the beginning I was working on more the
graphic design things
um doing thumbnails I would share the
load with Mikey because he was also the
like one of the people doing those as
well
um and then I would you know be on the
show as like one of the hosts and then
that led to me going more into social
media which is what I'm doing now and
then also donor relations so I'm really
just keeping everybody updated about
what little light Studios is up to
whenever we have new releases and then
also just sending weekly emails just to
keep our donors updated and to keep in
contact with them as well wow wow so
that's a that's a big job because not
only do you do Graphics or you did
Graphics at one time you also are
involved in the intricacies of the back
end of the whole system and being on the
show I've enjoyed some of your
commentary on some of the LED lives
thank you what are some of the
challenges that you have experienced
here and the hard things that are are
more difficult uh in dealing I guess I I
would say more in social media because
you communicate a lot with people right
yeah you have to keep all those people
happy out there yeah it is a huge
responsibility
um just because there are so many
messages that come in and so many
comments that we get every single day
and it's really hard to get to those on
time so I would say that's probably the
most difficult part but for the most
part I enjoy you know hearing feedback I
especially enjoy the testimonies that we
get like those who really like the
highlight and I've also just really been
enjoying to see the way the ministry has
been growing and just how the numbers
have been just rolling in and how many
people that were able to reach now that
our social media page is more updated oh
man yeah and we've increased quite a few
subscribers likes and all that other
stuff tell me about that tell me about
Facebook tell me about YouTube yeah so
Facebook this year alone we've been able
to grow our platform to an extra 50 000
followers so now we're at a hundred and
five thousand followers wow and on
YouTube we've been able to gain over 20
000. so now we're almost at 150 000
subscribers so that's really just with
the help of pushing as much content as
we can and just more and more people
coming to awareness about our ministry
and having shareable content as well
which is really important and it's
important because you want to reach as
many people as possible right and that's
that's the whole goal of this ministry
is to reach the masses tell them about
Christ and what the truth is behind all
this stuff that's going on yeah yeah and
uh and so in your personal Journey has
this helped you as you have you seen
things as we produce different content
just yourself as as you've watched the
different videos come out like I know
you have in the past but is there
anything that sticks out to you you're
like wow this is something I wish more
people would see yeah well when I first
came like you mean like when I first
came to know the ministry not only that
but also here just while you've been
here but yeah both both yeah I think it
really just um challenges me
um especially working here and just the
job that I do to really be careful about
the things that I watch and listen to
and just see how they can impact you and
I think just as I'm like I get to
communicate that more to our audience
like if they ever do ask us questions
because I am here and I watch all the
videos and I'm part of the conversations
it helps me
um I guess solidify more what I believe
in yeah yeah that's important because we
have to know what we believe by studying
the word of God by by viewing what's
around we we kind of can see through the
veil that is that is what's going on
right and it's it's fascinating because
I for for personal experience I have
seen that I've seen what's going and I'm
sure you have too yeah absolutely
so tell me more about
um your the back end of things that you
have done you've done uh so we talked a
little bit about social media uh donor
relations what does that entail donor
relations is really um keeping up with
patreon and then we're also sending out
weekly newsletters
um just keeping them our donors updated
with what's going on keeping in contact
with them we also send out little gifts
from time to time for all of our donors
and we also send an additional like
every Friday our donors get a testimony
that comes in from our viewers and it
just keeps them connected so we're just
continuing to talk to them and just
having this like nice little Community
together and that's really what we do
how do people if they wanted to be a
part of that subscription where they get
an email they get these information how
do they do that
um so they would go to our website on
our home page if you just scroll to the
bottom they'll say sign up for our
newsletter and you just put your email
address there and then hit submit and
then you should be added to the
newsletter and these are weekly messages
these are weekly yes so not only updates
about what we're doing but also
testimonies and what else is that it
yeah testimonies it's you know if we
have a video coming out just really
speaking engagements things like that if
they want to know where we're going to
be speaking next that's really where all
that information will be that's through
the newsletter yeah fantastic well I
want to know more about you because I I
know a little bit about you just because
we work together right right but there's
so much other people don't know like
your phone number stop I'm kidding
that's an inside joke between us as
staff members uh what what is uh what is
your um your your favorite thing to do
outside work
hmm
that's a good question I think I just
like to explore the area explore yeah
and I like to try new foods yeah drive
around a little bit you know I go to
Chattanooga and just like look at you
know different shops and try different
food places that I haven't eaten at
before just things like that hang out
with my friends I like to write and read
things like that that's good that's good
there's a lot of things I like to do too
and that does uh does any of those
things
um help your work here at the ministry
work
Inspire us so sometimes like if I go out
and I see a graphic or I see something
it always inspires me like oh that would
be actually really cool to try this out
with little light so I like to just
explore the outside world and just see
what I can get from that because
sometimes I just spend a lot of time on
the computer so it's just nice to really
just get out sometimes did you ever get
um messages from people that give you
ideas and and yes how do they do that if
they wanted if they had an idea that
they said oh this is a great shirt idea
this is a great uh different different
ideas how do they get that to you
um they just send it through like our
messages through Facebook or Instagram
just all of our social media platforms
they'll just tag us on something and
that's how we get a hold of it I'm good
yeah and
um we have a little bit more time left
so I want to dive into the information
about your past without going into too
much testimony because we all get a
testimony it's all can be very long but
what is it if you could narrow it down
just a two or three sentences what is it
about your life that you would say was
impactful that brought you to Christ and
eventually brought you to this ministry
in three sentences
um I would say that when I was in high
school I just went through a lot of
things that just put me in a really deep
depression and I got to a point where I
wanted to take my own life and just in
that moment like God just really worked
and I really found him there and was
able to build a relationship with him
and from there that led me into new age
and then just series of events that
happened I ended up going to like a
Christian college and so I just had more
experiences with God there and then I
just settled in my belief with him also
working here helped with that as well
and I recently got baptized this past
May so I feel like that's very vague but
you said three sentences that was a
little more that was perfect no that's
fantastic yeah we've had we've had a
joyous time I attend your baptism and it
was it was it was beautiful yeah and I
think that's very important to publicly
state that you are a follower of Christ
because not only does it solidify in
your heart but also everyone gets to
attend they don't do you want to you
want to talk about this stuff and say
hey this is this is what I've decided to
do yeah and that's very important so I'm
proud of you I'm proud of the you
working here in your work you've done
here it's been fantastic working with
you thank you thank you
and who's next Who's That You're Next
actually oh it's me you're the one on
the hot seats I'm looking forward to it
do we switch seats no no
you keep that seat that's the hot seat
how are you Brad I'm good how are you
so I'm excited to hear a little bit
about your story because uh everybody
has a really unique way that they've
kind of come to working with little
light but you I think more than anyone
else here in this ministry I began to
talk to you from the very first onset of
our ministry
tell me a little bit about that oh man
let me tell you so I used to live out in
Hawaii I was challenged with what I
believed and I was like I don't believe
the Bible says that I'm going to read it
through I'm going to prove you wrong I
was wrong and so I was like you know
what I need to go study this stuff I
went to AFCO which is a amazing facts
put on this Center of evangelism I went
out to California and I studied there
and that's where I met you but you
weren't attending AFCO at the time yeah
no I was actually doing a seminar there
for the AFCO students and you were
actually one of the attendees there
that's right yeah I went up front and
and you were having some mind trouble I
remember you distinctly saying this
happens every time yeah it was mic
trouble it began to be um just sort of a
little inside joke to me like I can't
tell you how many times I've been going
to speak somewhere and it's like the
whole system just goes and it's like of
course of course they don't want you to
know this information but
um you I think ended up helping me and
then we kind of started communicating
after that and you actually sent me a
video in the very beginning uh tell me a
little bit about the video that you sent
me so yeah I was thinking about
everything you said and actually before
I I live this is this is a really
important I think because it shows the
power of your message that you had back
then and today and so I I said well this
this four messages you put on in four
days I said this is so impactful I have
to bring these four videos because they
recorded them I have to bring them back
and show my family and so I prayed to
God I said you know what I I if this is
something this is true I want to bring
this back to my family members and so I
did I brought them back and uh through a
chain of events that's going to take
long and explain that I can do right now
brought them back
and my dad calls me the day before I get
there and says hey you know I put a
contest in and I won two flat screen TVs
before I get there of course and I'm
like are you kidding me I'm going back
to tell my father about the dangers of
the media and he said now we got to get
HDTV and you have to get all this cable
stuff and you have to do all this uh you
think about all the streaming platforms
we could do and in HD I said hey man the
devil's working really hard because we
didn't normally have all this stuff in
our house but now we went there so I
went back and after I talked to them
about it then I said you know what I I
really want to look over all this stuff
and I'm kind of pushed together into a
trailer for a little light because they
did such a fantastic work I want to give
back to them so all of a sudden I get a
uh an email from this guy named Brad
Burnham and uh he goes hey I made you a
video and and just wanted you to play
with it it was a trailer to basically
kind of all the concepts that we were
actually running around and giving talks
with but like distilled down in this
like trailer form and people had been
asking us so many times how do I share
this information I need some sort of
trailer to like play in front of my
church members or something you know to
like get them interested in it and so it
was like you know God just works through
different people to achieve things that
like we needed that and all of a sudden
you provided that and that's kind of
basically how I first got introduced to
you wow so it's really cool
um talking with Brad over the years uh
he decided to actually give me a call
about a year ago maybe a little more
than a year ago
um what were you what were you doing
yeah so I I was at that time we had
continued to communicate throughout the
year I was working on amazing facts for
like 10 years and and we we after uh
some dialogue with my wife I said you
know what we would like to move back to
Tennessee but there's there's a
documentary I'd like to work on and and
it was fantastic very interesting stuff
that we were both collabing kind of
talking over the phone I was talking
with Mikey I was talking with you and I
said you know what what if I move out
there so little insight about Brad here
I don't think this man sleeps actually I
think he is literally uh maybe one of
those people that sleeps an hour out of
the night I don't know but he has time
to have his own YouTube channel he
creates his own documentaries I mean
this guy is Non-Stop and the video that
he's talking about is a UFO documentary
that he began to work on a channel
called strange normal maybe some of you
guys have seen that strange normal you
can look that up on YouTube
wonderful wonderful Ministry that you've
started that really kind of takes the
idea of spiritualism and what's going on
right now like all these things are
happening right now in the world and
really kind of brings it to the
Forefront and uh so not only does he
work here 10 hours out of the day but he
goes home and works on that thing all
night long so it's really impressive to
me um you are a jack of all trade and
it's really been nice having you aboard
our team
um Brad also has been um gifted in a lot
of different areas not just making a
video what were you doing for amazing
facts I was doing well I did it for
seven years and then I did media for a
few years after that and um I I was so I
edited the Sabbath School Study Hour uh
ever uh not Everlasting gospel but there
there was another one of church service
I forget the name of it we changed the
name of it a few different times but um
it it's uh those hour-long programs I
did those edits we did uh setups of of
of of the studio and all kinds of stuff
it was it was engineer and editor at
that time so outside of your technical
skills Brad also has some set building
skills and one of the first tasks that
you did when you actually came into this
new building that we're in right now
um you got a chance to build something
really cool what was that no the the
green screen so I wanted to to do we
both decided we wanted to do something
that was more virtual because we could
change so many things and have so much
fun with it so we built this big what's
called a Cyclorama psych for short and
it's a big wall that has a four foot
scoop of drywall out of it and you paint
it green and so it has no corners yeah
and so you could change everything
behind it so the set that you guys if
you've ever seen any of our shows the
LED live show that's actually a virtual
set that's using this green screen
technology
um it's it's really fun to play around
because we can kind of play around with
the look of certain things and it
doesn't really cost a lot of money we
can be very effective and economical
with that and so that's been that's been
a really neat tool that you've been able
to bring on board with us and so well
tell us a little bit about what what
other kind of things you do here at
little light sure yeah we do when I
first got here we started doing short
these short videos which are changing
into YouTube shorts and reels and all
the other names they have for him right
tick tocks I guess but what there are
these they were originally just a short
form of LED content saying here this is
what's happening right now and how it
relates to the Bible and so it's it's
really fascinating to see all this and
there's a lot of people that get a
chance to kind of just find or stumble
across our content maybe they don't have
an hour that they can sit down and watch
some content like that and so you're
really kind of just trying to catch
catch send out the net right and and and
really just kind of pique their interest
with one little thing if you like this
you can come over here and And subscribe
to our Channel and like uh some more of
the content that's kind of in that vein
well it has been an absolute joy to have
you aboard and I know that you've got a
lot of uh wonderful things that you're
working on give us a little sneak peek
of something that you're working on here
oh man let me tell you we have had
requests after request for this
documentary on competition and sports
uh-oh and it's gonna make everybody
angry you're gonna ruffle some feathers
oh man the stuff I found Scotty is
incredible and it's legitimate it's from
people's own words players staff coaches
and it's really interesting what's
coming out in fact I think we have a
trailer a first ever played on the
internet of this new documentary that's
coming out very soon so you're going to
want to see this trailer because I
remember when Brad kind of was bringing
this concept to us and showing me a
couple of these little parts and bits of
this I was shocked at the transparent
currency that these sports players from
all over the world all sorts of
different sport disciplines and what
they were calling it and it was just
like we couldn't have paid people to say
that kind of content so I I think it's
gonna really
hopefully plant some seeds in in your in
the audience's mind of just like you
know we really should consider all these
things all these things I think we are
in the end of time and Jesus is coming
soon and the devil's got a distraction
for everyone on the planet and if he
can't get you over here he's gonna try
to get you over here and so this is one
area that I think people spend a lot of
time with and like anything you know in
order to build a relationship with
somebody you want to be able to spend
time with them so if you just kind of
consider it from from some of these
perspectives right right yeah I think
it's going to be a real eye-opener
absolutely well Brad thank you uh for
that and we are definitely wanting to
see more of that but as you guys can see
um we have such an awesome team here at
Little Light Studios it has been a joy
to work with each and every one of these
guys they all have these unique stories
on how they came aboard how they even
just got here it it is such a Divine
orchestrated opportunity that we all are
sitting in this room together and
through much of the generosity of our
supporters and our followers and the
prayers that you guys have given this
ministry over the years it's really
amazing that we have been afforded this
opportunity to sit in this room to
really dig through some of these things
to open up the eyes of of people that
maybe were never considering these
things before and so keep us in your
prayers keep praying for us and thank
you so much for all the love and support
that you poured into this ministry over
the years we really do appreciate you
guys you guys have really enabled our
work in a mighty way and we just are
thankful and grateful that we get this
opportunity
um I think we're going to play a little
trailer for you guys here and then we
will continue forward
[Music]
I don't know if if the athletes really
truly understand
how significant Sports is
and I'll take it even the steps further
I think Sports has become the new
religion I think in the rise of atheism
and the and the resignation from faith
in God that Sports and sports figures
have become the new religion there's
rituals in religion and there's rituals
in sports were there rituals that you
did before a game yeah yeah I've had a
lot
your body is just a vehicle with this
magic thing called hakka sports do the
work of religion fix they build
community they give us a sense of place
and purpose and meaning I like the hit
thing I can get all my frustration out
on the field the casters commentating
the game are going crazy they are now
the superheroes they are now the
mythological figure where they become
gods in their own domain if that's not
spirituality I don't I don't know what
it is and then it all made sense what
character is it teaching its fans and as
soon as that happened the entire dynamic
in that Stadium changed football is the
only major sport in this country Who
Sold basis is violent at some point it
comes to a showdown I have to defeat you
I have to do violence to your person he
had a 37 million dollar contract and
just walked away from football I think
it's a war I went to war Warrior without
actually having to go to war because I
almost sought psychiatric help because
it's not just a game your heart isn't
right they asked me how are you going to
deal with this the rest of your life
behind
the office game for the team and we have
his address and we're going to go out
and we're going to kill him tonight one
kid against an entire city they don't
get out of this inning this poor guy is
you know he's done for
[Music]
foreign
so I get something really cool to do for
you guys it's giving Tuesday and we want
to be able to give back to you guys as
much as you've given to us so I get to
introduce a really cool you're going to
want to subscribe if you haven't
subscribed to Little Light Studios
YouTube page right now you're going to
want to click that subscribe button
because we're gonna play each one of our
documentaries that we've produced since
the very beginning of this ministry so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
what's going to come up every single
Tuesday and every Tuesday we're going to
release a new documentary and the first
one that we're going to do is called
pseudology and the reason why I want to
tell you about pseudology is this was
kind of one of the beginning
documentaries that we actually began to
work on pseudology means the art of
lying and when I kind of began to open
my eyes to the media I wanted to answer
the question of does it really matter
what I watch does it really affect me in
my brain and so we decided to make a
documentary where we traveled around we
went and interviewed neurologists and
scientists and doctors all over the U.S
and we wanted to answer this question
are you truly affected by what you watch
because if you can understand how the
brain works then you can understand that
there they there's a there's no reason
why you would charge five million
dollars for 30 seconds to play a
commercial during the Super Bowl if it
didn't affect anybody right so based on
that information the next documentary I
want to tell you about was Magic Kingdom
so we will be we will be looking at okay
well if you are affected by this type of
media then does it matter what the
content is saying to you and so we
decided to make a documentary that
really started uh going over kids
programming and what's been more squeaky
clean over the years or or actually so
they put the imagery out there that they
are squeaky clean is Disney now I know a
lot of stuff is coming out in the news
lately that Disney is not as family
friendly as most people used to think
that it was but you would be shocked at
this very common phrase follow your
heart follow your heart how many
different movies from Disney share that
concept and so this goes over some
cartoons and really shows some of these
spiritual connections because some of
these old classic ones like Aladdin and
uh uh some of the really old uh uh
cartoons that have been around for a
long time Peter Pan they're not as
innocent as they s they they used to
portray them as and when you really kind
of look at it through the lens of the
Bible you'll see that there's actually
some very interesting things to learn
about that so another documentary I want
to tell you about is the replacement
Gods if you have any interest in
superheroes you will want to see this
documentary and it's very fascinating to
see that where these characters actually
come from they come from Greek and Roman
mythology and even the writers and the
creators of them they say they these are
Greek and Roman gods that we've
literally put spandex on we've
repackaged and we've handed to this
generation that's why Superman is Zeus
Batman is Hades Aquaman is Neptune
flashes Hermes they just go on down the
list and you can see all these ancient
gods literally are handed to our
generation and it is done in a very
um fantastic form in fact superheroes
are some of the most watched movies in
our day and age so you're going to want
to catch this there's a part one and a
part two part one we really specifically
dealt with DC characters Superman Batman
and part two we've really started to
introduce Marvel into the scene if you
haven't seen the the Marvel Satan's and
Marvel not at Satan's end game that's on
the top of our YouTube page as one of
our most watched videos I suggest that
you watch that video especially if you
have an interest in superheroes you will
find a lot of very fascinating
information
to create in the very beginning of our
ministry
um was on the topic of martial arts
um and the reason why we decided to uh
do an entire documentary on this
particular topic is because there's a
lot of spiritualism that is being
introduced into the public under the
guise of martial arts and so this was
done with Eric Wilson if you followed
our Channel we've had him on our show on
our LED show lots he is a wonderful
teacher he spent 25 years teaching
um martial arts he was a he was an
instructor he's been honored he's got
many black belts so this is a two-part
series the first part really talks about
his personal testimony how he got
involved in the martial arts since he
was a young boy and all the way into his
adult life and there's some very
powerful things that came out of his
testimony of that and then the second
part of that disc really talks about
where are all these spiritualistic ideas
coming from what are they actually doing
to you and what does the Bible have to
say about them so if you have any
interest in martial arts or you start to
see Eastern philosophies creeping into
the church you want to see these
documentaries
another documentary series that we
created is called the controller series
a lot of people came up to our ministry
and they said you know my kids don't
really watch a lot of of movies but they
play video games all the time what do
you guys know about that so over the
years we've we've we've done a number of
documentaries that really kind of talks
about some of the things that video
games
um are are introducing and so there's a
three-part series we'll play those for
you the first part really deals with the
very beginnings of Nintendo the second
one really deals with kind of how the
technology you is used the used video
game technology and and training in the
military the third one really kind of
goes over some of the most popular video
games and all you'd be surprised how
much biblical imagery is placed in video
games so you won't want to miss this
series especially if you guys have any
interest in video games another
documentary that we created was called
Selfie and this one was really kind of
taking a look at
social media because this is sort of the
new wave that we are experiencing our
kids are growing up with this technology
our kids are are all having social media
accounts nowadays and many many many
kids are spending upwards of eight nine
hours a day playing with this technology
so this really took a look at some of
the dangers that are coming out of an
addiction to social media so that you
can be aware of how to navigate I don't
think this technology is going away and
of course we using social media right
now we have this being broadcast around
the world using YouTube there is some
positive uses to the technology and we
discussed that in this documentary as
well but there's also some dangers that
we need to be aware of as well
and then
we also have another document Ary that
continued in that same line of the
superheroes called the Black Panther
deception and when this movie came out
the reason why we wanted to make a
documentary on it was because culturally
this movie
really hit the world and was a huge
phenomenon in in the in the cultural
world and the reason why is because you
know Hollywood has had an unfair
unslanted or a slanted
picture of what life and reality is
really like and and so
the devil used this topic really to push
spiritualistic ideas but you but
piggybacking on the top of a cultural
sensitive topic and so many people took
off their Christianity and decided to
engage in this movie and really just
there was a lot of spiritualism that was
introduced into that so we made a
documentary about it really powerful
piece that if you have any interest in
the Black Panther deception Kennedy did
a wonderful job really talking about the
Black Panther 2 that just recently came
out if you haven't seen that scroll
through some of our last recent videos
in our YouTube page and you will see
there is some awesome awesome
information candy did a wonderful job
talking about some of those topics and
issues that are presented in that video
as well
and so definitely take a look and we
will be uh putting those documentaries
out every single Tuesday and you won't
want to miss them so subscribe if you
haven't and we'll see you then
hi everyone a new study found that 40 of
three-month-olds are regular TV Watchers
would you believe that one third of all
three-year-olds in America have a TV in
their bedrooms no I can't believe it
it's kind of disturbing everywhere you
go we are saturated with media the baby
who watched two hours of TV a day before
the age of three would be twenty percent
more likely to have attentional problems
at age seven the frontal lobe of the
brain is the seat of spirituality
Morality In the will Entertainment
Television suppresses the frontal lobe
of the brain the humans are particularly
visual animals what you see is not
necessarily
a carbon copy of reality what you see is
a gradual coding and reconstruction of
the signal in neurologic terms and in
that process a lot of interpretation
goes on we have more depression than
ever before in human history more
anxiety mental health problems are
skyrocketing throughout the world and
the entertainment medium is one of the
primary reasons why this is occurring
more reason to keep infants and toddlers
away from television is there a danger
to exposing the mind to realities that
don't really exist the bottom line of
basically NFP any change work any
conditioning any brainwashing it goes
down to emotions well with hypnosis
they're still trying to find out exactly
what the mechanisms are that are working
in the brain but now with the
Neuroscience they're really finding out
fast with neural Cinema technology
filmmakers can now look inside your mind
and make better movies
[Music]
we're experimenting right now with
30-foot Lamberts in 3D and the result is
an experience that is so close to
reality it's called d-box and it's set
to cause quite a sensation it's being
tried
at theater in Hollywood I really enjoyed
how it made me feel like I was in the
movie you're actually in the movie in
the movie as if I was in the scene
myself but the idea of real in cinema as
in you know because Pandora's
meaningless now exactly the idea of
what's real it doesn't take an Einstein
baby or otherwise to understand what
this means so back to television back to
the movies where
you start to have a belief change or you
think it's a certain way to say hey
don't watch that or don't do that
yourself people go nah they have reasons
a whole bunch of why they can't be
hypnotized
cartoons are they simply stories only
meant for entertainment
or are they complex tools used for
seducing our characters into a certain
way of behaving
[Music]
what if you could escape to a far away
world
without parents
[Music]
without any rules without anyone telling
you what to do
all you have to do is leave home behind
but you can never come back
never is an awful long time I've been
trying to obey someone else's rules
about who I should be your duty was to
stay home but your heart told you to
break the rules how did you decide
between Beauty and heart by following my
feelings I wound up doing the right
thing Bottoms Up
[Music]
[Applause]
all around you are spirits child if you
listen they will guide you all right all
right all right wiki wiki dead people
we've got work to do so let's move with
purpose I've got an important
announcement to me
I got friends on the other side
[Music]
what messages are these occult theme
stories telling us about God
[Music]
all right I'll be the one to say it how
do we know you're really Jesus can you
perform Miracles sure how about this
you always wondered if there was a God
and now I know there it is and it's me
if there is a God send another copy I
guess that's our answer
is the president of Hollywood he's
supposed to give you the greens
greetings your tinseliness imperious
leader of Hollywood
foreign
[Music]
just watched was some trailers for our
documentaries
um you will want to see doco Tuesday if
you haven't seen our documentaries yet
we'll play a couple more trailers after
this but uh we're gonna talk about uh
some of the testimonies that come in
because really some of the inspiration
that we get is hearing from you guys and
when we see and hear testimonies of
people's lives being transformed that
just gives us much more energy to go out
and win more souls and put more
information out there and we listen to
the the the suggestions and people say
hey what about this do something on that
we listen to those kind of things so
we're going to read a couple of those
for you guys because we sit around we do
this from time to time go ahead pick a
couple
Okay who wants to go first Brad's going
first I'm going for it all right here we
go one two this one it's the smallest
all right I respect that you guys keep
it real keep up the good work this is
from sketch and sketch Inc repeat
sketching repeat I respect that you guys
keep it real keep up the great work he
said
all right I'll read a longer one here
this one says hello LED I'm so happy I
found your channel I've been binge
watching your shows uh we we don't
support binge watching but only our
Channel you can binge watch that yeah uh
and I'm catching up so I'm so thankful
for God bringing me to you because I
started to stray away from his word and
was starting to follow the new age
spiritual movement I thought that I
could combine it with the word of God
but it led me down a dark Road and I was
constantly drinking and having dark
thoughts and the light of God was fading
and I couldn't tell the difference
between right and wrong anymore but God
has brought me back I'm praying and
studying his word and I see how wrong
I've been and I'm so grateful to have
access to your channel it helps me a lot
in studying the word and may God
continue to bless you all Beverly thank
you so much for writing that awesome
test or testimony to us that gives us a
lot of encouragement and that's really
what we're doing this for is we want to
frame the word of God in a relevant way
that people can really grab onto that
and start to filter the world around
them through the Bible
Hot Potato Hot Potato all right I like
this person's name it's zabizabby
but this person says guys you are
amazing I became a Christian because of
your page this is so profound it's
literally an answer to the Great
Commission in Matthew 28 go into all the
word preaching the gospel God I mean
it's it's humbling to be put in this
position where we can share God's love
and people respond and they are looking
to Christ so we'll be praying for you
zabizabi that you will uh deepen your
walk with Christ and I invite you all to
pray for us and as we pray for you in
staying faithful and continuing and
sharing the word of God to the world
okay so this
commonness from the Instagram is keyed
of God always it says your videos are
really helped me in my spray tool bottle
uh I remember you know the first time I
watched the the LED all of the Magic
Kingdom uh it was really opening because
I have a little little girls and they
were watching some Disney and stuff like
that and I was like why can I believe it
you know that we watch this kind of
cartoon with my girls I never thought
about it we're attacking God uh yeah
it's a spiritual battle because it's
like it's an eye-opening you know it's
an opening and you make a decision you
know for God or for you know for for the
evil one so thanks so much the our
videos they're helping you and you and
your faith to grow
everybody
I just want to read something real quick
just we are live this isn't pre-recorded
and somebody said this uh Zach Rogers
said this channel is amazing I'm very
grateful for you guys and what you do
and then remeli says I wish there was a
place that little light Studios
Community could be together and chat
online that would be cool love chatting
with you guys we love chatting with you
guys I just want to show you guys this
is live here's a comment that came from
Spartacus 13 that says you guys are so
amazing I always love it when you come
out with new content and uh that really
is like candy said just so humbling to
think about that people are waiting for
what's next you know and and that's on
us you know we're trying to create
content so we appreciate you guys
reaching out and giving us ideas of what
you guys are looking forward to seeing
go ahead Brittany your hand's been
thanks you know I I've been you know
raising my hand it's just been yeah okay
okay so this is from keep calm and love
God
okay
um hit the like on your lips okay and
this person said Little Light Studios is
such a powerful Ministry especially for
the Youth
um yeah I I agree with this I don't
think there that there are very many
Ministries out there that really take
the angle that we do with pop culture
and I think that that's something that
um like the youth today are just so
drawn to is social media pop culture
movies music and so the fact that God
has given us the opportunity to minister
through these platforms is I think
really cool
before
yeah this this is a good one uh it says
you guys are the best my kids are big
fans and uh we are patreon supporters my
husband wears his producer's shirt a lot
with pride thank you all for what you
guys do praying for your ministry that
your ministry grows and we can support
you guys even more uh P.S FYI we are a
family of eight and we all watch your
your videos every time there is a new
video the kids gather up and around the
TV it's a blessing this is from Jesus
lifted High Ministry on Instagram and we
also want to acknowledge that we just
had a um a super chat from a meal a deep
I thank you so much for the Super Chat
we do appreciate those every little bit
helps
I do want to say something on the
families that get together and do this
that is such a beautiful thing by the
way we hear this testimony actually
quite a bit in our ministry people will
gather together and they'll do it as
like a family worship a topic will be
brought up and then they will all
discuss the topic and open up their
Bibles read some of the verses that
we've brought up and I just think that's
so neat that's that's literally what
we're trying to do here and also I
wanted to mention about the producer
shirt for those of you that don't know
about that
those people that are supporting us we
like to give a little something special
to those people and so we actually
create a t-shirt that is not for sale on
any of our website or anything like that
it's literally our way it says producer
on the back and on the front it says
little light evangelist digital
evangelist and it's just kind of a cool
t-shirt for for you uh so if you see
somebody on there they're a supporter of
our ministry
all right here's one from somebody we've
met
this is one of my deepest desires is to
get the entertainment industry knowledge
to the world I used to play video games
for 12 hours a day
a year ago I finally made a commitment
to stop and the time gained from leaving
this industry has been incredible I've
been studying my Bible now and I'm on
the road being a preacher there's no
other path in life I could possibly walk
but I would never be here if I didn't
give up the video games
because of your videos I was able to
have a more solid decision I was
addicted to them and your videos allowed
me to see the wickedness in not just
video games but all that wickedness My
Eyes Are Open and my life with Christ
has been strengthened thank you so much
to Little Light Studios I have a big
burden on my heart to be able to share
the messages with others they've changed
my life and I pray that God uses these
DVDs for a mighty purpose that's from
Enoch and we've met Enoch and Enoch
still travels today he has his own
Ministry that he operates so God really
changed his life in a powerful way
who's next
all right so this is Hannah and says
I've been watching your ministry and I
really like what you guys doing I
believe it's a Ministry needed for this
age uh yeah thanks so much for your
comments and thanks so much for watching
our videos and yeah I believe that the
stuff that we produce we make is for for
right now I mean it's time to to share
the gospel this opportunity that we have
uh I mean you know I mean watching TV
and you see all those news and you're
like wow this opportunity we have the
freedom of sharing and I believe the the
the videos that we produce is gonna help
you and you and you guys Faith thank you
for watching
foreign
I got another one here this is from
Deborah humblebee it says your work has
helped me in so many ways uh showing so
much truth personally it has brought me
closer to God and I thank him for you
you are always in my prayers thank you
so much Deborah we appreciate it and uh
we also got a soup another Super Chat I
want to acknowledge from A.D you and he
says you and Bible flock box our videos
are my Bible Inspirations for a TV
series you and Mikey and Mario and
Scotty should be a perfect actors in it
too
[Laughter]
foreign
while we're also talking about how
families get together and watch our
videos I do want to mention that we are
also on Roku as well and you can just
episodes get updated every single week
so that is something that if you're
interested in that's where we're
available as well
from Mariano Frias I'm in it says hello
guys I want to thank you for inspiring
me to live a more christ-centric life
and to be sober and diligent vigilant
um regarding the content that I consume
thank you for helping us to stay awake
God bless you all
yeah that's so awesome just to see how
this ministry is really impacting people
and that people are actually
you know taking that next step after
seeing the harm that media actually can
cause to our spiritual life
this comment is from Ricky it says a lot
of Christian content is getting censored
lately that is true we will be on
YouTube for as long as they'll have us
we're heading to a time where all
genuine Christian content will be
illegal on this platform that's actually
prophetic Revelation talks about that
not just on this platform but worldwide
the word needs to get out you guys are
doing an amazing job thank you so much
for your encouragement and yeah it is
good to be aware of this because now is
the time we do need to get the message
out and be as creative as possible for
as long as we can before Jesus comes
with that being said share our content
share share share why you can because
that opportunity may not always be there
this uh this comes from Brendan MF uh
you all make the best content for real I
love every show it hits home with
personal experiences and I think um
that's a really important comment
because I think if you if you listen to
our testimonies we all have personal
experiences with this kind of media what
we're doing is we're actually taking
things that maybe tripped us up in Life
or that we struggled with and we have
all of a sudden opened our hearts to God
God's opened our eyes and we're sharing
what God has taught us and hopefully
inspiring you guys so just take a lesson
from that you guys can open your eyes
and then turn around and share this
information with somebody else maybe at
your church maybe with your family maybe
with someone else that's that's around
your circle of influence and that's what
this this is all about and just giving
you an opportunity to to share your
witness for God
it's from uh leonette how do you say
that l-i-a-n-e-t Lynette 777 this is why
I love little eye Studios no fear they
tackle whatever uncomfortable topics
that might pop up oh man will you wait
till this next documentary comes out you
don't know
oh man that's that's going to be huge
but I I really appreciate that thank you
so much
um I do also want to comment on the one
that candy just wrote about us being
censored we do have an alternative
um streaming site which is Odyssey which
is kind of like YouTube but all of our
videos are on there if they've ever got
taken down on YouTube Odyssey does save
them and you can find that at Odyssey
it's o d y s wait o-d-y-s
s-e-e no it's ee the way they spell it
yeah the way they spell is ee.com slash
Little Light Studios you can find that
on our Facebook as well it is in the
link in all the descriptions
um but this person is called random or
the username is random potato
and they said
um thank you I really needed an LED to
make my week better
it's really sweet thank you for saying
that we love you random potato
it's probably a couple of videos we
should upload to the Odyssey channel
that I've never seen the light of day on
our YouTube channel
because I got taken down right away
um yeah I was the one that struck out
twice
so one more and I'm out I guess
this one's from YouTube it's from
rejoice it says thank you guys for being
so bold and preaching the truth I
personally learned so much and what I've
learned has really taken me to the next
level in my Christian walk I truly
believe you guys have a huge reward
waiting for you in heaven for the
amazing work you're doing on Earth and
they put 100K let's go right now we're
closer to 150k let's go
so very close maybe who knows maybe by
the end of the day
thank you
that is a charge for you guys by the end
of the day 150k I think we're only like
400 or less away
so here is one from Eric bolt says I
really love your content you all you
guys always come with the truth and the
production is always very well done keep
shining your little light God bless you
all from Eric bolt God bless you thank
you for that encouragement you don't
understand how much it means to us to
get encouragement like this because we
get a lot of pushback for this tough
message you know and so we need the
encouragement too I want to read one
that came yesterday because
um I went live about the gift of tongues
and a comment came in that said uh yeah
I agree with you on this but I was
surprised to hear about your stance on
the pre-trib Rapture not being a
Biblical thing and so I responded with a
video that we did on that and this was
the response we got back said thank you
so much after watching and reading those
scriptures I must change my position
what I believed is what we were taught
from the pulpit said we really must look
into things after we are taught one
thing I found too is that the word for
left and the strongs is the same word
used so this person you know what what
we're doing is we're trying to share the
truth from the scriptures alone and get
away from just traditional things that
are taught and thanks to one of our
videos somebody has seen the truth on
this subject and changed their mind I
love that
um I do want to read one more comment
um
from
nithi and it says love and prayers from
India love your ministry so much dear
little light Studios and I hope you'll
reach more souls like me and expose the
darkness through the light of Jesus
thanks a lot for your ministry again and
God bless you all I love this because it
just shows that we're reaching more than
just people in America but we're
actually having like a worldwide reach
which I think is really really cool for
our ministry
there's one more there's one more we
want to say uh thank you so much for the
Super Chat Pariah Perla thank you so
much for your donation it really really
helps out a lot and we just love that
you guys have shared some of these
comments with us over the years it
really encourages our hearts and
hopefully you guys kind of uh see a
little bit of the influence that we've
been able to actually have and and it's
really an honor to work for God in this
way
um right now we're going to play another
trailer for one of our doco Tuesdays
this one's going to be up for the
replacement Gods if you have an interest
in superheroes uh you won't want to miss
this on doco Tuesday here's the trailer
for that
[Music]
you will become earth's greatest savior
ever Dance with the Devil in advance
Victor you always thought you were a god
[Music]
you're not a guy God's receptive beings
we fly around in little red caves and
don't share their power with humankind
God bleed
people will cease to believe in him
the very bold big Primal characters you
know Superman is Zeus Batman is Hades
aquamanas Neptune and they kind of fit
into the the Pantene of gods of a lot of
different cultures
[Music]
the book of Rao
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so
probably a couple years ago me and my
wife went through a big transitional
period where the father was just
working on this big time Deliverance of
some stuff
and one of the biggest things that
happened during that time is we
recognized we had an entertainment
addiction so for years I worked I don't
work there anymore but I worked at a
hospital so I worked 12-hour shifts and
then
drive home take a take a shower eat sit
down on the couch look over at my wife
so what do you want to watch tonight
instead of do you want to pray together
do you want to read scripture and this
happened for years not to say I don't
read my scriptures because I do but
obviously there's a problem if he
sitting there like
what do you want to watch and we would
watch Central stuff too so I try to keep
the scriptures as best as I can I'm out
of Faith however you want to call it
but we choose to watch Central stuff and
I don't know how I found Little Light
Studios but we started watching some of
their videos
I don't know how many videos we've
watched
probably three or four months with just
watching y'all watching live Studios
content
a lot regularly together too so that was
big and then the father just delivered
me and my wife of or he used he used low
life Studios content to deliver me and
my wife of an entertainment addiction
and now so it's cool now we have a rule
we
and we only he's only watch movies on
pureflex which
it's good for the most part they try to
slide a little bit in there but it's a
lot better than Hollywood so we have a
role on Sundays we'll pick one one to
two movies so usually about three hours
so sometimes
a lot of times their movies are hour and
a half so you'd stack that on top of
each other it's about three hours but
normally we just watch one movie a week
and that's it and that's a rule we've
had since being delivered of this
Entertainment station that that we had
for a very long time
hello my name is bonti and I have really
been blessed by this ministry it has
really blessed me
um I first started to know about through
a friend actually and she watched their
videos and she started recommending them
to the WhatsApp group that we had called
the saved ones and for me personally I
was a bit skeptic at the beginning
because I personally grew up watching
movies used to come back from school and
then you know turn on the TV and watch
movies especially during the holidays
and so getting to see the truth revealed
Behind these movies actually just got me
shocked that I had never seen the truth
behind them before I had never seen the
details of actually what they say or
what they act or whatever they do
so through LED light Studios I was able
to get that truth and just my eyes were
opened and even though I was skeptic at
the beginning I really felt the
impression of the Holy Spirit to move
forward in faith and keep watching them
and the more I watch them the more the
truth was revealed to me so if you're
one of their viewers and you're kind of
like scared and skeptic it's okay at the
beginning you know that's what happens
sometimes but continue watching their
videos you will be blessed by it because
I have been blessed my sister has been
blessed my family has been blessed and
even my friends so thank you so much
let's like Studios for continuing to
share the truth through your ministry
and I know so many other Youth and
people will gain hope and encouragement
and also that their eyes will be open
till that truth and also another thing
that has encouraged me through this
ministry is that to instead instead
rather spend more over time in the Bible
in God's word and actually
opening God's word has just made me
understand it more instead of spending
three hours on a movie I have started
spending more time in God's word and so
I'm so thankful about that that I am
replacing my time with the good things
with things that help me grow
spiritually mentally emotionally and all
sorts of ways and so if you're thinking
about why should I replace my time with
now singing songs reading the Bible
having devotions with friends that's a
way in which you can replace that time
that you used to use for something else
and use it for the glory of God I hope
this can encourage you as well as much
as he has encouraged me bye-bye
[Music]
foreign
English you know I invite people I
interview people sharing the testimonies
or some topics or the LED live so we go
and Bebo it's like going live but I I
just present a message stuff like that
and also uh we have those LEDs is in
Spanish also and thanks so much for your
support because that helped us also to
you know to create more videos you know
we're able to create more videos like
that and also we have T-shirts we have
teachers in it yeah and like that this
one uh if you were kind of interested
you can go to our our website uh you can
get those different designs is it a
different website or is it little
livestudios.tv uh I believe is in the
lightwear but you can find in your
website yeah exactly there but right
here on your shirt says little like
studios.tv slash espanol yeah this is
our our website good yeah a website and
watch our videos uh watch this video
about our teachers
is
[Music]
thank you man that was really cool I
have a quick question though sure you
know we have a lot of content on our
English YouTube channel and I know you
have a lot of content on the Spanish
channel is it the exact same video the
exact same content or are there
different videos on the Spanish channel
uh no it's practically the same you know
I just
translate it and put the voiceovers and
stuff like that when is the the LED live
when I present it I mean it's gonna be
different it's not the same you guys you
know the four people different guests as
well yeah different guesses and as by
myself deliver the message even if you
speak English you may not speak Spanish
YouTube Auto generates English struggles
sometimes so you can go on and hear the
wonderful testimonies and experiences of
Alex's guests and not all of his guests
speak English so they don't come on our
Channel or sorry on the English Channel
yeah but um yeah I encourage you to
support both and if you have anyone who
speaks Spanish in your family share
Little Light Studios espanol with them
yeah and also there's another way to
practice your Spanish right that's what
you want to learn that's very true yeah
so I'm gonna show you uh the process uh
you know a lot of people asking like how
you do the the doubling and the process
of breathing yes okay
hmm process of dubbing so first thing is
to have something to dub so we create
the content on whatever topic and then
uh someone would reach out to us shout
out to our volunteers first of all I
only speak one language and that's
English oop let me fix my mic here I
English so all the translations that are
done that are outside of Spanish are
purely volunteers they reach out to us
via email or sometimes they call and
they say hey I'd like to translate that
video so what I'll do is I take our
English video and I just send them the
the music and the sound effects and if
they don't know how to download the
video I'll send them just the visuals as
well and the person will translate the
documentary into text that way we can
upload the subtitles but what makes
these special is they do a voice over
they record their voices speaking in
that language and then they put those
three elements together the visual their
voice and the sound effects so it's
pretty much the same video as the a
English one but it's just in their
language then they send that video back
to us and we publish it on the
international Channel but I'll talk
about that later on after we finish with
the Spanish has have you collaborated
with other Spanish speakers for the
Spanish Channel yes yes and I have a
video uh they're going to explain to you
a little more about the process on the
Spanish side watch this video
I'm too uh
controllers those they control those the
lower commentaries
[Music]
the dollars versus the the
problems those colors can I say
some different bosses
somebody else
is
[Music]
seriously all right let's take a look at
some of these projects you have here so
the first ever documentary that little
light did was Magic Kingdom yeah and you
have that here in Spanish that's right
how do you pronounce this
that's right okay and then we have
replacement Gods yeah dioses okay I'll
leave that for you
uh what else do we have here this is the
presentations in Spanish uh I went to
churches and little Studios they filmed
you know live audience and stuff like
that so it's like four presentations and
my testimony great so and we have
controller anyone interested in video
games yes anyone in Spanish the first
one the first one and then the last one
here we have pseudology the Art of Lying
yeah in Spanish
yes I need to practice my Spanish I
should watch some of these yeah um is
this this is hard copy this is DVDs yes
available on streaming yes and some
Vimeo is available uh download and you
can rent it or you can buy it and
nowadays you know worldwide you can just
buy and download it and it's cheaper
that way too a really great idea that
little light came up with a few years
ago was creating what we call a sharing
DVD it's one disc that has many of our
documentaries all in one that way if you
find someone on the street you can just
hand it to them and they have a complete
package of everything they need from
superheroes to
um to video games to understand standing
how media affects the brand and
advertising and all of that we have it
in Spanish as well that's right I think
they get this uh you can go on our
website and expand is you can check you
know you can get them and it's very uh
useful for churches or Bible workers or
just you know youth group and you want
to share the gospel and you want to with
the young people whoever I mean it's
very you know sometimes people are
looking for uh is any new you know new
uh uh you know new things so sure uh
Christian videos or something like that
in Spanish because you know it's kind of
hard to produce some stuff in Spanish
but uh we had this opportunity and let
me tell you your churches or youth group
of Bible worker they're looking for you
know to to get this and share the gospel
is a unique way it's great yeah so this
takes a process and we've done the
process over and over but sometimes
there are bumps in the road can you tell
us about that some behind the scenes
clips of things that may not always oh
sorry I'm going to be ahead of myself
stay tuned for that though yeah these
are all of our past products yeah
um projects there are some in the works
what are those so right now I just
finished controller two about video
games and so it's uh
is is yeah this is the one and number
two uh I don't have it in Spanish but
it's done it's available in vimeu you
can rent and buy it you know you can
download it now we still processing this
to about on DVD physical you know things
and I control two is done and thank you
for all those people they bring you know
I think it was like 80 different
voices 80 yeah so it is a lot of a lot
of voices yes yes it takes a long time
and a lot of people said oh yeah man
just making Hispanics I was like no it
takes like eight months or six months to
do it but uh technology is you know is
going growing but I'm gonna be starting
on working on 2D big projects uh this
coming you know the year and it's anime
and it's four parts no just one part one
at a time just one at a time just part
one the anime and I know a lot of people
are gonna be looking forward for that
kind of documentary and also uh
um the dragon reveal part two the one
part one the testimony of brother Eric
Wilson is available in our YouTube
channel littlest cheers in Spanish uh
amazing testimony amazing production
it's in Spanish uh you're gonna enjoy
the voice do it myself and that's good
so uh the part two uh the replacement
the dragon reveal part two I'm gonna be
working on that this coming year and the
anime so watch the videos I have The
Thrillers right now in Spanish so watch
the controller 2 and the anime
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I am really excited for these products
that are going to be coming out yeah
please pray for this man he has a lot on
his plate as literally the only person
in this office that speaks fluent
Spanish but if you speak fluent Spanish
but if you know someone who speaks
Spanish and they are willing to give of
their time please reach out to us yes
lls.tv slash contact Dash us send us an
email let us know that you're interested
in how you can work together with Alex
to get these Productions out to the
world Amen okay I was getting ahead of
myself earlier yes but now we're back to
the behind the scenes stuff
well I mean like she was saying like
it's a lot of production you're in the
camera and stuff like that you know
sometimes you do a little mistakes or uh
happens to all of us your mini tanks or
something I mean sometimes you're
watching it's like oh how beautiful
really nice yes you never know all the
all the texts we do to make it make it
happen even though black panther too
I mean you you I mean she has a lot of
um
so you're going to be watching some of
the bloopers uh for the Spanish uh right
now watch this video
Tuesday is
Tuesday no
good
saludos is
martes
is
[Music]
momentos
.com
foreign
okay so now we're gonna go to learn more
about little SGS International and Candy
season in charge of that that's right
all right let's get into it so we
started off with little light Studios
just our main Channel Little Light
Studios in espanol then we have Little
Light Studios International we've had
this channel up for a little over a year
now I believe and how it all started is
uh someone who was in Brazil we speak
Portuguese they saw
um I believe it was one of our LED lives
no it was the one on on oh boy not
Dragon we were talking about Dragon Ball
Z but it was in preparation for the
anime.com he was like I really want to
share this video so he translated it he
dubbed the video and sent it to us we
were like this will be a little out of
place if we publish it on Little Light
Studios the main channel so we said okay
why don't we just have an international
Channel and then encourage more people
to trans help us translate videos and
that's what we did and so we started at
zero a whole new Channel and to the
today we have over a thousand people
subscribed to this channel
and it's growing so all the languages
that we have here we have M Herrick
Romanian
Macedonian you know anyone who speaks
Macedonia no in the Bible right yeah
exactly
Japanese
Russian
German and Portuguese we actually have a
lot of Portuguese videos shout out to
our Portuguese translators who are
continuing to send us videos to upload
and Romanian as well we have a few
Romanian speakers who continually send
us videos I just can't thank you enough
enough because literally this would not
exist without volunteers sending in
these dubbed videos so I just encourage
you
um if you do speak a different language
other than well yeah other than English
and Spanish and you'd like to share
Little Live Studio's Productions
worldwide to the people who speak your
language reach out to us we'll walk you
through it you don't have to be a top
tier video editor will take the time we
appreciate you we will take the time to
walk you through provide you with the
tools you need depending on the tools
and to get these videos out because
that's our goal to share it with the
world Amen really by any means necessary
I know yeah yeah this has been fun Alex
yeah me too I have a question for those
who are live with us and are active in
the chat do you speak a different
language if so put it in the chat don't
worry we won't like reach out to you to
for your help um only those who are
willing you can reach out to us and
we'll uh get in contact with you but if
you speak a different language or let's
say you've been to a different country
that speaks a different language put
that in the chat that'll be that'd be
really cool for us to see yeah and let's
share the gospel you know I mean I think
we had this technology and if you're
willing seriously to donate your time
and if you want to you know I mean you
got to if you have a phone I mean you
can record your voice that's true and
just go to the little and you closet or
something like that kind of quiet room
and just read and stuff like that and
like a candy said we can show you and
share with you how to do it things but
if you had the willingness to you know
to to record your voice and help us to
create those videos in different
languages I mean let's do it yeah and
let's share the gospel so we can go home
right we have a Romanian in the chat
shout out to you
we have someone who's learning Japanese
wow that's awesome someone speaks
Spanish all right cool that's good well
thank you so much all right well thank
you for those who have been with us
since this morning we have a lot more in
store today but we're going to take a
little break about 15-20 minutes please
enjoy the the pre-produced Productions
that we have to share with you and we'll
see you in a bit okay okay bye adios
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need to go out of your way to
help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world
better place
hey guys I got a tip for you to really
spice up your YouTube channel with
b-roll at videomission.com this guy I
hope through prophecy he's got 55 000
subscribers and he used one of our Clips
to illustrate the fall of Lucifer and he
used the snake in the Garden of Eden so
if you're looking for footage to
illustrate biblical topics check out
videomission.com
[Music]
thank you
is there any hope for me what can I do
to unify my family on not watching
harmful media how do I know my thoughts
are my own and how can I distinguish
between Impressions from God I'm nervous
when it comes to sharing my testimony it
is really that important I stopped
watching mainstream media now what
sometimes we get a lot of people asking
the same kind of questions so we thought
it would be cool to make these little
videos answering some of them in a new
series called I got a question concise
answers to your media related questions
we'd love to hear from you reach out to
us privately on our Instagram page or
Facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website
littlelightstudios.tv slash contact us
hey we're here to help
we're here to help you let your little
light shine
[Music]
foreign
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
foreign
to do something that lets someone know
you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
foreign
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
Blue Light Studios is a fade-based media
Ministry with a passion for today's
youth by God's grace our videos have
been circulating YouTube and reaching
thousands of people I mean seriously
thousands of people as the popularity of
our videos began to rise we realize a
problem what about the countries that
don't speak English we heard your
requests and having an answer by
creating new life Studios International
this YouTube channel is assigned to be a
hub for people to enjoy little life
Studios Production and their own native
tongue a big thank you to all the
volunteers who have helped us with
translation voiceovers and editing we
encourage you to utilize this Source by
subscribing and sharing our videos with
your friends and family
welcome to the video Bible study Series
where we will explore a variety of Bible
topics using video and print what is
humility do we need God's law can I
understand the Holy Spirit yes you can
and we're going to solve that today in
five minutes or less they're designed to
engage You by watching a five minute
video having a discussion on the topic
and Diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with Jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to
www.littlelightstudios.tv or find us on
your favorite social media platform
[Music]
thank you
you're a Seeker you're an artist you've
been looking for cinematic biblical
footage you've been creating amazing
pieces of footage and animations and you
can't find it and it's too expensive to
create but most of it doesn't end up in
your final project we've all been there
what are you gonna do with all those
Creations but what if you could buy it
why not sell it at an affordable price
well now
you can where you ask
[Music]
hi you might not know me because I work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name's Michael and I'm the
director of little live Studio's 3D
Department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology
where we are trying to blame reality
with the virtual world it's more
efficient and offer us the opportunity
to make higher quality Productions with
better visuals by using the online
engine software it gives us the
possibility to create realistic virtual
environments for sets in a short amount
of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have Financial limits that's why
we're working toward getting an LED wall
in the future because it will allow us
to use extended reality this simply
means that we don't need green screen
anymore
it will save us tremendous time in the
post-compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from Led wall which
matches the subject and the set in real
time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
so that's what we've been up to here at
little eye status
we're so thankful for the ways that God
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey I'm Scotty I'm Alex I'm Keith I'm
Mikey Michael hey I'm candy and we are
Little Light Studios and we like to
share the gospel with the Light of
Christ
light exposing Darkness so here at
Little Light Studios we actually really
want to inspire our audience to dig deep
into the Bible to know what you believe
to to know how to find the source of
Truth and to be able to analyze the
world around you and filter that through
the lens of the Bible yeah we're
actually on YouTube we have a weekly
show called LED live and that stands for
light exposing Darkness it's a show
where we use the Light of Christ to
expose the darkness found in media and
our culture today and our topics span
the gamut we talk about politics we talk
about movies and spiritualism and also
how to deepen your walk with Christ we
have hour-long shows we also have
shorter videos that you can share all
over the Internet worldwide but we don't
just have an LED show on YouTube We also
make documentaries we've made everything
from superheroes to how cartoons affect
your children to how media affects your
mind and right now we're working on an
anime documentary yeah so I'm excited
the anime project is just about finished
and we've got a couple more coming down
the pipe an alien just full disclosure
documentary which will be kind of fun
and uh we got a transhuman documentary
that we're working on as well we don't
just do videos though you can actually
wear your witness with our t-shirts we
have a brand called lightwear and it's
about not being ashamed of the gospel
and putting it out there that you're a
Christian and just a way to break the
ice about spiritual things when people
see that message they'll say hey what is
that Bible verse or what's that graphic
about it's a great way to to share the
gospel with with a complete stranger and
also we have Little Life Studio saying
in Spanish we have YouTube channel and
also we bring all the materials that we
have a little less serious in English to
a Spanish world so please follow us on
our social media and we do seminars too
we also have an international channel
for all the other languages if somebody
who that speaks another language wants
to translate our material we have one
single location on a YouTube channel
called Little Light Studios
International so check that out if you
you want to see what we're doing behind
the scenes make sure you get on patreon
where you can get lots of perks for
helping support our ministry if you love
these kind of contents please like
subscribe and share and thank you guys
hello my name is bonti and I have really
been blessed by this ministry it has
really blessed me
um I first started to know about through
a friend actually and she watched their
videos and she started recommending them
to the WhatsApp groups that we had
called the saved ones and for me
personally I was a bit skeptic at the
beginning because I personally grew up
watching movies we used to come back
from school and then you know turn on
the TV and watch movies especially
during the holidays and so getting to
see the truths revealed Behind these
movies actually just got me shocked that
I had never seen the truth behind them
before I had never seen the details of
actually what they say or what they act
or whatever they do
so through LED light Studios I was able
to get that truth and just my eyes were
opened and even though I was skeptic at
the beginning I really felt the
impression of the Holy Spirit to move
forward in faith and keep watching them
and the more I watch them the more the
truth was revealed to me so if you're
one of their viewers and you're kind of
like scared and skeptic it's okay at the
beginning you know that's what happens
sometimes but continue watching their
videos you will be blessed by it because
I have been blessed my sister has been
blessed my family has been blessed and
even my friends so thank you so much LED
lights to girls for continuing to share
the truth through your ministry and I
know so many other Youth and people will
gain hope and encouragement and also
that their eyes will be open to their
truth and also another thing that has
encouraged me through this ministry is
that to instead to instead rather spend
more time in the Bible in God's word and
actually opening God's word has just
made me understand it more instead of
spending three hours on a movie I have
started spending more time in God's word
and so I'm so thankful about that that I
am replacing my time with the good
things with things that help me grow
spiritually mentally emotionally and all
sorts of ways and so if you're thinking
about why should I replace my time with
now singing songs reading the Bible
having devotions with friends that's a
way in which you can replace that time
that you used to use for something else
and use it for the glory of God I hope
this can encourage you as well as much
as he has encouraged me bye
[Music]
hello my name is rameli japaiva I'm 16
years old and although my family is
originally from Brazil we live in the
United States right now so I found out
about Little Light Studios through a
inactive group chat from someone I
didn't know they sent the link in the
group chat and I decided to open it I
wasn't actually interested in the link
at first but about a week later I
decided to open it again and my father
and I watched our very first Ali Z Light
it was the MCU video about endgame and
we were really interested in what we
found although we are a very religiously
conservative we don't really watch
movies I grew up only watching
sporadically a movie with the family and
we're not very active on social media or
in the media in general uh we're still
aware of you know what happened to the
media of movies that come out recently
because we live in a society in a
community where people people are really
into media so I'm aware of things that
happen on social media and in the media
in general and at the time we were also
aware about the MCU although we never
watched a movie
um and it was really interesting to
really put those pieces together and
realize what kind of stuff is going into
the brains of people who watch things
like the MCU and other movies like live
life Studios talks about and ever since
then we've been watching their videos
we've loved every moment of it these
past 11 months have been very blessed as
we've learned so many amazing things and
we continue watching these videos
because at least for me it's like I've
been handed a new lens in which I can
see the world through what I love about
Little Light Studios is they um
they'll talk about a topic and they'll
give you the evidence and they'll
discuss a little bit and give their
opinions but they don't force their
opinion they don't force an agenda like
today's media does they allow you to
make that decision of what you're going
to do this information and they leave it
up to you and God whatever ends up
whatever you end up deciding and I think
that's so important because
um I go through a lot of decision making
when people ask if oh I want to see a
movie or something like that and
um learning how to discern whether I
should or not what the long-term
consequences and effects of that action
that I may take what it will do to my
spiritual life or my connection with God
has really helped me
um they've shed light on a lot of topics
that um that aren't really talked about
enough in the community especially like
demons and spirits I remember when I was
little thinking that you'd literally
just walk fly on the road and you could
get possessed and hurt and for no reason
but I'm so thankful that I learned it's
not something that happens overnight
it's a process
um something else that I feel really
happy that Levi Series has helped me do
is they've helped Empower me to be more
confident in sharing my faith and
knowing why I do things because a lot of
times people would ask oh why don't you
celebrate Halloween or why do you do
this or why don't you do this and I
sometimes didn't know why I did things
it was just something I did out of
traditionalism or someone told me to and
I'd do it and um it's a dangerous place
to be in because that turns off people
that
um makes them less receptive to this
wonderful gospel news that we have to
share with people
and it really empowered and made my
spiritual walk stronger and as a result
of watching these videos and learning
this information they have to share I've
been sharing videos in group chats just
like I found out about their life
Studios
um I've actually reached out to the
Light Studios and I've been helping them
translate some of their videos into
Portuguese they have an international
Channel if you didn't know where they're
translating their videos into other
languages so more people can be blessed
by that and it's been really fun
translating new videos and knowing that
I'm helping a little bit sharing that
blessing that was given to me and I
started writing about my findings and
movies that I've watched in the past or
that I hear people talking about
um I even had the courage to accept
speaking at a staff meeting at my school
and talk a little bit about little life
Studios and what they do and I've been
learning to utilize Zoom to do these
little slash shows and programs to talk
about Little Light Studios and topics
that aren't really talked about enough
especially in the community of young
people and talk about how yes the Devil
is a lot more powerful than we sometimes
think or give him credit to but likewise
God is even more powerful and we don't
talk about that enough sometimes and how
much power there is in following Christ
and I'm just so excited to see where
this channel leads me to in the future
and how they continue to grow and bless
others and I'm so excited to see where
God will lead me and the rest of the
rest of this spiritual journey that we
have and I'm so excited that I was able
to share this testimony thank you so
much to the light seduce what you guys
do and I'm so blessed and so excited to
be part of this low light serious
community of people who are really
serious about growing in their faith and
and learning about these amazing things
that little light Studios has taught us
so thank you so much all of you be
blessed and have a good day thank you so
much
hi guys I am Tanaka and I'm all the way
from South Africa I'm 21 years old
so how did our first year of Little
Light Studios it was two years ago when
I first came across a video which was
like an hour and something minutes and
it said Satan's end game not Marvel's
end game by Little Light Studios I think
this was the very first time I came
across this YouTube channel and I
watched this video and wow
it blew my mind and I told myself I'm
not going to watch endgame I grew up in
the church but I was never I was I
thought I was serious but I was not
serious enough so I was a Christian that
would watch movies listen to music and
you know do all these things that seem
normal until I watched this end games
I'm not Satan's end game and I actually
told myself that I'm not going to watch
endgame and I shared with all my friends
and told them guys do not watch these
things the devil's on a mission here
because the biblical language they were
using in the movie how they used to make
fun of Christ and it just showed me
things that I'd never would have seen if
it was not for the video anyways I I
found myself watching Marvel endgame
more than once it actually became my
favorite movie and I'd forgotten about
not that I'd forgotten about the video
from Little Light Studios that I'd watch
but it's just I didn't have power to
stop watching
um end game because of the hype that
move ahead and like I said it became my
favorite movie anyways fast forward I
actually wanted to become an actor
because I was told that you need to
choose your career based on your
personality and everyone always told me
you would make a very good actor or
you'd make a very good model so I
actually thought I should become a model
and an actress I was very interested in
fashion and in the fashion industry so I
need to kind of balance the two being an
actor and a fashion influence or fashion
model until I went to University and I
pursued the career of acting I was
studying drama and theater studies it
was interesting because the things that
I now know is exactly opposite to the
things that my religion says I should
believe for example like the way we
learned the Dark Ages in that time was
the Roman Catholic was this good church
that was playing moral acts when the
Bible is not in the picture but they
never told us actually who took the
Bible away and you know all the history
of the Dark Ages lockdown hits and I
think come back home because schools get
shut down and that's when I realized
that growing up in the church I linked
the lockdown and the chaos that was
taking place in the world with the mark
of the beast end of the world Jesus
coming and I saw myself as no I am not
ready so I kind of felt that you know
that that emptiness and that destitution
of not having Christ in my life and
that's when I realized that I need to
start reading my Bible so in this time
of reading my Bible and trying to equate
myself with a lot of spiritual things I
was on YouTube again and I stumbled upon
a video from Little Light Studios
because I subscribed to the channel and
this video now he directly home he did
the situation I found myself in and this
video if I'm not mistaken it was um or
you being entertained by demons right
and I was like whoa good question am I
being detained by demons uh I don't know
what's it about so I checked it out and
it was thinking about our actors and
movie directors are Chan handling evil
spirits to get into character how movie
script writers are actually
getting scripts of the best movies in
five minutes and I found this very very
interesting so I kind of posed the
question to myself saying wait am I
being entertained by demons but then I
realized that no I'm not being
entertained by demons I'm actually being
trained to be the Entertainer that the
demons use to entertain other people and
this hit me I was like okay no I'm in a
very dangerous position right now
because now I'm actually being trained
to lead many Souls astray and this
really hit me hard and honestly because
I'd watch the video I dropped everything
that I was doing I dropped school people
ask what you're going to do I was like I
don't know what I'm gonna do but I'm not
doing this anymore because this is evil
at a specific class which was called
movement this class was basically to
teach me how to meditate to bring my
mind and my body into one so when I
watch the video for from Little Light
Studios it made a lot of sense now
concerning that specific class that I
had and I dropped out of school Little
Light Studios really played an important
role in my life this video must be less
than five minutes so I'm ending it right
here but you guys played a very
important role in my life and in my
Christian Journey I'd like to thank you
so much for the work that you guys are
doing please give it up guys thank you
[Music]
foreign
hey guys for those of you who don't know
me or weren't here for the first half my
name is Brittany and I am the social
media manager here at Little Light
Studios and basically what my role is
here is just to keep you guys updated
about things that are going on in the
ministry whether it's speaking
engagement some places we've been
traveling to events that we're doing the
videos that we come out with I also do
the countdowns that you see on Instagram
where I let you guys know which video is
about to come out all those things that
come that is about letting you know
what's going on in the ministry I'm the
one who puts that stuff out there and so
I love my job I love being able to read
all the comments and connect with you
guys and we actually all take turns with
that so it's not just me that you're
talking to you really get like a
well-rounded response from all of us in
the office but how I got here was
actually a really cool Ministry a really
cool testimony in itself because I
actually was a student missionary in
Hong Kong back in 2019 and one of the
youth pastors there during a Vespers he
showed one of little lights videos I
believe it was follow your heart it was
one of those short clips that they had
on their YouTube channel and from there
they just became part of my Sabbath
morning routines especially because the
LED lives since I was 13 hours ahead
when they would go live on Ellie when
they would do the LED lives on Fridays
it would be Saturday morning for me over
there and so it just became a part of my
Sabbath morning routines and I remember
when I was just looking at all the
social media platforms really just
starting to follow the ministry I was
like oh God I wish that you could just
like I just pray that you could give me
the opportunity to work on their social
media platform because I know that it
could be so much stronger and they just
weren't as active on all the other
platforms as they were on YouTube and so
sure enough I ended up completing my
mission year I came back here to finish
my final year of college and then just a
few months before I graduated I ran into
Mikey at a bookstore and then from there
we just started talking he invited me
over to the office and then I got to
meet everybody and then that led to me
volunteering a little bit which led to
me having this job so it's been really
awesome the Journey of getting here and
also it's just been a really exciting
year for us as well for our social media
so for example not only have we been
able to reach people around the world
but we've been able to really increase
our reach in general so as you can see
here on Facebook just this year alone
we've been able to grow our follower
count by 52 000 so that puts us at a
hundred and five thousand followers this
year which is a lot and it's still
always growing so
there's also YouTube which we now have
almost 30 000 subscribers that we've
gotten just from this last year and so
we have almost 150k so if you guys could
just share this video share our platform
with other people and help help us get
to 150 by the end of the day that'd be
really awesome also we have Instagram
we've been able to grow this by 2000 so
now we're almost at 10 000 and then on
Twitter we have we've been able to grow
it 324 followers so we're at 3.1 K so if
you aren't following us guys please
follow us on all these social media web
um all these social media platforms
share them with all your friends and
I'll see you guys for the next segment
see when I was already watching you know
these Disney movies since I was grade
four of my time I never knew that they
were so dark until they knew what
they're done because you exposed them
and that is why early on I decided to
make a Ministry that exposes the dark
secrets of Disney movies and other
movies as well so tce Ministries also
known as the cartoon evangelist
Mysteries are devoted to
expose with the light of God's word so
that is why I want to say a big thank
you I watched your video about the dark
secrets of Disney and you know
this truth that I heard so much
it's like light to me so early on they
decided to start a Ministry which I
can't expose dark secrets of moons with
the line of God's word again that's my
Ministry of TC Ministries
early on
we decided that the ministry could reach
more children with the light of the word
of God so today I wanted to testify that
you are indeed a beacon of light too
many even for children of Amazon
hi guys my name is tafara choguguza and
I am from South Africa I'm 18 years old
I first came to know little light
Studios through Amazing Discoveries they
used to play on our television set and
they had a small segment in between each
program which would be on various topics
I remember one was on the Peter Pan
cartoon and the others on the Sims and
how it promotes all sorts of
immoralities and that's my first
encounter with little light Studios but
I didn't realize it was them until I
became more serious with my faith and I
saw the ministry on YouTube they really
inspired me because they had a different
approach to all the other Ministries
that I would see they were more targeted
to the young people and it's very rare
to see people that Target the youth and
we often just see adults ministering to
adults and because of this it motivated
me in two ways mainly being able to use
my interest in photography and
videography to actually work for God and
it also helped me realize that the youth
can be reached in a more effective way
so because of that I also engaged in
Ministry and there was a ministry that's
called voice of the end times which I
became a part of because of menaces like
little life Studios and others so we
began as a group of young people to
minister on the streets and we thought
no the streets is not enough we need to
share this with more people and because
of that we even started our own YouTube
channel
which we documented our experiences on
the street and all this was because of
other Ministries including little like
Ministries because they encouraged the
youth specifically to be engaged in
God's work and they sort of try to make
it cool and it's a really good approach
even though I had my doubts at first
because I would think that no these guys
are just trying to watch movies and
justified by saying we're exposing the
darkness but eventually I saw the only
way to reach those youth is actually to
show them things that apply to them and
the things that they see in their daily
lives and show them that this is where
you can actually be caught by the devil
so I would like to thank you guys at
Little Live Studios for your ministry
and for taking the time out to reach
young people like myself and inspiring
us to work for Christ thank you
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that let someone know your
thing of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
yeah
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]
foreign
welcome everybody we want to introduce
our graphic designer to you because
we've been talking a lot about these
t-shirts and this is really how the
t-shirts get made Regine is very
talented and Regine tell us a little bit
about uh lightwear we recently did a
redesign when we first came up with the
logo for this we weren't quite sure what
we wanted and so we really sat down we
started talking about it and what do we
come up with so you can check our new
logo or branding in all our social media
but mainly our website it's at light or
dot shop we just fully rebranded it and
yeah I think the new logo is actually on
fire I mean it's really on fire like
it's really a cool logo it's pretty cool
when you came up with the idea it's
really a t and a t-shirt that's
literally on fire and you know kind of
like we got the inspiration from you're
supposed to be sharing the light right
you know using the holy spirit to guide
those conversations and the the idea
behind the T-shirt Ministry is what
Keith
the idea behind the T-shirt Ministry is
to really wear your witness and you
could say that multiple ways but that's
the idea Deuteronomy talks about that
um
you know your whole life is really a
sermon and so
the way we kind of look at it is you're
going to wear somebody's branding
so you might as well be branded with
things that promote Christianity and so
that's what we like to do so and it's so
true like when you see somebody wearing
like Nike so to say what do you think of
that that brand actually gives you an
idea about something that that person
believes in yeah and so this is really
like um just maybe hopefully sparking a
conversation or you know hopefully if
you're wearing something that says Jesus
on it you're nice to everybody yeah
especially if you're actually wearing
your witness but we want to show you
some of these cool designs
um because a lot of them are just really
taking cultural ideas now um I don't
know if you've seen the t-shirt that is
uh says obey on it
um but that's kind of like a pop culture
you'll see these things all over cities
and and stuff so we kind of redesigned
that and uh really just said you know
like uh we should really be worshiping
God so yeah uh we'll come up with
Concepts like this and maybe this will
speak to somebody this one's original it
was hand drawn by another graphic
designer that we had once upon a time
and she kind of gave us a little bit of
uh pushback on this because it was too
drippy
but actually it's been one of our more
popular designs and uh somebody actually
put this as an Acro they made an acrylic
painting out of this and just sent us
their paintings that was really cool
so yeah original design there I
con is really cool Regine you came up
with this design uh tell me a little bit
about this one
um I guess it's like the NASA logo but
you know pray because God is the creator
of the universe space I don't know so
it's kind of taking a catchy
um recognizable image and sort of
putting a spin on it that makes people
think of something spiritual about it
but I I like this design this one's
really cool we we've actually printed
quite a few of these all kinds of new
designs yeah there's a bunch of neat
designs if you guys haven't checked
these out you know we're coming up to
holiday season and maybe uh you're
looking for some cool gift to give to
somebody here's a great way to give them
a gift that helps them hopefully think
of Eternal things and also is something
nice to wear maybe we'll start a
conversation but check out lightwear dot
shop yep cool yeah
see when I was already watching you know
these Disney movies since I was grade
four
in my time I never knew that they were
so dark until they knew they're done
because you exposed them
and that is why early on I decided to
make a Ministry that exposes the dark
secrets of Disney movies and other
movies as well so tce Ministries also
known as the cartoon evangelist
Mysteries are devoted to
expose with the light of God's word so
that is why I want to say a big thank
you I watched your video about the dark
secrets of Disney and you know
this truth that I heard so much
it's like light to me so early on they
decided to start a Ministry which you
can expose dark secrets of moons with a
lot of God's word again that's my
Ministry TC Ministries
early on
we decided that the ministry could reach
more children with the light of the word
of God so today I wanted to testify that
you are indeed a beacon of light too
many even for children from Amazon
hi everyone a new study found that 40 of
three-month-olds are regular TV Watchers
would you believe that one third of all
three-year-olds in America have a TV in
their bedrooms no I can't believe it
it's kind of disturbing everywhere you
go we are saturated with media the baby
who watched two hours of TV a day before
the age of three would be 20 more likely
to have attentional problems at age
seven the frontal lobe of the brain is
the seat of spirituality Morality In the
will Entertainment Television suppresses
the frontal lobe of the brain the humans
are particularly visual animals what you
see is not necessarily
a carbon copy of reality what you see is
a gradual coding and reconstruction of
the signal in neurologic terms and in
that process a lot of interpretation
goes on we have more depression than
ever before in human history more
anxiety mental health problems are
skyrocketing throughout the world and
the entertainment medium is one of the
primary reasons why this is occurring
more reason to keep infants and toddlers
away from television is there a danger
to exposing the mind to realities that
don't really exist the bottom line of
basically NFP any change work any
conditioning any brainwashing it goes
down to emotions
well with hypnosis they're still trying
to find out exactly what the mechanisms
are that are working in the brain but
now with the Neuroscience they're really
finding out fast with neural Cinema
technology filmmakers can now look
inside your mind and make better movies
we're experimenting right now with
30-foot labyrinths in 3D and the result
is an experience that is so close to
reality it's called d-box and it's set
to cause quite a sensation it's being
tried out
really enjoyed how it made me feel like
I was in the movie you're actually in
the movie in the movie as if I was in
the scene myself
but the idea of real in cinema as in you
know because Pandora's meaningless now
exactly the idea of what's real it
doesn't take an Einstein baby or
otherwise to understand what this means
so back to television back to the movies
when you start to have a belief change
or you think it's a certain way you say
hey don't watch that or don't do that
yourself people go nah they have reasons
a whole bunch of why they can't be
hypnotized
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
foreign
to do something that lets someone know
you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world
[Music]
foreign
nice jacket you like that
since there's a lot of green behind you
what's going on okay so
we're discussing a very pop culture
iconic movie called The Matrix and it
really has like really deep
philosophical Roots they're trying to
discuss what's behind the veil
um and you know there's this there's
this theme of the one that was
prophesied to come and save all the
people it has all this Christian
terminology
but when you really sit down and you
kind of start to analyze it it's it's
absolutely opposite of that and so um
we're making a little video about it
they just released a new one the very
first one was released on Easter weekend
back in 1999 I don't think that's by
Chance the last one that they released
called resurrections was just released a
couple days before Christmas I don't
think that's a uh by chance either so
you know this being a illustration for
Jesus tons of Christians have attributed
him to Jesus but really uh as you will
see in this video
is quite opposite than than Jesus so
we're putting a little video out about
it seems like oh big big plans because
the big screen and you asked about the
green screen
so uh we didn't have a lot of space to
build a set and so the easiest solution
for us is really we're trying to mimic a
very iconic chair that was in the movie
and a little bit of a scene that was in
the movie as well and um Michael's built
the background in CG so we're we're uh
we're just shooting and then they're
gonna put me in a digital chair
any response we have a CG background
there yeah okay let's check that out
so here you see that's one of our camera
angle
they were trying to recreate the scene
of Matrix
okay so the dummy is where Scotty is
going to be sitting yeah we're gonna
replace Scotty so
and here's another camera angle where
he's sitting right now so that's the
chair he was talking about yeah that's
gonna be the chair he's talking about
the iconic amorphous chair yeah and
we're like we're gonna remove the
mannequins
that's cool so you built this
yeah I've been getting this set so the
set is not exactly the same but
look at the idea
okay yeah it's gonna be cool so
follow our Channel awesome job Michael
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
so as you guys can see there's kind of a
lot of effort that goes into each one of
these little Productions in fact we try
to put as much creativity in as possible
yeah and I think sometimes when people
watch our videos and maybe if you have
any sort of production experience you
might go oh wow they actually put some
effort into that I love us really like
why don't you do a movie about this why
don't you make it look better or
whatever I mean Mikey some of the things
that we've done how long have you spent
on one minute of video oh yeah sometimes
some days it's like a whole day and
you're like what I got two minutes of
video done you know yeah because it's
not just the creative aspect but then
you're waiting on the computer to render
it I have to do an after effects and
pull it over to Premiere and different
things yeah and and you know it's like a
book cover right
um there's already a level of of voices
in the world that are really competing
for attention and you know unfortunately
the reality of the people that we're
really trying to reach if they're really
immersed in a lot of this Hollywood
stuff
they're they're exposed to tons of this
kind of content that's that's that's
they spent hundreds of millions of
dollars right and we're having to
compete against that we don't have that
kind of luxury of financing
um so we try to be as creative as
possible to actually just get the
attention so they'll sit there and
actually watch it
um and maybe learn something from it so
we thought it'd be kind of cool for you
guys to see a little bit of our thought
process as we go over and we talk about
this video um we'll play it you can hear
kind of a director's commentary on it as
we've talked about it this is one of the
um the video productions I think that uh
that uh I was big into the Matrix for
you yeah me too definitely yeah this was
something that uh definitely I watched
tons of times yes even as a Christian I
could not put my finger on it it wasn't
until I really he kind of opened my
heart back to God and started really
reading my Bible that I started saying
hey what they're discussing in this does
not make sense and what's interesting is
being a part of like the truther
community that we are this movie is kind
of Herald up like yes wake up from the
Matrix fight the system and all that and
that's how Satan portrays it that's how
he packages it Satan never comes out
with just a lie he comes out with
deception a lot of Truth a little bit of
error so he wraps it up in these things
that you can identify with but then the
gnosticism is always thrown in there
this anti-christian message and you're
going to see that it's undeniable yeah
so this scene that we're going to open
up here with is um probably one of the
most iconic scenes in The Matrix
um
this is the uh the the infamous pill
scene between Morpheus that's the
inspiration of the chair came from and
the pill is really where they're
discussing
um him making the choice to to be woken
up right so March 31st what's the
significance about that
Easter weekend oh hey there's a white
rabbit up there there's like I think
there's like seven hidden white rabbits
in this uh documentary here and yeah
like the Matrix was so iconic that that
everybody did a parody of it yeah
there's there's references in all kinds
of cartoons pop culture is really kind
of like responded well to this movie and
they really push the boundaries with the
technology like this was
the they pioneered the whole like moving
the camera while it was in pause and
things like that
yeah this was really fun like setting it
up to where you were in that chair and
Michael was this is interesting what
they say right here what is real what is
reality even in my own life just looking
around and being like Oh my God we're in
The Matrix I would literally think that
it's sort of impossible to articulate
how it's seeped into our minds and
culture I can't even remember not have
member of my life before the world of
the Matrix The Matrix as an idea has
lasted 20 years people use terminology
like are you going to take the red pill
you either don't take that blue pill
you're gonna take the red everything
entered pop culture and stayed we say a
glitch in The Matrix the fact that
that's part of the likes of God I think
this is one of the few movies that has
really has seeped its way into every
kind of facet of popular culture I'll
run into young people who've done
college courses all of the philosophies
and ideas around the matrix it's this
amazing magical mythological world that
has been created using numbers and
digits but it's actually about
Consciousness it's actually about four
you'll hear the sentences the nature
exchanged my life that's all right let's
see thank you change mine too the books
so I just want to put it on pause right
here for a second because that was a
little trailer that was promoting the
new Matrix and they released that
talking about the influence of it this
movie has had on the world oh yeah well
all the time we hear people say look
this move it's just a movie I know the
difference between fiction and reality
like we don't know they're implying that
we're idiots because we're we can't
differentiate between reality and
fiction but these people are literally
telling you the Matrix changed my life
yeah I no longer think the same because
of a movie yeah and this isn't just them
you can look you know I've heard that
testimony over and over from people it's
one more piece of evidence when people
say it's just a movie like why are you
guys making such a big deal about this
look at this movie changed people's
lives and so if this has the capability
to change a world mindset yeah we should
be careful what kind of media we're
allowing into our lives this could
obviously plant ideas into your mind and
and you know vernacular into your brain
and all sorts of stuff like exactly what
the actors are saying yeah so um I
thought that was really interesting that
they were that honest and even Keanu
Reeves himself he's like this movie
channel changed my life too right
that have been written on The Matrix
yeah there's Bibles written
so Christians are actually writing stuff
about this saying oh you can see the
gospel in The Matrix
how do you think they see the how do you
think they see the gospel in The Matrix
because they're using terminology and
there is a lot of scenes that were in
The Matrix that that that had tie-ins
into biblical Concepts the
Nebuchadnezzar that was the name of the
ship okay
um and so when you came in did you look
at it from a Christian perspective
because there's saying that he's the one
that's prophesied to come and and
actually like you know change the world
yeah he's like Jesus he's the one that's
gonna change the world and wait but it's
interesting what they say right here
listen to this
it has a record of everything
[Music]
God sees everything that you've been
living
he lives two lives one life you're
Thomas a Anderson program writer for a
respectable software
you have a Social Security number you
pay your taxes
so you follow the rules it does good
thank you good thanks nicely the other
life is
the shooters
where you go by the hacker Alias Neo and
you're guilty of virtually every
computer crime we have alone for okay so
if he has two lives and he's literally a
hacker he does bad things that's not
really like Jesus yeah so even right off
the bat Jesus did not have a a alternate
life that he was living that was not
following the rules that's true so
that's where the departure really comes
from and people that want to equate this
character to Jesus he's not like Jesus
right I mean he tells you like the
Superman yeah they tell you right in the
beginning yeah so it's very interesting
the information that's told to us he has
two lives almost like Jesus was God in
heaven and then came down to our Earth
as a man his name was Thomas Anderson
right oh this is just amazing first part
of the word Anderson is Ander which
comes from the Greek word man his name
is also Neo which is Greek for new so
he's the new son of man
the Bible says
will tell for the son of
the Sonos that's like such a cool
breakdown you know Anderson son of man
new Neo son of man well there's a lot of
references that he's like Jesus when
he's sitting there drinking with Cipher
and you know he's like wow you're here
to save the world man I mean that's a
reference to Jesus and if somebody comes
to his door and he's like oh you're my
own personal Jesus Christ yep
so you know the fact that they're
putting this idea out there that he is a
Christ type but then showing that he's
like he's this evil character to me is
very Antichrist right so these guys who
are now women uh they were very open and
honest that the names had very specific
meanings so we're not thinking too deep
like people are always like you think it
too deep about it I think it's funny
that it seems like every time we do dig
deep we see the same theme why would it
be the same way every time well and the
creators are thinking this deep yeah so
you know as you're watching this and
you're going why are you guys thinking
too too deep it's like but the creators
are are really intimately deeply
thinking about each of the names the
meanings the the thing is a slap in the
face to the writers to say oh it's
mindless entertainment whoa these
writers are spinning a lot of time yeah
I mean I thought this was pretty
interesting too the fact that they were
gonna call her switch because they were
putting this transgender idea out there
but the society wasn't ready for that
yet oh yeah and then later they actually
say that was the whole concept of the
Matrix because both these guys who are
brothers
transformed now they're both females now
yep so the fact that they were putting
those cultural ideas and they're knowing
that this would be a movie that would
that would greatly impact the world
they're putting their ideas and their
World Views in there so the whole
message is about there's no set rules
you can change whatever you can bend you
can be a gender bender you can change
the rules that's what they're pushing in
the whole thing yeah
so anybody that's really defending this
knowing or unknowing is defending a
movie about transgenderism
and that's not from us that's from the
directors right right right yeah there's
all the parallels where he's like Jesus
they purposely made him like even the
artwork I mean there's this much thought
that goes into simply putting the um
poster out there I don't think people
realize that there's a lot of thought
there's there's meetings that people
have that sit there and meticulously go
through every item that's in the scene
right I mean they do not just randomly
put items in a scene by Randomness
Mark three number eleven
I mean for somebody to make the decision
to make this sign and tell you to put
the Bible verse on the name of the ship
is that's some thought that went into
that and the Bible verse is about the
son of man which Anderson knew son of
man and that's when Neo is getting
introduced to the scene and for the very
first time and introduced to the people
of the ship I want to say I I think this
documentary was a little underrated you
guys need to watch it if anybody's
watching right now and hasn't seen it
it's really good I'm watching it now I'm
like excited about it again you know
well there's just a lot of detail here
and I think that one thing this kind of
hopefully will do is to teach people to
just look at the imagery what's the
message that's been trying to be told to
you I mean look he's in a Christ type
pose yeah I mean there is so much
biblical imagery interwoven in between
the dialogue and here he's talking about
you're a child of Zion a child of Zion I
mean that's a Biblical concept for
heaven and then they're going to show
Zion and it's nothing like heaven it's
actually a complete opposite he says
where's Zion
So gnosticism for anybody that doesn't
know it's literally an inversion of the
Bible Satan or Lucifer he was the hero
that tried to save Adam and Eve from a
tyrannical God that put him in this
guard in prison and he said yeah God
doesn't want you to have knowledge so
this is Zion this is what heaven should
look like with like molten lava it pans
down it's showing you this is down and
people at a gigantic Rave I mean this is
just looks like orgies this looks like
hell yeah
but yeah this is and these are all the
people that want to break free from the
system of the Matrix yep which is a
world that was created it's the same
thing you see in The Truman Show Truman
was put in this perfect world where
everything was good but in the end he
found out he was in this perfect world
and wanted to go out the dark the door
of the darkness and God basically spoke
to him from the Sun and said I've been
watching you your whole life this is a
perfect world there's nothing but pain
and misery out there and Truman says
bye and he goes right through the door
and the whole watching World cheers that
he left Eden
wow man it's just the same way of The
Matrix
identity because when you see like the
real world that they exit into it's like
it's pretty terrifying yeah it's
literally uh you know just an upside
down reversal view of what the Bible
would describe as as a utopian heaven
right now
blending all kinds of religious and
philosophical yeah
Buddha to Jesus to Frederick Nietzsche
who absolutely didn't even believe in
God hated God to Philip K dick the
wikowskis were heavily influenced by
Philip tabig and Philippe dick was a
gnostic writer so when the wikowski
brothers were asked in an interview
do you know that your movie The Matrix
has a lot of Gnostic themes in it they
said do you consider that to be a good
thing I would wow if you look through
YouTube
like they're blatantly telling you it is
Gnostic but yeah it will be accused of
making something out of nothing that I
I tell people that are questioning this
kind of material because there's always
there's always you know people that get
on our Channel and they want to really
like you know pick apart what saying or
anything like this I hope that you
question the media in the same manner
that you would question this like you
know um if you're if you're all of a
sudden questioning somebody saying hey
that doesn't make sense or hey that's
flipping the Bible upside down right I
hope that you're going to the media and
saying hey that doesn't make sense hey
you're flipping the Bible upside down
because if you're not questioning that
media but then all of a sudden you're
sitting there questioning the ministry
that's trying to point it out uh that's
a problem yeah it's like let's let's
fight amongst ourselves instead of going
to The Source Who admit that they are
doing this right we don't we don't just
like make something enough and we like
to show this is what the director said
this is what the writer said this is
what the actor said it's coming right
from their mouths but yeah
they don't want to receive it yeah
oh here's what gnosticism is in fact the
gnostics turned the story of the Garden
of Eden upside down because the serpent
was a rather engaging character after
all the serpents said to Eve
take some of the fruit from the Tree of
the knowledge of Good and Evil and to
gnostics that sounded like a wonderful
invitation wouldn't you like to have a
bite of an apple of knowledge gnostics
believe that we have a spark of divinity
inside of us you can see that same Lie
from the Tree of knowledge of Good and
Evil still being so what's kind of crazy
is this is a concept that early
Christians dealt with way back when the
um disciples yeah when the disciples
were going around and and teaching and
preaching about Jesus and the characters
of The Bible and really trying to you
know tell about Jesus there was these
groups of gnostics that were running
around and trying to flip that model
upside down on the head and saying you
know like the serpent in their Garden
he's the good guy and Judas the one that
deceived Christ he's the good one you
know but it's interesting that we still
see this in our modern world today and
this is how it's done dude when I was
was watching this scene it was just so
dark like when we used to watch it it
was like cool but now when I'm looking
at it it's literally satanic
Neo is sitting here having a
conversation with this guy who's wearing
a leather jacket from head to toe but
look at the pattern on the jacket dude
yeah the one you're wearing and the the
shot that's cow skin this is snake skin
dude's wearing a snakeskin trench coat
and I never recognize that ever
dude those are snake scales and he's
bald there's no hair on him this is a
representation of the snake now what is
he doing he's having a conversation with
Neo saying
eat this your eyes will be able to force
you I can only present this option to
you and that's what the devil was doing
to Eve in the Garden of Eden this scene
right here you can always tell a gnostic
film because they have an apple eating
scene there's always this idea between
you're choosing between good and evil
and it's done in this type of way wow I
wonder if there's any reference to that
water I know he drinks it to swallow the
pill but yeah and you'll notice that
what he hands them to eat is red and we
know that the Bible doesn't say that
it's an apple but it's always
represented by an apple and art
um and entertainment and stuff and so he
wants truth I'm going to give you colors
have a lot of meaning behind them even
in the Bible colors have a lot of
meaning blue in the Bible was
representative of the law because the
the God told the priests to put a Hem of
blue around their garments and that was
to signify the law so it's interesting
to me that he's choosing between red and
blue and red being the the the color of
you know what we yeah yeah exactly what
we choose as the Apple so to say it
wasn't an apple but um it's the imagery
that they're after
oh and he's straight like quoting the
Bible you cannot taste you cannot touch
oh man this is crazy he's using biblical
language in this scene oh look you can
see the parallels
like even the fact that he's wearing
those glasses they kind of make his eyes
look reptilian or whatever
yep yeah even the expression on this is
like where's this sort of he knows he's
not doing it right right
and I noticed this too about the blue
you have to see it for yourself wow that
you have to experience what evil is
know or understand people
that was what the devil was offering was
do you want the knowledge of Good and
Evil you have to experience it yourself
this is your last chance after this
there is no turning back
you take the blue pill the law the story
ends you wake up in your bed and believe
whatever you leave whatever you want to
take the red pill you stay in Wonderland
and I show you how deep the rabbit hole
goes like he's literally saying you're
gonna go down a rabbit hole Yeah
remember
all I'm offering is the truth nothing
the truth Morpheus telling me
he's not offering you eternal life he's
not offering you salvation he's offering
you just what he calls the truth
and honestly was his life better off and
and you know Adam and Eve their eyes
were open to sin something that God
didn't want them to see who wants to
know about murder and death and look at
the evil smile on his face while he's
eating it and the lightning in the
background going on and then it's
interesting that he finished that up
with follow me follow me I mean it's
like very typical right yeah Jesus wants
you to follow him but now Satan's saying
oh you ate all right and don't you find
it interesting in our world today that
people are always like follow us follow
us follow me on Tick Tock follow me on
Twitter the concept's still the same
even when Jesus's day there was people
what did you follow did you follow the
religious leaders did you follow it you
know Jesus did you follow what did you
follow we're all like sheep literally
and we are all just wandering around and
who are we actually following wow
all of a sudden you hear these little
biblical buzzwords but in a bad context
such as this
guns I mean look at that what do you
need besides a miracle guns lots of guns
you know what I mean like you're gonna
be the one that's gonna that's the Jesus
yeah and now Jesus walks into the
building and blows people away with an
AK-47 blown away from everybody these
are law enforcers that he's killing the
law isn't that crazy I mean this movie
is so common every time we watch it we
see more and more stuff so complex that
I believe only a satanic mind can design
something like this because human mind
can't do it you could literally go
through the Matrix and almost every
minute of this movie is just
mind-blowing like this
yeah we see something very interesting
look at this in the numbers that are
falling to the screen it stops and the
camera shows at the very top left of the
screen five five five five is a very
interesting number because there is a
lot of Hollywood movies that always use
the number 555. if you've ever seen
anybody numerology it's always 2555
something something
yeah but it's very interesting what 555
actually stands for
if you just look at what is the meaning
of 555 on the internet the urban green
witch shows you that when you see the
number 555 it means an angel is trying
to give you a message and a big change
in transformation is coming your way so
555 is really White Rabbit yeah 555 is a
witch's number yeah and um it's often
used in conjunction with witchcraft
um so it's interesting to me that
Hollywood obviously being you know the
Holly wood is a which is one to put
people to sleep that's why Harry Potter
uses the Hollywood that's what his wand
is made out of right and and it's
witchcraft really I mean they're casting
people to be in the videos and things
like this like all of it has like this
very interesting
um witchcraft type terminology with it
what I think it's interesting is it says
555 and it says that it's an angel
trying to give you a message and okay
Lucifer is an angel trying to give Adam
and Eve a message about a new beginning
it's right I'm going to open your eyes
take you to A Whole New World yeah it's
true and that's why this is really such
a complexly deep you know you can't make
this stuff up you can't there's no way
we can just sit there and see this over
and over and over what about this even
the book The the book was required
reading let's look how it says nihilism
on the top right nihilism is basically
doing away with rules and laws
um and it's empty
emptiness yeah look at this the
rejection of religious moral principles
that was required reading for all the
actors if you were going to be in this
movie you had to read this book you had
to read that book that's insane and and
the whole book was this flipped upside
down
um version basically saying that there
is no truth and things like this so you
know you think about how impacted this
indoctrination it's indoctrination only
the people that are going to watch the
movie the people that were in the movie
it's like they're that's why this movie
is on a totally different level no
wonder he said the Matrix changed my
life too you had to read this gnosticism
and then play in it and your whole
mind's getting warped with this theology
and it's not just a movie about waking
up to the the system or whatever that
we've all had our eyes kind of open to
because they're purposely putting in
this anti-christian theme like eat this
thing I'm dressed like a snake right now
I had watched this movie multiple times
when I was sort of wanting to be a
filmmaker because uh this is this this
was in the early 2000s it was kind of
the gold standard this really did change
filmmaking oh yeah people people watch
this movie a bunch of times because they
broke all kinds of ground with like the
shots and the camera angles and things
all the time yeah and remember I grew up
in Christianity so I grew up with a lot
of biblical understanding I didn't see
any of this yeah couldn't see any of
this we've been blinded by the God of
this world totally blinded by the God of
this world and so I hadn't watched this
movie for years look at that green snake
skin tie man interesting I hadn't
watched this for years and then coming
back and re-watching this just to do
this production
I was just flipping through and looking
at different scenes on YouTube that were
on there just randomly selecting
different scenes just for like b-roll
and stuff and it was like scene after
scene after scene I mean we could have
done a five hour show I remember yeah it
was just like that because you had
already done a presentation like this
one of the first presentations you ever
put together and you got the concept but
then
10 years later looking at the footage
again it's like whoa like this this was
pretty crazy wow a girl in a red dress
walking by may not seem like out of
place
listen to this scene the camera starts
on a do not walk sign and notice
everybody is wearing black and white
in the crowd and when the light goes
green the people start walking across
the crosswalk and Morpheus and Neo are
walking backwards this is not accidental
that system is our enemy when you're
triceps
lawyers Carpenters
so wait a minute did you just catch that
he said teachers lawyers and Carpenters
you see Jesus was a teacher he also was
a carpenter and the Bible describes
Jesus as your Advocate which is another
name for a lawyer all three of those
describe an aspect of Jesus and he's the
enemy
teachers lawyers Carpenters the very
minds of the people we are trying to
save but until we do these people are
still a part of that system and that
makes them our enemies
he's saying the very people were trying
to save he's even using biblical
Terminator Jesus came to save us but
he's saying no the lawyers and all the
the cop they're the ones who are trying
to save you from what's going on with
this so the fact that there's a woman in
a red dress is very interesting biblical
Revelation Revelation talks about a
woman deceiving the nations in a red
dress and in this scene they're using
the woman in the red dress to try and
trick and deceive the attention of Neo
so I think it's interesting that they're
using this imagery which is biblical
imagery yeah oh and the woman when
there's a woman in a white wedding dress
that walks by him in a city that doesn't
even make sense that he does not even
notice yeah yeah if you're in a white
dress where's your where's your husband
like aren't you getting married yeah
you're supposed to be in the church and
everything so the fact that he walks
right by her doesn't even notice her and
his attention go like goes to the Harley
he's wandering after the Harlot right
and in in this story remember the boy
says that he can hook him up with the
girl and that he's a digital pimp so
she's a harlot in the story she's a
harlot
and yeah we've talked about the whole
black and white system they're saying
that this system that's evil is all
about black and white there's no gray
area it's right or wrong but that system
is evil right we need one that you can
bend the rules and sometimes even break
the rules right very interesting yeah
they keep throwing this kind of imagery
all over in the place you've got a dove
ironically framed over him subliminal
propaganda if if they took a picture of
President Trump with a dove flying over
his head people would point that out and
say you're trying to make him look like
a messiah or something right
right the law enforcement
the law is the enemy I've seen an agent
and that's what he literally they're
literally saying the rules is the enemy
we want a world with no rules are still
based in a world that is built on rules
they will never be as strong or as fast
as you can be so Morpheus so the enemy
is a group of people that order their
life after rules and because they
actually order their life after rules
they will never be as strong they're
being held back
isn't that interesting wow but the Bible
says that he that Jesus gives the laws
of Liberty because the laws of Liberty
are keeping you out of bondage to sin
you want to be liberated you keep God's
Commandments because it's sin that has
you in bondage not the laws not the
rules the devil is always flipping
everything upside down on its head like
you said he's proclaiming that if you
just do whatever you want it's actual
freedom but it's not Freedom it's
bondage bondage to sin right true
Freedom comes when God releases us from
that bondage of that sin this is pretty
interesting too so the enemies are three
identical beings speak each other's
words finish each other's sentences
third movie Neil dies oh yeah this is
placed in a crucifixion pose where when
the machine is finished and he dies that
is exactly what Jesus said as he was
taking his last breath and giving his
Spirit up to God
it is done it is this is finished it is
that's not an accident that doesn't just
happen like it doesn't even make sense
yeah you die in a crucifix pose any and
you quote the words it is done yep
there's there is a lot of imagery with
the machine the architect being like God
and so the whole Matrix is really a
representation of God everybody follows
the rules and the laws and so it's about
him
breaking away from that this is deep
listen to this I know that you're afraid
you're afraid of us you're afraid of
change
I don't know the future God never
changes I didn't come here to tell you
how this is going to end he doesn't know
the future to tell you how it's going to
begin
I'm going to hang up because God knows
the future then I'm going to show these
people what you don't want them to see
wow I'm going to show them a world
without you
a world without rules and controls
Without Borders or boundaries no border
world no boundaries but anything is
possible
wow
where we go from there
if you remember that's right after he
got shot dies is resurrected back to
life and so in the end when he's talking
on the phone there in the first Matrix
it's literally like a scene where Jesus
gets resurrected and then after he talks
to The Matrix he ascends into the sky so
this is like Jesus Jesus absolutely
absolutely an antichrist he died was
resurrected and then he calls God and
says I'm going to show people a world
without rules without you a world where
they can do anything that is the
Antichrist that is not a representation
of Jesus and so when new son of man even
sounds like an antichrist not so not the
old son of man the new son of man so
when people take a movie like this and
then they begin to equate those
characters to Jesus that's very
problematic because in the end of time
Jesus is coming again that's what the
Bible says he's coming to take his
people back before that before that
happens Satan is going to try and also
trick the people one last time and so I
believe all these things are subtly
planting these ideas into people's minds
and they will be more sympathetic to in
Antichrist spirit and we see that with
all kinds of movies even these like
um the the movies that are coming out
about the villains oh Maleficent she was
her mom abuser oh the Joker he had
mental issues like oh it's always like
Sympathy for the villain yep and then
even turn them into the good guys like
Venom he's helping the you know it's
like people say I don't know is he good
guy is a bad guy anti-hero yep wow so
this was really a breakdown of all of
the kind of first Trilogy that happened
and then like it said right there at the
end the new one came out called
resurrections very interesting title to
begin with and it was released on
Christmas day so the first movie came on
Easter which you know it came out around
that that's a direction day type thing
yeah exactly that's not untypical for
um you know Springtime or for Christmas
time to to have a release because
there's a lot of people that will go and
see like spring break and summertime and
things like that but but because name
the title Resurrection exactly you're
getting really like close to you know
biblical ideas and then releasing it
near Christmas is pretty telling yeah
so this was the newest one didn't get
the best ratings but had the same
messages in it but it was throwing in
there in there kinds of cultural
messages for today so there's a lot of
transgender ideas that are put in there
there's a lot of role reversal between
the characters between male and female
and all sorts of stuff like this because
that's what the okowski brothers are
into there's or sisters or whatever
so this one transitioned first and then
this guy followed suit now they're both
they're the Kelsey sisters now
the very end after the credits the
creators try to deconstruct this
perception through humor media is
nothing but new to trigger response and
vital conditioning wait what are you two
talking about although this scene was an
after credit scene it's quintessential
to understanding the mindset of the
Riders Nero trigger response is often
talked about in PTSD patients where the
soldier has been conditioned to a
specific involuntary response to a sound
or situation in short the character is
saying that media is nothing but
training our brain to respond without
thinking in the second part he says
media is viral conditioning or being
quickly programmed to act a certain way
so essentially the writers have said
media is nothing but quickly training
our brain to act a certain way without
considering the moral consequences of
course a bit of humor is attached to the
end to make sure that the audience
doesn't think too much about it and yeah
because what they're saying is absolute
truth like right this is literally
programming it's called programming and
the irony
argue all day long like whatever I'm not
affected by this I can watch all this
stuff and it's not having an impact upon
my personal life but the creators 100
know that that's going to have an
influence on you yeah you imagine
telling the Creator oh you don't affect
me and it's like really you're wearing
the shirt that I created or whatever
yeah it's like you're going to cosplay
dress like the person acting like the
person
it's like it's almost like you wish you
could be that person I wish I could be
Neo
was to tell the story of transgenderism
Lily Wilkowski confirmed this finding
when he exposed the true hope for the
movies was to be this transsexual
analogy he even originally wrote Into
the film a character that would change
identities between the real world and
the Matrix I didn't like this
and I'd like this The Matrix stuff was
all like about the desire for
transformation this is one of them
wikowski brothers is now identifying as
a woman
telling us it's about yeah
the real world or and then a woman in
The Matrix and both were
our head spaces were I'm glad that it
has gotten out that um you know that was
the original intention but I'm glad that
it's gotten out this is the director too
I don't think people realize this enough
yeah like these guys are putting ideas
in there that they know will impact and
change people's minds dude they're
saying that like even the James Cameron
from Avatar and stuff he said I don't I
didn't have to make another movie I made
the biggest movie of all time with
Titanic and and he said I wanted to make
a movie that was going to change the
minds of the masses about climate change
and all these things he said it they're
making propaganda and and delivering it
to you as entertainment yep so the the
idea behind kind of pointing some of
these things out and and really taking
our time with this and really slowly
going over and discussing okay he just
said that so you know what do you think
about this is really trying to teach the
audience I really hope hope that that as
in if you are engaged in watching modern
media please watch it with an open eye
and open your eyes because this is not
just entertainment right this is meant
to influence you and and here's another
important concept I think too
um how do we teach a young child about
the Bible
they read to him all the time
we're telling them stories and you try
to make it fun and visual in fact if you
tell your kid enough stories they'll
understand the concepts of God well
that's how Jesus taught his crowd let me
tell you a story about a man who is
sowing seed let me tell you about a
story man I'm building his house on a
rock or on the sand exactly so the
devil's doing the same thing he's
telling his version his world view you
don't need to follow the rules God did
not make you male or female you know
what I mean in even in this concept of a
new Matrix like this they are teaching
anti-biblical Concepts yeah that you can
be a woman if you're born a man
and like you said that you tell the
stories over and over repackage a
different way look hey watch uh ugly
dolls it's about breaking the rules and
not one Perfection hey watch smallfoot
it's about the stones are a lie the the
rules on the stones over and over and
over you get the same message the rules
are bad do what you want and isn't it
interesting that these concepts are told
to the population over and over and over
again like you don't need to follow the
rules to me that kind of is evidence
that you know what maybe there's
something about the rules why would the
devil waste so much time telling you not
to do that if there was nothing
important with it and that's what I
think about when people think oh
Christianity is just some government
construct to keep people in line or
whatever that's interesting because the
Bible is illegal to have in school you
can't have prayer in school
you can't have prayer on the ball field
like how come if if it's a government
thing that's pushed out there to to keep
people in place wouldn't they be pushing
it everywhere instead of tearing it down
let's tear down the tanker Mouse tear
down that cross
yeah it doesn't make sense and then the
media that is controlled we know that's
controlled it's always Antichrist Satan
is the hero Lucifer is a hero in the TV
show uh Hellboy he's the hero if you see
that story enough times you begin to
have those ideas planted into your
subconscious and you begin to believe
them yeah I I believe that a good
majority of what we do all day long is
really dealing with the subconscious
right the subconscious and things that
you've experienced over your life and
and and things that you believe right
and see the devil knows that he's
putting his little subconscious ideas in
people's minds and then all of a sudden
they go you know what I really don't
believe in God and I really believe that
the world was created to you know
endlessly go on and on and on or
whatever you know and they don't believe
that we're in this war well you can see
the the changing of the mindset happen
over time there was a time when
a married couple couldn't sleep in the
same bed in Hollywood or whatever but
over the years now it's like divorce is
on the rise and then you got
um like homosexuality like in our
parents day it was nobody looked at that
like that was an acceptable thing but
now you ask even the church and they're
like oh well some people are born that
way it's that's Old Testament or
something
what has happened in 40 years that has
changed the mindsets of people even with
like aliens and stuff I watched a guy on
the street in the black and white days
90 of the people thought oh that's
that's science fiction stuff we went on
the street and 100 of them said oh yeah
of course there's aliens there's no way
we're alone in this universe so
something has happened over time I think
it's media but something has happened
over 50 years that has changed the minds
of people drastically if we were time
travel 50 years ago do you think they'd
have the same ideals that we do today
right right yeah it's really interesting
to live in a modern age where we
actually have a record of what what has
been told to society over the years
because if you just take a step back and
you recognize what's being told to us
today and see where some of those things
began and you can easily say well then
there must be a reason why our mindset
to day is what it is yeah and in the
music same thing you know there was like
the free love movement uh the drugs and
all this and in the 50s they wouldn't
show Elvis from the waist down because
he was moving his pelvis now you got a
press Christian Selena Gomez having an
orgy on stage in front of 11 year olds
isn't that crazy and praying right
before she goes on the stage I mean it's
just nuts so there's a there's a moral
decline no doubt which is definitely a
signs of the times what Jesus said would
happen that there would be a falling
away first and we're living in that time
a day like Sodom and Gomorrah a day like
the days of Noah we're living in it yep
that's why I believe it's high time to
awake out of our Slumber open our eyes
to this kind of stuff you know people
ask all the time like you know do you
guys just sit and watch all these things
all the time I actually don't watch
these anymore yeah you just watch a
trailer and you're like whoa I see
everything wrong with that movie that's
right and it just came takes a little
bit of research to look into something
and you don't have to watch the entire
thing to even understand where they're
going with this and shouldn't we
research something before we indulge in
it before you spend twenty dollars sit
in a seat that you're not going to leave
because you paid money for you're not
going to leave the middle of the movie
we every product we use we research
first I don't just go on Amazon and buy
the first product that shows up I'm
going to look at the reviews what are
people saying about it I'm going to
watch and see what are the ingredients
in this thing I'm about to consume in my
diet but when it comes to consuming for
our mind our soul we're like hey it
looks like it's got a lot of action in
it looks like it's a cool movie I'm
gonna sit here and and indulge in you
you generally do that with a book right
you know you're going to read pick the
book up and if I'm going to spend time
with this book then I want to know what
is it going to teach me or what's it
going to do but we don't often do that
with the media and so you know hopefully
our ministry kind of has inspired people
to really just start thinking about
these things critically look into this
when you see things that are biblically
not correct or different than the Bible
then what do you do do you continue to
sit there and watch it or you turn it
off and ah this is teaching me something
that I don't really want taught to me
right and you know turn away from it and
that's hopefully what we kind of do I
haven't seen the new Matrix film
um and you know for the purposes of
research that that you know has been
done for this particular project
um you know we're we're trying to point
these things out but hopefully you're
not walking away with this like I gotta
go see this movie I just want to see all
the bad things I want to see all the
like things hopefully enough information
was given to you to make a wise decision
yeah I hope that what we are teaching
people is like look
watch the trailer if they're glamorizing
witchcraft don't it no question don't go
watch it if they're blaspheming God's
name if they're breaking any of The
Commandments in a positive light don't
watch it and then if you're if it look
if the trailer like okay it looked like
it was pretty decent watch the review
see what people are saying you'd be
amazed at like the fans will tell you
gold like they'll tell you exactly all
the bad things about it and they think
it's cool
a good verse to remember is Isaiah 8 20.
um if it speaks not according to this
word or this testimony it's because
there's no light in it and so you know
the word and the testimony like hold the
Bible up to it and and does it speak the
same language as the Bible if the Bible
says you know there's there's uh you
know
um a a a a savior that was wants to come
and save you from your sin from your sin
then that's a particular savior if
somebody's saying well don't follow the
rules that's not the Savior that's the
Antichrist so if you hold that up to the
Bible savior you'll see real quick that
that's two different people now
something we talk about all the time on
here but maybe for new people the Bible
literally says I will set no Wicked
thing before my eyes and it says
whatever thing it says whatever things
are lovely and pure and true and all
these things think on these things not
not indulging in wickedness and then
Romans 1 32 right yep
says who knowing the Judgment of God
they which commit such things are worthy
of death meaning if you do these evil
things you're worthy of the death of the
Judgment of that the wage of the sin is
that the wages of sin is death but then
it also says not only those that do
those things but those that take
pleasure and then that do them if we're
taking pleasure in other people doing
Wicked acts witchcraft sexual immorality
killing people all sorts of things like
that then then are we actually taking
pleasure into the point where we would
be doing it but we're doing it in our
mind yeah I had a there was a DVD in my
drawer the other day I didn't notice it
was still in there I hadn't seen it in
years and years but it's called quick
change I just remember it was a funny
movie with Bill Murray in it but the
whole movie is him robbing a bank and
getting away with it and stuff I had to
get rid of them I found I just did a
purge of my house because there's a lot
of things that have just been there that
I just forgot about my old clothing line
the logo is a skull and I'm like I can't
have this so I'm having a bonfire and I
actually had a bonfire with my dad on uh
Thanksgiving and there was yeah my dad
brought out a bunch of records from his
house prints and sticks and all them and
uh we we set a bunch of stuff on fire
that had just been kind of sitting
around you forget about these things but
I'm I'm convicted that even if we're not
listening to him or watching them just
having them in there is an invitation
yeah and you bring up a good point
um don't get distracted by the humor of
certain things because I remember a
movie that Jim Carrey did called Liar
Liar do you remember that and it was all
about him like there's got to be a
reason that I can lie no and if I can't
lie which that was what that film was
about was him being prevented from lying
and it made his life hell when he
couldn't lie exactly and that there's
times that you're gonna need to lie well
that's one of the Ten Commandments right
buried false witness they wrap it up in
humor like it's it's funny yeah
sometimes you gotta lie it is amazing
how many movies try and and
justify breaking the Ten Commandments
yeah it is really truly amazing so we
hope that this was beneficial to you
guys
um this is often what we'll do when we
sit around we talk about you know a
particular
piece of content or something and and
we'll discuss it and we'll really you
know we'll bring out a Bible and we'll
really just say Hey listen to what they
said does it isn't there a Bible verse
that talks again against that
and that's actually really how we come
up with this kind of content so we hope
uh that you guys got some blessing out
of watching us kind of discuss one of
the pieces that we made if you haven't
checked it out go and check it out and
you know we've made 400 and something
videos over the years 400 videos look
through some of our old videos there is
some oldies but goodies in there that
might catch your eye also there are
videos that some of you may not even
know exist there's full length
documentaries that aren't on YouTube but
they're going to be right Taco Tuesday
we are going to play each one of our
documentaries because we we want to give
back to you guys you guys have really
loved on us afforded us gifted us this
beautiful building that we're working
out of and it's really been an amazing
journey to have such an awesome team you
saw some of the creativity that were
able to sit here and and Tinker with
with so that we can make these things as
as engaging as possible so our way of
giving back to you is really showing you
10 years of our work and that's if you
really look at it for dollar for dollar
that's millions of dollars worth of
content that we're giving to you for
free we want you guys to
um just just just really be thanked for
um supporting our ministry loving on our
ministry and just keep us in your
prayers yeah it's going to be out for
the holidays so you guys have plenty of
time to watch it and don't forget to
share it with all your family friends
because it's only going to be up for a
limited time and then it'll be back to
uh Vimeo where you can you can buy it or
rent it or whatever but that really
helps support our ministry
awesome
are they gonna switch
[Music]
I don't know if the athletes really
truly understand
how significant Sports is
then I'll take it even the steps further
I think Sports has become the new
religion I think in the rise of atheism
and the and the resignation from faith
in God that Sports and sports figures
have become the new religion there's
rituals in religion and there's rituals
in sports were there rituals that you
did before a game yeah yeah I had a lot
your body is just a vehicle with this
magic thing called hakka sports do the
work of religion fix they build
community they give us a sense of place
and purpose and meaning I like the hit
thing I can get all my frustration out
on the field the casters commentating
the game are going crazy they are now
the superheroes they are now the
mythological figure where they become
gods in their own domain if that's not
spirituality I don't know what is and
then it all made sense what character is
it teaching its fans and as soon as that
happened the entire dynamic in that
Stadium changed football is the only
major sport in this country Who Sold
bases as violent at some point it comes
to a showdown I have to defeat you I
have to do violence to your person he
had a 37 million dollar contract and
just walked away from football I think
it's a war I went to war Warrior without
actually having to go to war because I I
almost sought psychiatric help because
it's not just a game your heart is into
right they asked me how are you going to
deal with this the rest of your life
I lost this game for the team and we
have his address and we're going to go
out and we're going to kill him tonight
there's one kid against an entire city
they don't get out of this inning this
poor guy is you know he's done for
foreign
[Music]
hey guys I got a tip for you to really
spice up your YouTube channel with
b-roll at videomission.com this guy at
Hope through prophecy he's got 55 000
subscribers and he used one of our Clips
to illustrate the fall of Lucifer and he
used the snake in the Garden of Eden so
if you're looking for footage to
illustrate biblical topics check out
videomission.com
[Music]
thank you
is there any hope for me what can I do
to unify my family on not watching
harmful media how do I know my thoughts
are my own and how can I distinguish
between Impressions from God I'm nervous
when it comes to sharing my testimony it
is really that important I stopped
watching mainstream media now what
sometimes we get a lot of people asking
the same kind of questions so we thought
it would be cool to make these little
videos answering some of them in a new
series called I got a question concise
answers to your media related questions
we'd love to hear from you reach out to
us privately on our Instagram page or
Facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website
littlelightstudios.tv slash contact us
hey we're here to help
we're here to help you let your little
light shine
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to show kindness to the world
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
I don't know
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
New Life Studios is a fade-based media
Ministry with a passion for today's
youth by God's grace our videos has been
circulating YouTube and reaching
thousands of people I mean seriously
thousands of people as the popularity of
our videos began to rise we realize a
problem what about the countries that
only speak English we heard your
requests and having an answer by
creating real life Studios International
this YouTube channel is assigned to be a
hub for people to enjoy little life
Studios Production and their own native
tongue a big thank you to all the
volunteers who have helped us with
translation voiceovers and editing we
encourage you to utilize this Source by
subscribing and sharing our videos with
your friends and family
welcome to the video Bible study Series
where we will explore a variety of Bible
topics using video and print what is
humility do we need God's law can I
understand the Holy Spirit yes you can
and we're going to solve that today in
five minutes or less they're designed to
engage You by watching a five minute
video having a discussion on the topic
and Diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with Jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to this on your favorite
social media platform
[Music]
foreign
you're a Seeker you're an artist you've
been looking for cinematic biblical
footage you've been creating amazing
pieces of footage and animations and you
can't find it and it's too expensive to
create but most of it doesn't end up in
your final project we've all been there
what are you gonna do with all those
Creations but what if you could buy it
why not sell it at an affordable price
well now
we can where you ask
[Music]
hi you might not know me because I work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name is Michael and I'm the
director of little live Studio's 3D
Department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology where we're trying to blend
reality with the virtual world it's more
efficient and offer us the opportunity
to make higher quality Productions with
better visuals by using the arranging
software it gives us the possibility to
create realistic virtual environments
for sets in a short amount of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have Financial limits that's why
we're working toward getting an LED wall
in the future because it will allow us
to use extended reality this simply
means that we don't need green screen
anymore
it will save us tremendous time in the
post-compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from Led wall which
matches the subject and the set in real
time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
so that's what we've been up to here at
little eye status
we're so thankful for the ways that God
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello I hope you all enjoy that
director's commentary about the Matrix
if you missed it if you're just joining
our all day live right now it's okay
we're going to be leaving this video up
and you'll be able to scroll back and
hear what Scotty and Mikey had to say
about that and all the other things that
we've been doing all throughout this day
we have just been having so much fun and
we thank you so much for joining us
right now though I'm going to be giving
a director's commentary about a recent
video we published called Black Panther
and this whole thing was like you know
watch this before you consider going and
watching black panther wakanda forever
um man what a task to get that video out
I just want to stop and say thank you
thank you thank you to all of you our
donors for sure you are literally the
ones who made this possible and I'll
continue saying that over and over again
throughout this presentation and we'll
be watching clips of this together and
I'll stop and I'll
share a little behind the scenes with
you but really it's the donors that
allowed us to get the equipment that we
use and get the space that we're in now
to make these Productions possible so
thank you I also want to thank those who
are praying for me and for the team and
for those who are sharing the
information or the research that they
had done personally and just the general
support it means the world to me my
heart is so full and I thank you I can't
thank you enough so this black panther
project it actually took a total of of
three weeks which is not normal by any
means it on on average
for this kind of work it probably takes
us month well it does take us months and
why it had to be done in three weeks is
because we made the decision to actually
release something on Black Panther and
in the time that we made that decision
and the time that the Black Panther
wakanda forever was coming out was a
three-week gap we released the Black
Panther video uh Friday
um November 11th if you haven't watched
that video highly recommend you do so
what I'll be talking about will make a
lot more sense if you watched it if you
did watch that video how about you write
in the comments below hey I watched it
and we'd like to hear what you thought
about it thank you for everyone who left
comments I'll be responding to comments
a little later on
in this section
so yes this was most definitely a team
effort as I did say it as I said it took
three weeks
um Working Day and Night doing as much
research as we could to wrap our heads
around the comic books the history and
then also learning about Stan Lee Jack
Kirby and then trying to decide which
direction we wanted to take this
production and the information we wanted
to share and also obviously being as
sensitive as possible to to those who
have an emotional attachment to the MCU
and that franchise so
uh God definitely came through he
pointed Us in the direction that we
needed to go to find exactly what we
needed so that we could actually get
this done in the time and meet the goal
so all glory to God for helping us all
right so without further ado
let's get started oh I also want to give
a heads up to my team would you mind
looking at the comments as it comes in
if there's anything that really stands
out don't mind coming in here and
letting me know so that we can address
it all right so let's begin
known as one of the most tumultuous and
divisive decades in world history and
I'll stop it right there this was a
collaboration between Micah and I shout
out to Micah our cinematographer on the
team we sat down together and I was like
you know what what is the most dramatic
way that we can start this mini doc to
like really grab the attention and have
people like wanting more leave them
wanting more and so I was thinking you
know maybe I could just like clap and
lights turn on he was like yeah that
sounds like a good idea I left and came
back in like 10 minutes and this whole
set was built up and if you
see I'll pull it back here the attention
to detail that he has
there's this like oh it's probably hard
to see here but there's like a blue
silhouette happening
um like we're just very uh
detail-oriented Micah is and so when I
clapped then all the studio lights came
on no one is one of the most of course
with the dramatic music shout out to
Scotty who did the sound design and all
of this or the the music production and
all of this just to grab the attention
and and draw the viewer in so that the
information can be digested now we
actually had to film this twice we
filmed it first on a Friday and I took
it home to start editing on Sunday only
to find out that first like somehow the
footage got deleted so I had to come
back in on Monday and refilm this
section so that's the section you're
seeing now the refilming but it turned
out great nonetheless and yeah I just
praise God it comes with the territory
video productions you go through bumps
and and haphazards but
it turned out well in the end
Okay so
let's see let's Jump Ahead to about two
minutes and 55 seconds in
around there
it's one of my favorite Parts the intro
scene my name is Candy and I invite you
to join me on this journey of
discovering the true ideology behind the
Black Panther
[Music]
now this is so epic and I have to shout
out Michael for creating this our visual
effects artist I mean the the
introduction was dramatic in itself and
I was like hey Michael listen you got to
match this energy going into this this
is a mini doc we gotta come correct for
this kind of topic and he used Unreal
Engine and just created this entire
scene and if you can like when you're
watching it pause you'll find some birds
flying and there's some animals by the
water I mean just another person who's
very uh detail-oriented and he just
built this all from scratch I just shout
out him and his work this was definitely
money well spent I'll put it that way
shout out again to our donors for making
this possible
yes so I had some co-writers and
researchers that joined me in this
project Lindell and Cosi he is from
Zimbabwe and also Mama calendar my
mother Florence calendar I'd like to
shout out them because if it were just
me alone sifting through all this
research this video probably wouldn't be
out yet and so we came together we
combed through all the stack of research
that we had to make this video as
accurate as possible so thank you so
much to them
[Music]
and then we have the actual title of
this production is the illusion of
empowerment but we put in Black Panther
because we wanted as many people to
click on the video as possible and not
for it to be ambiguous like what do you
mean the illusion of empowerment but
anyway we're going to pause right here
for a second for a quick commercial
break and I'll meet you right back here
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know your
thing you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
good
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need to go out of your way to
help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world
and we're back all right let's continue
I often wonder what people mean when
they call this a black film what does
that mean exactly
is it because it has a predominantly
Black cast
all of this all of this was built in
Unreal Engine even the detail with the
spinning shoe that was made by Michael
now it this as a finished product looks
Epic
when we filmed it it was completely
green screen and I'd like to show you a
behind the scenes picture because it was
a team effort so I'll that should be on
the screen right now
you'll see
uh the person holding the camera that
there is Micah
Michael is in the back holding the green
screen they have Alex holding one of the
lights he's in the the blue shirt to
make sure I'm well lit and then Scotty's
holding another light and we have
Brittany she was trying to make sure
that the cords didn't get in Scotty's
way as he was walking with me and so
there's also a video that
we have we can go ahead and play the
video I'll talk over it
I often want
s of me saying the opening scene as you
see it's completely green screen we had
to put those pieces the green pieces of
tape so that the camera could track what
was was happening but yeah just complete
having to like imagine it in our our
minds as we went along to make sure we
stayed on time and then Michael took
that footage put it into Unreal Engine
built the scene and it just came out as
a masterpiece so again I have to thank
the team for working and helping me make
this a reality
okay let's move to about halfway through
their practices now I've heard rebuttals
that this proves that spiritualism is
the true religion of Africa and
Christianity well that's the white man's
religion the religion of colonizers
that is so so not true and it's actually
a myopic view of History it's a fact
that Christianity was in Africa before
it was in the United States even before
it reached Britain and the northern
countries in Europe
www.ola fans and Africa now if you're
wondering how in the world did she get
here from talking about Black Panther
well you have to watch and find out also
before I make mention of this I do I do
want to say that there is a lot more
behind the scenes videos and content on
our patreon Channel or if you donate it
through our website we send out emails
all the information to become a part of
our family to be part of our donor base
you can find it on the screen here and
it's also in the description box
underneath this video now I want to
share a story about
this section because I actually debated
whether I should leave it in or take it
out and I was close to taking it out
actually in the original edit it was out
and everything was going smooth with the
editing side of it as I said we had a
little mishap in filming but editing
everything was smooth which was which
was weird because it doesn't usually
happen that way but things are going
great
and then all of a sudden
my computer crashed the first time in a
few days it crashed and I always like on
the verge of hyperventilating I was like
oh no Lord please please save this
project I hadn't saved I was using
Premiere see Final Cut Pro it saves
automatically and yes uh Premier has a
auto save feature but it's not as
frequently as Final Cut Pro I didn't
know when last I actually saved it on my
uh on my own like manually so when I
went into the auto save folder I didn't
know what to expect I didn't know if it
would be a pro
a copy of the project from hours ago
because a lot can be done in a few hours
or if it would be what I just did
and so I'm praying Lord please please I
don't even think I had words I think I
was just saying Lord please please over
and over again as I was going through my
computer and when I opened up the
project file it had saved everything up
until this piece
and I said Lord
I got it I got the message I'm taking
the sign I will leave this piece into
the project and based off of the
comments and the reactions to this
historical piece I know it was a good
decision and God was definitely in
control and a part of this project the
fact that this was almost not included
in the project
the whole thing crashed and I was able
to recover all the way up until this
piece to continue going uh God was just
present throughout this entire
production and I thank him for making
sure that I didn't have to start over
completely
and also preserving uh the beginning
half of it
was in Africa before it was in the
United States it
where it reached Britain and the
northern countries in Europe
birth of Moses
for Abraham the father of Judaism was
born that's also 700 years before the
birth of Moses you know the men who
wrote down the Ten Commandments that
makes specifications about the Sabbath
so I'll pause it right here because I
did make a mistake and I um
I found it in the comments and I do want
to thank you for making that comment
here I said that Moses was the one who
wrote down the Ten Commandments and I
must confess I'll be completely honest
with you I believed or I had the
misunderstanding that he did now from my
understanding previously I knew that God
wrote down the Ten Commandments and gave
it to Moses when Moses descended from
the mountain he saw the idolatry that
the children of Israel were partaking
and got angry and smashed to the first
set completely destroyed those tablets
and when he went up the mountain I was
of the understanding that
he wrote the second but that is not true
I went back and read after I saw your
comments and now I I am of the correct
understanding that God wrote both sets
and I'd like to read those verses if
anyone is unsure as well it can be found
or the first set of of the Ten
Commandments that God gave to Moses you
can find that in Exodus chapter 31.
Exodus chapter 31 verse 18 and it says
and he God gave to Moses when he had
made an end of consuming with sorry
communing with him upon Mount Sinai two
tables of testimony tables of stone
written with the Finger of God so that's
the first set and then you have you know
Moses descending and the Israelites
falling into idolatry but then in
Exodus chapter 34 Verse 1 it says and
the Lord said to Moses Hew you two
tables of stone like to the first and I
will write upon these tables the words
that were on the first tables which you
broke and so that's why it's so
important this is for me as well to be
meticulous when we're reading scripture
because probably when it says who you he
instructed the Lord instructed Moses to
Hew the tablets and I think that's where
I got the misinterpretation that Moses
was the one who wrote it the Bible
clearly says Exodus chapter 34 Verse 1
that God said I will write upon these
tables The Words which were in the first
tables so correction on my part
okay let's continue on
while in Ethiopia during the 4th Century
Saint fermentius ethiop World rest and
His Holy Apostles that we observed that
day
of the Apostles if you remember the
story in Acts chapter 8 an Ethiopian
eunuch is baptized by Philip now this
was made by A.I it's called mid-journey
and it's it's this incredible piece of
software we type in certain key words
and then the AI produces scenes like
this based off of what was inputted so
this whole scene of like the Ethiopian
eunuch we were able to just let the AI
do its work and then input it into our
video it was phenomenal Christ's main
objective to his disciples was to carry
the gospel to all the world and one of
the first places it reached was Ethiopia
it happened between 80 and 90 A.D the
first century this means the gospel
reached Ethiopia over 1400 years before
the Church of England was even
established in 1534. it wasn't some
Foreigner who evangelized Africa it was
a citizen rather other a government
official who whose understanding of the
scriptures changed his life Revelation
people
they were looking for empowerment in the
face of chaos and fierce oppression
which positioned them to be more readily
accepting of a hero savior
unfortunately this acceptance came
outside of Christ
superheroes and self-sufficiency came as
a replacement
the theme found in all superheroes
regardless of ethnicity and gender is a
hopeless race looking for a savior but
the Savior that comes either uses
sorcery or Alchemy or or looks for
strength within themselves or from
mythical Gods some superhero storylines
even have Gnostic Origins that mirror
the way Jesus came to this earth now
this is just scratching the surface we
put a little example Clips in this
production but we have a whole full
length actually two full-length
documentaries talking about this very
topic of how these themes found in the
not just superhero movies but Hollywood
Productions have this storyline that if
you flip it is parallel to the Bible and
so if you'd like to delve deeper into
these types of topics I would recommend
replacement Gods it's a two-part series
that you can stream on Vimeo if you'd
like that information you can go to our
website littlelightstudios.tv
so there's replacement Gods one and two
we have pseudology talking about this as
well and there's one more that I'm
missing but later on we'll talk about
that
okay so
um I'll play a little bit more of this
but then the next piece of this black
panther segment will actually be a
little bit of trivia because those
documentaries that I just mentioned we'd
like to give back and give a couple of
those away and the trivia is going to be
based on this particular video uh the
New Black Panther the real story Secrets
Revealed so stick around in a few
minutes we'll have a trivia and then
I'll be answering some questions
[Music]
way of the devil I will be it may not
have been the intention of Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby but the response of the
masses echoed the ploy of the devil I
will be like the most high
all right let me ask you this one time
what Master do you sir what Master will
you serve you know these clips are found
all throughout these movies and the
thing is when you sit down and watch
them they're designed to bypass our
frontal lobes and go directly into our
brains and it's like our defenses are
down and these things are easily missed
even though there are so blatant you
know maybe I should actually create a
montage of all these different scenes
and publish that because really when you
see it in that setting it clicks and
it's like whoa like I I didn't notice
that I didn't know that was there and
hopefully that will will wake some
people up to the agenda that's there in
these films because it's not Christians
inserting themselves into these
Productions it's there we're showing
their Clips they're the ones who sat
down and wrote These out these
derogatory things and making fun of
they had their pick of all religions but
they keep attacking Christianity that's
interesting so maybe that'll be a video
that I do if you think that's a good
idea write that in the the comments
section but for right now we are going
to put up a little commercial I'll meet
you in another location as we get ready
for our trivia
[Applause]
the Black Panther and the enemy of our
souls namely Lucifer have in common the
number one question that needs to be
answered is this what do superheroes
depend upon when badly against the
forces of evil in their roles when's the
last time or the first time you see an
animal speaking to a human being to eat
something to receive power we know very
well what it is when the devil and he
possessed a serpent spoke through the
serpent and told Eve that if you eat of
the fruit you'll become like God where
is he getting his power from who is he
getting his wisdom from the goddess past
you know that's the devil the Black
Panther and bass are connected together
with the heart-shaped herb the Black
Panther is saying honored fathers Mighty
Warriors fearsome priests black panthers
all in the name of bats not in the name
of Jesus but in the name of a false god
the name of fast I call upon you to
counsel hold on we must follow biblical
principles when it comes to what we
watch bottom line is this right here if
you take the Witchcraft and the
spiritualism and the false god worship
Out of the Black Panther movie guess
what you won't have a black panther
[Music]
get ready for the Black Panther
deception
[Music]
available now on DVD and digital
download at littlelightstudios.tv
all right so that trailer that you just
saw well that was of our first black
panther expose this was released back in
2018 by Dr olentunji we have it right
here it's available for streaming on
Vimeo you can go get to Vimeo through
our website
littlelightstudios.tv to watch the first
one that we did this was a full-length
one and the one that we recently did it
was like a refresher so to speak and
also to hopefully persuade people not to
go see uh Black Panther wakanda forever
now we were watching clips of the movie
that I produ sorry the mini dock that I
produced of black panther if you haven't
seen it it's on our YouTube channel you
don't have to stream it on Vimeo this is
for purchase but the one that I did you
can find on Little Light Studios YouTube
channel
um right now actually it was just
released a couple of weeks ago so that
is free for you to view let's get into
our trivia I have three documentaries
here
the Black Panther deception I have the
replacement Gods the first one and I
have the replacement Gods two the second
one this replacement Gods number one was
the first superhero documentary that
little light Studios released it came
out in 2012 and then a part two came out
and we just want to give back and
give away a free a promo code to those
persons who get these questions correct
now so this is how it will go I'll ask a
question the first person who gets it
right I'm looking at the chat now
the first person who gets it correct
I will acknowledge you and then all you
need to do is send us an email through
our website with your username
and saying that you won the Black
Panther trivia and we will get in
contact with you so just to make sure
that this is working correctly for me
please if you're watching and if you are
active in the chat put the number one
put the number one as a test just to
make sure this is fair everyone is
engaged and that I can see that the chat
is active
and we can begin all right I'm seeing
the ones come in great
excellent okay so the first one we'll do
is
how about we go in order we'll go in
order replacement Gods number one so
whoever gets this right the first one
that I see
um
you will get replacement Gods number one
I see is this trivia in the chat or in
kahoot okay I should clarify this black
panther trivia is separate from the
trivia that's coming up
after this segment in kahoot so with
this trivia answer in the chat right
here on YouTube and then in a subsequent
section we will be using kahoot
okay hope you're ready for the question
first question
we talked about how t'challa this is a
character in the Black Panther film we
talked about how t'challa and his family
engaged in a seance to save his life and
to get his kingdom back which Bible
character lost his kingdom when he
engaged in necromancy
so we have t'challa he in the film got
his kingdom back through necromancy but
in the Bible God's word there is a
character who lost up I see Mandy Mandy
Stewart you're the first that is correct
it was King Saul
you could find that story in second
Samuel you get the replacement Gods part
one so send us an email
lls.tv slash contact Dash us you can
send us an email through that uh link
that's to our website make sure you
include your username
and let us know that you won
I'm going to Mark you down here to make
sure that we look out for you Mandy
Stewart good job and there are many
other people who got it correct
okay great so I have that down congrats
Mandy okay number two this will be
replacement Gods part two whoever gets
this correct first
between what years
between what years did the Apostle
Philip baptize the Ethiopian eunuch do
you know
between what years
did the Apostle Philip baptize the
Ethiopian eunuch if you watched the
video that we did on black panther that
was inserted into that mini dock
oh that seems to be a hard one
hard questions yep
take a guess
13 to 14 no
34-37 no
it was a little later close 40 to 60
getting closer
between what years did the Apostle
Philip baptize the Ethiopian eunuch
okay if no one gets it right I'll go
with the person that was closest oh we
got someone even closer between 50 and
70 close haven't hit the mark yet
75 okay that's closer
okay let me do a countdown three
two
one okay the closest person
was Jason Ducks duxton I hope I'm saying
your name right Jason ducks in 75 the
answer is 80 to 90 A.D that's the time
period that uh the Apostle Philip
baptized the Ethiopian eunuch so
Jason
baxton this is for you so send us an
email
littlelightstudios.tv slash contact Dash
us include your username and let us know
that you won
you write your name here
okay last one the person who gets this
right gets the Black Panther deception
this was a documentary that we put out
in 2018 it was hosted by Dr Olin tunji
very good resource
this question goes as follows
what are we opening ourselves up to when
we look for empowerments from anything
or any one other than God
what are we opening ourselves up to when
we look for empowerment from anything or
any one other than God
ah someone got it Elise princess
deception is correct that was fast and
you guys are really attentive watching
that video okay so this is yours send us
an email using little
lightstudios.tv slash contact Dash us
send us an email with your username and
letting us know that you won and we will
get those codes over to you so you can
stream those documentaries for free if
you didn't win the documentaries are
still available check them out on Vimeo
okay let me
write your name down so we can
verify
congratulations to those that one thank
you so much for your participations
everyone who did
so now we're going to check out some
comments some comments that were left
underneath the video
this is the video uh Black Panther the
one we released a couple of weeks ago it
is available on our YouTube channel for
those who haven't seen it as yet
and I just um I'm going through it here
and I'll just pick out a few and give
some responses
so let's pull it up here
also I'll be checking the live chat
that's here on YouTube
if you have any questions and if I have
the answers I will give it a go
here we go okay
so let's go with the first one this
question or sorry this comment
is by David Ramirez David Ramirez thank
you so much for engaging with us and
liking our videos commenting under them
sharing them all over the world really
we appreciate you so David Ramirez says
this was going great but when it started
with the Christian stuff then it lost me
okay okay well I actually hope David
watched the whole video but this comment
really it lets me know that the video
went far and wide it reached a broad
audience you know we we start at little
I Studios we start with a secular topic
because we want to hopefully catch as
many people's attention as possible and
then what we do is we turn their
attention to spiritual things what the
Bible has to say concerning this topic
we'd like to present the Christian
Perspective and really present
information that leaves the viewer with
everything laid out and then they make
the choice
if you look at any of our videos that is
the style that we take and so I'm happy
David that you clicked on our video and
I hope that you watched the whole thing
I wonder what your thoughts are if you
did get to the end of the video but um
you know as Christians we view the world
through the lens of the Bible so with
anything that will be our perspective
that will be our approach it is just who
we are
okay let's find another one
oh this one is interesting Eddie Jimenez
I'm sorry if I get your name wrong I'm
trying my best this person says stop
please no stop already please it's just
a movie it's just a movie
it's make believe it's fiction I don't
see how any
I don't see how you guys try to tie
everything to the Bible and make
everything evil it's just the movie stop
it already get your theology right okay
so from this comment well right off the
bat
it's very emotional and this topic I
understood was very emotional people
were very emotionally attached to these
superheroes especially watching them for
years and years being so intertwined
with their storylines so I was expecting
this but really my hope is that
with information that we continue to
present that people will start using
more of their reasoning capabilities and
understand media's effect on society
it's not just a movie
it's not just fiction and it's not just
coming from our end either they're
people who are Avid supporters of Disney
and of Marvel of the MCU who are
actually disappointed about the Black
Panther movie for a variety of reasons
whether it had to do with the you know
lgbtq couple that was
um added to wakanda forever or you know
the imbalance of of male and female
roles or you know political stances or
maybe scenery or what have you if it was
just fiction why would we why would they
care so much and on the flip side
when it comes for us we understand the
science behind things and how what you
watch does affect you it has impact just
like what you eat affects your body what
you see affects you as well mental
health is just as important if not more
in some cases important than your
physical health so no it's not just
Fiction it's not just a movie because we
see the impact it is having on society
we see the debates that are happening we
have countries different countries in
the world that have actually or are
considering I don't know if it went
through yet but they were considering
Banning this movie for their own reasons
if it was just fiction then who who
cares why don't you just play it and the
fact that that is not happening speaks
volumes so I would consider that going
forward before we just write something
off as fiction
okay let's move on to another one
I will just say Mr ocean uh
this comment says I thank God for
allowing me to be able to find this
channel for a long time I've been seeing
weird patterns in most of these movies
and musics and all the forms of media we
consume
and when I warn people and tell them
even my fellow Christians they look at
me like I'm possessed or I don't I don't
know what I'm talking about thank you
guys for sensitizing us to the things we
need to watch out for and man I can't
even explain how this video and your
content what sorry I can't even explain
how this video and your content means to
me knowing
that there are others in the work
striving to spread the word of God and
make sure we don't cap we don't get
captured in the jaws of Satan
may all the glory be to God and may He
bless you guys for using your talents
that he has given you to advance his
kingdom amen amen thank you so much we
praise God I thank you for for your
encouragement
and actually want to encourage you that
when you encounter people like this
they're not rejecting you they're
rejecting Christ they're rejecting the
message that you're trying to share with
them I wouldn't take it personal and I'm
also reminded of Elijah you know when he
was running away from the queen at the
time and he was in the Rock and God is
having a conversation with him and he's
saying God is asking Elijah why are you
why are you hearing this rock why are
you running away why are you hiding and
Elijah was saying well
I'm the only one this is a terrifying
situation I'm the only one preaching
this message I'm I'm doing what is right
and it seems that nothing is happening
and God had to remind him no I have
hundreds if not I believe thousands of
other prophets scattered all over the
world doing the exact same work that
you're doing be of good share know that
I am working and I just wanted to
encourage you and anyone else who's
listening who's being persecuted for
standing up for what is right God is
with you we are here with you we are are
just humble to be of support to you to
let you know that there are other people
standing with you standing for truth
found in the word of God to to share the
good news of Salvation And The Gospel to
the world so please be encouraged and
continue doing what you're doing thank
you so much for that comment that was
great
okay
let's go to Albert
the double-edged sword of themes and
superhero movies has never been made
much clearer wow praise God at the
Forefront the theme is so Noble while
the response of the masses unveils in
the background a subtle yet strong and
deep-rooted a situation of spiritualism
combined with self-sufficiency
the demonstration of how a movie
intended to promote inclusion can easily
be transformed to promote separatism is
outstanding hmm
the massive gray area between Sabbath
keeping and Judaism has also been
demystified in few words facts and
historical statements the widespread
confusion
as to the origins of Christianity
paganism and spiritualism in connection
with the African continent has been
explained in simple terms excellent
production God bless you know I praise
God for you Albert this was a great
analysis you were spot on because when
it comes to Art when you put out art
it's left really up to the
interpretation of whoever digests it and
so
the fact that you got the interpretation
that we were praying that people would
get is is just an answer to prayer and
it's a blessing and we thank you for
your feedback for letting us know that
we presented the message clearly and
that that people got it so that's very
encouraging thank you
okay Samuel Samuel says the best
production I have seen from this
ministry as a supporter since the first
replacement Gods oh so that means you've
been watching us for 10 years praise God
thank you just shared with my co-worker
who was equally blessed and will share
with others keep on keeping on in Jesus
name so if you weren't here earlier I
just want to share this documentary that
Samuel is talking about the replacement
Gods you can find it on Vimeo for
streaming
I wonder I wonder if this is on our
clips of this is on our YouTube channel
too is it on our YouTube channel the
whole thing or is it clips
that's true okay I was just reminded we
have doco Tuesday coming up uh every
Tuesday for the next few weeks we'll
actually be streaming these DVDs on
YouTube for a limited time so look out
for those you may be able to catch this
on YouTube
um but yes this was the first superhero
movies that little live Studios ever
released the replacement Gods highly
recommend thank you Samuel for your
comment
okay let's do a few more here let's see
let's let's do it's in the word it's in
the word says the fact that the recent
Black Panther movie was filled with
ancestral worship and now this movie
starts off this movie being wakanda
forever starts off with praying to an
Egyptian goddess by a woman who says
she's a Christian okay I believe you're
talking about Leticia writes the the
woman who plays shuri in in wakanda
forever only shows a deception and
Witchcraft involved to manipulate the
masses you know this is so true and I'm
actually thinking of doing a show
questioning the discernment that
Christians have or Christians use
specifically Christian actors and
producers who are active in Hollywood
when they're choosing their roles let me
know if that's a video you may be
interested in write that in the comment
sections below after the live I'll take
a look at it
um but yeah it it's it's uh it's a kind
of dissonance that is striking to me
because on the one hand they're
witnessing for for Christ and you could
they're very outspoken in their
interviews and whatnot but then in
in the interviews maybe tens of
thousands of people see it but in the
roles they take hundreds of thousands
millions of people watch it and it's a
completely different message so we'll
delve into that and look at what the
Bible has to say in that regard okay so
we will do one more before we oh we'll
do two more before we wrap up here
so this is from my goddess Yahweh
this person says even in India still now
people call Jesus britishers God and
white people's god well this is
worldwide it's a worldwide thing Satan
has really done a number on Christ's
reputation and his character and people
are looking at the actions of
unconverted religious people and it's
really putting a Bad Name On Christ I
would just encourage people to read The
Words of Christ himself and you'll see
that the actions don't match people need
to to
have a personal relationship with God
for themselves it is life-changing and
not be so easily dissuaded by those
around them okay so the last comment I
will take
is from Super velos
uh this person says can you translate it
to Spanish if so please let us know okay
pray for Alex I'm working with him on
this and even with wakanda forever there
are a lot of Mayan Roots found in that
movie and I believe Alex will will have
a lot more insight in regards to that so
I'm working with Alex maybe uh write in
the comments below help me give him some
heat so he can help me with that
production but that would be really fun
to produce again thank you so much
everyone for
uh commenting underneath the video
supporting the video sharing
um your thoughts about it dialoguing
with us if there's anything that you'd
like to see on little less Studios page
that you'd like us to talk about uh send
us that via email or on our social media
platforms or you can comment underneath
this video we'll be interacting with you
continuously we just thank you so much
for joining us on this giving Tuesday
those who have been here from since
morning until now or if you just joined
again don't worry we'll leave this video
up you can start from the beginning if
you'd like to and I will see you later
on today bye-bye
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know your
thing
you think
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them thank you
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what's up everybody thank you for
we're here on kahoot and we got a full
house we got Sandra Harley MCC
Pio tur Mal R.L Smith Stefan TCB
Anonymous boshk Hugh anus and Nick we
have everybody in here so let's get into
the game these questions are going to be
based on things that you've seen or
learned or heard on our Channel and a
little bit of trivia about us personally
so get your thinking caps on we're about
to play because whoever wins will get
digital downloads for any video you want
or all the videos that we have on our
Vimeo channel so three two one
here we go quiz time baby when we went
to Walmart what symbols did we see did
we see a pentagram a book about Jesus a
Ouija board or all the above which one
of these did you see when we went to
Walmart and we were showing you all the
different Illuminati symbols the satanic
symbols that we saw at Walmart and you
got
two seconds one second and only four
answers all right everybody said all
above and that was correct we got three
people who got the answer correct
because we did we saw a pentagram inside
of a book a coloring book about
witchcraft it was literally called
witchcraft coloring book we also saw a
book about Jesus but that book wasn't
saying that Jesus was the Savior but
rather talked about him as a historical
figure
um and we did see a Ouija board inside
that coloring book as well so when you
answered all the above you were correct
somebody answered pentagram that was
correct as well how do we go to the next
question
uh let's see who's in the top all right
Hue in the top
bring it down some my voice close this
oh
all right guys true or false Elon Musk
had an inverted cross on his chest we
went live about this Scotty showed you
that Elon Musk wore this seven thousand
dollar costume and what was on his chest
was there an inverted cross on Elon
musk's chest we got eight that said true
and that is correct because it was a
goat head an inverted pentagram but on
the goat's head was an inverted cross so
tried to get tricky with that one two
people said no because they were
probably thinking of the goat head and
not the inverted cross all right who's
in the lead now
NCC in the lead all right next question
Kirk Franklin's official response to his
lyric the lion and and the lamb will bow
down to the goat what did he officially
say about it did he say Jesus Will bow
down to Satan did he say I was talking
about the real animals align in the lamb
will bow down to the greatest of all
time or did he say I was calling the
world greats lines and lambs and they'll
bow down to the grace of all time or did
he say this was a freestyle my words
just got mixed up
we had
three people say it was the third answer
and that was correct that was actually
His official response on Twitter he said
look I was talking about the world
greats I was calling you know the the
famous ball players and the rappers and
all I was calling them lions and Lambs
that doesn't even make sense I can
understand maybe calling somebody
imagine going up to uh the best
basketball player around and being like
man you're the lamb bro makes no sense
but anyway that was his response so you
guys caught up with that you're keeping
up with the trends
Hugh is back in the top
let's go to the next question
pick the false statement
out of the Halloween was bonfires
actually originates from bone fires
Sunway was originally a Christian
celebration before it was hijacked by
Halloween wearing costumes is meant to
scare away evil spirits or people used
to carve turnips and other root
vegetables for and before pumpkins
we got two people that said bonfires
actually originates from bone fires and
three people that said Sunway was
originally a Christian celebration you
were correct if you answered the blue
because
bonfires actually does originate from
bone fires we talked about that in the
video
who is at the top now still you M.C in
the lead right underneath
next question 5 out of 10 here
who
who's the presenter of this oh this
should be easy if you guys were with us
is it candy is it Dr o was it Brittany
or Scotty who was the presenter of the
wakanda forever the video that was
recently done that was actually had a
different title the illusion of
empowerment
who was it we had 10 people guess candy
and they were correct who's in the lead
now Hugh is still in the lead but
Anonymous Bosh started rising up
true or false Scotty used to work in
Hollywood is this a true or false
statement
[Music]
if you guys saw the very beginning of
this live a couple hours ago
Scotty talked about his testimony where
he came from did he spend any time in
Hollywood one person said no but Scotty
did he spent 10 years in Hollywood he
started out trying to act and realized
he wasn't the best actor so he got
behind the camera started doing a lot of
reality show camera work such as the
biggest loser and other shows like that
so yes Scotty did come out of Hollywood
who's in the lead Hugh is still in the
lead
we got three more questions though guys
Disney's consistent message is to obey
the rules true or false this is a good
family friendly company right you think
they're probably telling the kids to you
know obey your parents obey the rules it
seems like something you would get out
of a family-friendly or are they saying
something else we don't know whoa
everybody got it right it is false their
whole motto is Break The Rules follow
your heart do what thou wilt
you guys have been paying attention
who's in the lead Sandra's on the list
but he is still at number one
you guys can still come back there's two
more answers before Ministry Keith was a
history teacher worked for NASA
pharmacist or a chemist
what job career path do you think Keith
had before he was in Ministry
history teacher worked for NASA
pharmacist or a chemist he talked about
this when he told his testimony at the
beginning of the day wow six people knew
that he was a chemist one person thought
he was a pharmacist one person thought
he was a history teacher I wouldn't be
surprised if Keith was any of these he's
a very smart person I could even see him
working for NASA that one didn't get any
votes though
who is in the lead Hugh is still in the
lead all right final question who will
get it right
no this is nine out of ten before
Ministry Mikey was a rapper country
singer actor or Club DJ this question's
about me if you ever watched my
testimony on the channel as you can see
I used to be really Gothic and I did
some Gothic metal stuff but before right
before I got into Ministry I was a
whoa 10 of you guys got it right I
thought maybe somebody thought I was a
country singer
You Don't Know What You Got Till It's
Gone all right everybody got that answer
right
wow he was still in the lead
one more question guys
one more final question which is not a
little light Studios documentary Magic
Kingdom replacement Gods what would
Jesus watch or dark secrets of anime
exposed if you don't know we have full
length documentaries they're not on
YouTube you have to go to Vimeo or you
can go to our website
littlelightstudios.tv towards shop you
can buy them on those ancient DVDs that
a lot of people don't have players for
anymore or you can get it on digital
download at vimeo.com and
everybody got it right except one person
we do actually have dark secrets of
anime exposed we that was our last
full-length documentary that we made it
was three hours long very thorough on a
lot of the most popular animes from
Pokemon to seven deadly sins and
everything in between Dragon Ball and
all those uh three hours of content
split up into four uh shorter format
films split up into four 30 minute
segments
who was the winner of today's trivia
thank you guys for playing we appreciate
when you guys get involved
and it looks like
in third place we had Anonymous Bosh
in second place we had MCC
congratulations guys and then first
you
we thank you so much funny name I see
that now and you can write to Mikey at
lls.tv and let me know how I can get you
this digital download free digital
downloads on our site you can watch all
the documentaries we have for free thank
you so much for your participation we're
wrapping up the day we got a few more
segments we might have about 30 more
minutes so stay with us guys and we're
gonna pray this thing out after we do a
couple more things but I really
appreciate spending this time with you
guys thanks for participating we'll see
you guys later
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so according to the internet today
January 11th is indeed National learn
your name in Morris code day so I'm
going to write Scotty and Keith's name
out in Morris code and see if they can
figure it out
happy New Year
the first behind the scenes video
catching these guys off guard as usual
there you are do you know what that says
check check out what the paper says
I would say it's Morse code it is Morse
code
um
this is a creeping of Threes okay first
of all I have to have it orientated the
right way
um
divided into something like that correct
so this is probably four letters this is
probably a letter this is probably two
letters one letter and then three
letters
but that kind of doesn't make sense this
isn't even Chinese
um
yeah I have no idea I don't know Morse
code but I mean I I recognize it but I I
don't have it memorized I think that's
the same for most people they would
recognize guessing but I don't know what
it's got it divided I think but that's
about as far as I can go yeah God
yes no okay there's one letter
this says Scotty nice and that says
Keith gotcha happy Morse code day hey
my name yep we should put this on our
did you know that Morse code was used to
send the first text message
that's true like it would be a text
message so I have a question for you
guys okay what device did you use to
send your very first text message is an
iPhone
wow mine was a flip phone okay which one
you remember the model man
no no Samsung Samsung I was too cheap to
pay for texting so until it was included
in like the whole plan I wouldn't buy it
yeah my I remember the flip flown and
then you'd have to like press it like
multiple times to like get the right
letter and stuff like that wow did you
have it memorized by feel oh yeah we
could knock out a text real fast I had a
Blackberry oh nice oh yeah that was my
first phone I remember that okay Keith
so if text iPhone was your first text do
you remember what you used to make your
first first phone call like on a cell
phone on a cell phone yeah you remember
those uh Motorola flip phones with the
brick battery that you could put on the
end yeah I put up a photo for those
that's it wow all right so we can't get
them now yeah my dad actually had one of
those cell phones that was it looked
like a carrying case yeah it was like a
bag my parents had those 90s and they'd
bring in the cars I can remember the
very first
um the very first uh time ever seen a
car make a cell phone um
be and you know before backgrounds took
off they had the engagers yeah goodness
so it looked just like that yeah yeah
you would carry it you would carry it
around uh in a car yeah and uh
um yeah I can remember making a phone
call and just being like this is so cool
we can make a phone call while we're
driving in a car dinosaur times yeah
well thank you guys okay no problem
thanks Michael
do you know what your name is in Morris
code if so write it in the comments
below and if not you can do what I did I
just looked up a Morse code translator
and use it to convert English the
English letters into Morris code and it
was pretty fun I'm gonna do my name next
and I'll post it down below as well and
if you want to have a little bit more
fun also put what was the device that
you used to send your very first text
message and then we can communicate in
the comment section Below have a great
day guys
foreign
[Music]
well congratulations you've made it this
far we have gone live all day long and
it's been a journey you've heard lots of
incredible stories you've got to play
games you've heard commentaries there's
been so many elements and hopefully you
guys know us a little bit better after
all of this so what I want to do right
now is announce to our donors or
hopefully are watching all this because
you're dedicated fans and I want to let
you know that we're doing a giveaway
this year I know it's giving Tuesday but
we thought it was important for us to
give back to you it's hard times
inflation is up and everybody's kind of
you know feeling the pain in the economy
but we want to give back
and so what we're going to do is those
of you who are are monthly or
significant donors I'm going to send you
a code and that code is going to be good
so you can share it with whoever you
want
for any of our videos on Vimeo and the
person who redeems that code can watch
that video
for 30 days
so the time they put the code in and run
it they have 30 days they can watch that
video as many times as they want so if
you were greatly affected by Magic
Kingdom or replacement gods or the Black
Panther or selfie or any of the
controller series Whatever video right
you share that with somebody give them
this code and they'll be able to watch
that for 30 days so that's what we're
going to do to get back to all of you
this year now of course it's also giving
Tuesday so as part of giving Tuesday we
wanted to Launch
a video every week and this is just for
the general viewing audience a video
every week and we're going to leave it
up all week
for our viewing audience these are our
documentaries what we normally charge
for so what we're trying to do though we
need you guys to help us we need we're
trying to get subscribers now we're
close to 150 but we think hey why not
shoot for the moon we could go for 200
000 subscribers by the end of the year
wouldn't that be incredible so when we
leave these videos up we're just asking
share them and subscribe like crazy so
um I don't remember which one we're oh
yeah I do we're going to start with
Magic Kingdom and as far as I remember
as far as I remember that's going to
start today
to release Magic Kingdom today as part
of giving Tuesday and we're going to
leave it up for a week
but we want subscribers so you know
hopefully you know we'll we'll see where
that goes so anyway
that's what we're doing for giving
Tuesday
um and we'll see we'll see how that goes
you guys will see more about this and
announcements and social media in the
weeks to come but we're going to go
through multiple videos week by week and
Premiere those air those put that out
there for you to share with other people
but if you're a donor you get a special
code and that special code will be able
to be Redeemed by whoever you share it
with
and they can watch it free for 30 days
starting December 1 through the end of
the year so that's our gift to you this
year
um let's see I think after that we are
ready to wrap up this live I mean we've
been going at it all day and you know
eventually people have to go home they
have families and so I want to invite a
few of our friends in here who have been
joining us today just to all sign off
together and say goodbye to you so come
on in everybody they're off camera
eagerly awaiting and some of them have
gone home already they're weary Warriors
and they had things to do places to go
people to see probably mouths to feed
now come on in here Mikey so we got
everybody we're gonna sign off who wants
you you've seen regime yeah my kids are
here you probably haven't seen them on
camera that'd probably be shying away I
don't blame them
um is it a tight shot oh we have to go
outside do I have to uh out do I have to
go down like this is it that tight or am
I out of let me out of frame
way down Okay so
okay so I need to go to the back let me
go to the back tall guys in back okay
[Music]
and we are going to so what I see is
like sign off here to like okay we're
gonna single file
uh probably at the lens we're all gonna
sing a song now no probably not we want
to thank you guys for spending the day
with us and we hope that you were
blessed by something that you saw
something that you heard uh we have a
neat team and we really are appreciative
of each and every individual that is
here you didn't even get a chance to see
everybody that works in this ministry
there is even people back in the back
doing things back there that make this
possible so we yeah shout out to Michael
shout out to Mike Mike is behind the
camera right here so yeah just at least
put your finger in front of the camera
there's his camera all right so we'll
we'll show a picture of him later on and
uh no I'm just kidding
um but thank you guys so much for
enabling us to do what we do we just uh
feel it it's such a privilege to be able
to come to work and to think about
spiritual things constantly and and
actually that's our job that's our daily
job so thank you for that I know there
was one more thing I have the mic
anyway uh one more thing we wanted to
announce is part of this was also a
fundraiser today for giving Tuesday and
you guys have come through with over a
thousand dollars worth of donations
through our website or through YouTube
or through text to give a couple of
people that did that so all that
information is on the screen if you want
to continue to give of course we're not
going to stop you we have a lofty goal
for phase two it's 250 000 and now we're
that much closer so thank you for that
and
um you know I think we discussed
something in the office we were trying
to I know I kind of briefly said
something about releasing a documentary
every week for the next you know so many
weeks but were we only going to leave
those on like for so many subscribers or
did we uh did we decide I think that we
were going we're just gonna get up check
out this video yeah so exactly we'll
work on that those details we'll put it
out there but just look forward to doco
Tuesday we'll be putting some
documentaries out for you starting today
yes right yeah Magic Kingdom all right
so all right love you guys take care
[Music]
hey guys I got a tip for you to really
spice up your YouTube channel with
b-roll at videomission.com this guy I
hope through prophecy he's got 55 000
subscribers and he used one of our Clips
to illustrate the fall of Lucifer and he
used the snake in the Garden of Eden so
if you're looking for footage to
illustrate biblical topics check out
videomission.com
[Music]
thank you
is there any hope for me what can I do
to unify my family on not watching
harmful media how do I know my thoughts
are my own and how can I distinguish
between Impressions from God I'm nervous
when it comes to sharing my testimony it
is really that important I stopped
watching mainstream media now what
sometimes we get a lot of people asking
the same kind of questions so we thought
it would be cool to make these little
videos answering some of them in a new
series called I got a question concise
answers to your media related questions
we'd love to hear from you reach out to
us privately on our Instagram page or
Facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website
littlelightstudios.tv slash contact us
hey we're here to help
we're here to help you let your little
light shine
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to show kindness to the world
foreign
to do something that let someone know
you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need to go out of your way to
help them
every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world
place